law and thanks for your point san
francisco the live feed from the senate
is now available the senate in session
momentarily
foreign
uh
[Music]
so
hmm
the senate will convene as a court of
impeachment the chaplain will offer
prayer
dear god you know what we need before we
ask you
but in the asking our minds and hearts
are prepared to receive your answer
in this impeachment trial
we've learned again that really
listening over a prolonged period of
time
is hard work
often it's difficult to hear what is
said
because of differing convictions
dissonance causes discordant static
sometimes our preconceptions
about what we think will be said
keep us from hearing what is actually
said
thank you for the commitment of the men
and women of this senate
to serve you and our nation
by accepting the demanding
responsibility
of listening for
and evaluating truth
grantham renewed energy
sensitive audio nerves
and discerning minds
for your glory
and for the good of america
amen
amen
[Music]
the sergeant-at-arms will make the
proclamation
hear ye hear ye hear ye
all persons are commanded to keep silent
on pain of imprisonment while the senate
of the united states is sitting for the
trial
of the articles of impeachment exhibited
by the house of representatives against
william jefferson clinton president of
the united states
the chair recognizes the majority leader
thank you mr chief justice
today we'll conclude the presentation of
the white house councils and i
understand that the presentation will
last approximately four and one half
hours
as we've done previously we will take
periodic breaks throughout the
proceedings with the first one coming in
approximately
one hour and 15 minutes i believe that
would be approximately midway
in the presentation of mr council
kendall
and
then we would probably take at least one
more break later on
so that the senators and chief justice
would have a chance to
stretch and so it would have some
logical break in the presentations
as a reminder we will convene tomorrow
at 1 pm to resume consideration of
articles
and at this point i would ask the
indulgence of the chief justice and all
senators as we would take up some
routine matters before we resume
consideration of the articles these have
been pre-cleared i understand
though that i would need to ask
unanimous consent that notwithstanding
the consideration of the articles that
it'd be in order at this time to conduct
several routine legislative matters
is there objection
without objection is so ordered mr chief
justice there are three bills at the
desk and i would like to ask that bills
be considered as read a third time i
further asked the bills be read a second
time in block and
would object to my own request
is there objection
without objection is so ordered
then the bills would be read a second
time on the next legislative day as i
understand it
the leader is correct
mr chief justice i ask unanimous consent
that the senate proceed to the immediate
consideration of s res 28 which would
change the words handicapped individuals
to individuals with disabilities in rule
25 i further ask consent the resolution
be agreed to and the motion be to
reconsider be laid upon the table
is there objection
without objection it's so ordered
then that concludes our regular business
i believe that we are prepared for the
concluding presentation by the white
house council and i yield the floor mr
chief justice
if there's no objection the journal of
proceedings of the trial are approved to
date pursuant to the provisions of
senate rule 16 resolution 16 the council
for the president have 18 hours and nine
minutes remaining to make the
presentation of their case the senate
will now hear you the presiding officer
recognizes mr counsel kendall
mr chief justice
members of the senate
managers from the house of
representatives
good afternoon
i'm david kendall
of the law firm of williams and conley
and since 1993
it has been my privilege to represent
the president
in the tortuous and meandering
whitewater investigation
which approximately a year ago
was transformed in a remarkable way
into
the lewinsky investigation
i want to address this morning this
afternoon
certain
allegations of obstruction of justice
contained in article
two
of the articles of impeachment
mr manager sensenbrenner
uh remarked that
no prior article
alleging of obstruction of justice has
ever been has ever reached this chamber
so this is a case of first impression
uh deputy council cheryl mills
yesterday
addressed the
parts of article 2
pertaining to gifts and the president's
conversations with miss curry
and i will cover this afternoon the
remaining five subparts of article two
the evidence plainly shows
that the president did not obstruct
justice in any way and there is nothing
in this article which would warrant his
removal from office
as i begin i want to thank you for
your open minds
for your attention
for your withholding judgment
until you've heard all of our
evidentiary presentation
there are a lot of myths
about what the evidence is in this case
some of them
are misunderstandings based upon
erroneous media reports
some spring from confusion in the
evidence itself
and some are the result of
concerted
partisan distortion
i want to talk to you this afternoon
about what the record is
and what the evidence actually shows and
i apologize to you in advance if the
process is tedious
what i think i've got to request from
you
is your common sense and some uncommon
patience but the evidence those stubborn
facts are critically important
to inform your ultimate vote on these
articles
i'll do my best to avoid
repetition
and lawyer talk although i am a lawyer
in our trial memorandum we gave you the
citations to the evidence i'm going to
be referencing so you can check
the facts there i want to say that i
welcome your scrutiny
my presentation this morning consists of
six parts and i'd like if i could to
give you those as milestones
i want to make some remarks generally
about evidence
and then i want to consider the specific
evidence which is relevant to each of
the five subparts i'm going to be
talking about
i'm going to do them out of numerical
order but what i hope is in a logical
order i'm going to cover article one
first
then article two
uh then article five
article seven and article four
miss mills yesterday has already covered
three and six
first of all
a few words about evidence
we've heard a great deal about the rule
of law
in the various presentations of the
house managers
but what's at issue here
and i think mr manager graham
made this point very well is a solemn
obligation
which is constitutionally
committed to this body
your decision whatever it is is not
going to have some kind of domino effect
that ineluctably
leads to that midnight knock at the door
the rule of law is more than rhetoric
it means that in proceedings like these
where important rights are being
adjudicated
that evidence matters
fairness matters
rules of procedural regularity matter
the presumption of innocence matters
and proportionality
matters
the rule of law is not the monopoly of
the house managers
and it ought to be practiced in these
proceedings as well as talked about in
speeches
we've heard a lot of
pejorative rhetoric about legal hair
splitting
that the president
and his legal team have engaged in and
as a member of that legal team i paid
attention to that rhetoric
but as i sat there listening to the
various presentations
they struck me as somewhat odd because
one of the hallmarks of the rule of law
is careful procedures and explicit laws
which try to define rights for every
citizen
it's not legal hair splitting to raise
available defenses
or to point out gaps in the evidence
or to make legal arguments based upon
precedent however technical and
politically unpopular some of those
arguments may be and i think it's
particularly important in a proceeding
like this where the charge is an
accusation of crime and mr
manager mccollum was quite explicit
in his argument that the first thing you
have to determine here is whether the
president committed any crimes
i'm going to try and focus on the facts
and the evidence
concerning obstruction of justice i
don't think there is a need for me to go
in to the law
we've set forth the relevant legal
principles in our trial memorandum
uh
mr ruff and miss mills
very ably covered some of the governing
principles and ms mills played some
videotape excerpts of experts so i don't
think there's any need for me to
rehearse that here indeed our primary
disagreement
with the very able house managers
concerns the evidence
and what it shows
now in december
the
judiciary committee
of the house of representatives reported
four articles of impeachment to the
floor
two of those
one involving or one alleging
perjury in the president's january 17
1998 deposition in the paula jones case
and one alleging abuse of power
were specifically considered
by the house and just as specifically
rejected
although the house managers have very
very cleverly attempted to weave into
their discussion of the two articles
that were
adopted some of the rejected allegations
now
on the chart
article 2 alleges that the president has
in some way
impeded or covered up
the existence of evidence relevant to
the paula jones case that's the whole
focus of this article
it focuses on alleged impact on the
paula jones case it's important because
when we get to subpart 7 we'll see that
there is no way the allegations there
could be a part of this article or
impact the paula jones case
the president supposedly accomplished
this
obstruction of justice
through
and here i quote
one or more of the following acts
now here i think i should observe
that this
one or more menu
as it were
is plainly defective
in a constitutional sense because as
we've pointed out in our answer and our
trial memorandum and as mr ruff has made
clear in his presentation such a format
makes it impossible
to assure the constitutionally required
two-thirds of senators voting
concur on any particular ground that is
alleged since the senate's rules provide
that you can't split up
this menu you've got to cover all seven
allegations together it would be
possible for the president to be
convicted without that requisite
two-thirds majority because you might
get uh
nine or ten votes in favor of the
article based on each of the seven
different grounds
constitution of course gives the house
of representatives the sole power of
impeachment and it's exercised that
power to adopt article two
however several of the allegations about
what the president did
to obstruct justice supposedly
in the house manager's presentation are
nowhere contained in these seven
subparts they're simply not there for
example you heard repeatedly
about the president's use in his
deposition of the term alone was he ever
alone with miss lewinsky and the
managers claimed that that somehow
obstructed justice
uh the allegation that this consisted of
an impeachable offense however was
rejected when the house of
representatives voted down
the one of the four articles alleging
deposition perjury you've also heard
reference to the president's
allegedly false and misleading answers
to the 81 interrogatories
sent to the president in november
by the house judiciary committee again
an article based upon those
interrogatory answers was voted down in
the house of representatives
i'd like you to bear in mind
an image which mr manager hutchinson
and council ruff
shared in some way you'll see that they
didn't share it entirely mr manager
hutcheson referred to the seven pillars
of obstruction
uh mr
white house counsel ruff
referred to
the seven shifting sand castles of
speculation
won't surprise you that i agree with
mr ruff's characterization but the
important point is that there are seven
grounds in this article there are not
eight there are not 19 there are not
seven there are seven charges that's
what the house
enacted and that's what we're going to
address and rebut
before considering the five articles the
five subparts of article two that i'm
going to be addressing
uh i'd like to say
a few words about the different kinds of
evidence that you're going to have to
consider
there is first direct evidence
now this is the most probative kind of
evidence because it's the least
ambiguous
it comes directly from the five senses
of the witness and for example when the
witness testifies about something the
witness did
that is direct evidence from
the house managers very skillful
presentation you would not be aware
of the large amount of direct evidence
which is in the record
which refutes
and contradicts the allegations
obstruction of justice i'm going to
cover that in detail this afternoon
the second kind of evidence
is what the law calls
circumstantial and this describes any
evidence which is probative only if a
certain conclusion or inference
is drawn from the evidence
circumstantial evidence is admissible
but by definition it is to some degree
ambiguous because it's not direct
its probative power or its value
depends upon the strength of the
inference you can logically draw from it
let me give you an example
you walk out of your house in the
morning
and you see the sidewalk is completely
wet
now
you might conclude that it had rain
the night before and you might be
reasonably confident in that conclusion
however
were your sharp eyes to focus further
and observe your neighbor's sprinkler
sitting right by the sidewalk dripping
from the sprinkler head you might want
to revise your conclusion
circumstantial evidence is often subject
to several different interpretations
and for this reason it's got to be
viewed very carefully
as one court has stated
circumstantial evidence presents a
danger
that the trier of fact may leap logical
gaps in the proof offered
and draw unwarranted conclusions
based on probabilities of low degree
if a criminal charge
is to be based on conclusions drawn from
circumstantial evidence
rather than on direct evidence those
conclusions have got to be virtually
unavoidable
most of the obstruction case presented
and they have recognized this and mr
manager hutchinson rep recognized it on
sunday is based on
circumstantial evidence and that
evidence is as at best profoundly
ambiguous
they told you
that they had painted a picture
with circumstantial evidence
i think what they've in fact done
is given you a rorschach test
[Applause]
i'd like to now turn
to the five subparts
of article 2 which i intend to cover
and i want to describe as to each
the relevant direct evidence in the
record
the circumstantial evidence
and the portions of the manager's
presentation which do not in fact
constitute either kind of evidence but
in fact represent
speculation
theorizing
and hypothesis
what i believe you will find is that the
direct evidence disproves the charges of
obstruction
and the managers have had to rely
on contradictory and unpersuasive
circumstantial evidence to try to make
their case
subpart one
of article two
alleges that
the president
encouraged
ms lewinsky
to execute an affidavit in the paula
jones case that he knew to be
perjurious false and misleading
uh the house managers allege that during
a
december 17 telephone conversation
ms lewinsky asked the president
what she could do
if she were subpoenaed in the jones case
and the president responded well
maybe you could sign an affidavit
and that's a statement the president
does not dispute making
it's hard to believe
but this statement of the president to
ms lewinsky
advising her of the possibility of
totally lawful conduct
is the house manager's entire
factual basis
for supporting the first allegation in
subpart one
the managers don't claim
that the president
advised her to file a false affidavit
that's not what subpart one alleges
and there's no evidence in the record
anywhere to support such an allegation
nor did the managers allege he even
told her advised her urged her or
suggested to her what to put in to her
affidavit
the
charge which the managers have spun out
of this single statement by the
president
is refuted by the direct evidence
first of all
ms lewinsky has repeatedly
and forcefully denied any and all
suggestions
that the president ever asked her to lie
in her proffer
and a proffer of course is an offer made
to a prosecutor to try and get immunity
she made one in her own handwriting on
february the 1st 1998
and she stated explicitly
that neither the president
nor anyone on his behalf
ever told
ever
ask or encourage ms lewinsky
to lie
in an fbi interview conducted on july
27th
she made two similar statements and you
see them up here on the chart neither
the president or jordan
ever told lewinsky that she had to lie
neither the president nor anyone ever
directed lewinsky to say anything or to
lie
and it was the fbi agent who transcribed
those two comments
now i'd like to focus on the fact that
she told the fbi the president never
directed her to say anything
or to lie
i think that is particularly telling
as direct evidence
in the context of this allegation that
the president supposedly urged her to
file an affidavit that he knew would be
false
finally
in ms lewinsky's
august the 20th
grand jury testimony
she stated and she had to volunteer to
do it
no one ever asked me to lie
and i was never promised a job for my
silence
no one ever asked me to lie
and i was never promised a job for my
silence
is there something difficult to
understand here
it's interesting to see how the house
managers try to establish that somehow
the president asked ms lewinsky to file
a false affidavit but their argument
essentially begs the question they argue
that the president in fact somehow
encouraged her to lie because both
parties knew the affidavit would have to
be false and misleading to accomplish
the desired result
but again there's no evidence to support
this conjecture and in fact the opposite
is true
both ms lewinsky and the president have
testified repeatedly
that given the particular claims being
made in the jones case
they both honestly believed
that a truthful albeit limited affidavit
might
might
establish that ms lewinsky had nothing
relevant to offer in the way of
testimony in the jones case
the president explained in his grand
jury testimony on at least five
occasions
in response to the prosecutor's
questions
that he believed
miss lewinsky could execute
a truthful but limited affidavit that
would have established there was no
basis for calling her as a witness to
testify in the jones case
for example
president told the grand jury
but i'm just telling you that it's
certainly true what she says here that
we didn't have there was no employment
no benefit in exchange there was nothing
having to do with sexual harassment and
if she defined
sexual relationship in the way i think
most americans do
then she told the truth
or again
the president told the grand jury i've
already told you that i felt strongly
that she could issue that she could
execute an affidavit that would be
factually truthful that might get her
out of having to testify
and did i hope she'd be able to get out
of testifying on an affidavit absolutely
did i want her to execute a false
affidavit no i did not
it's important to bear in mind
that the paula jones case was a sexual
harassment case
although it turned out to be legally
groundless
and it involved allegations of
non-consensual
sexual solicitation
ms lewinsky's relationship to the
president had been consensual
she knew nothing whatsoever about the
allegations in the jones case
there's no evidence in the record that
she'd ever been in arkansas in her life
and in any event the jones case arose
out of factual allegations dating from
may of 1991 when the president was
governor of arkansas long before ms
lewinsky had even met the president
now it's not simply the president
who believed
that in the circumstances here ms
lewinsky could have filed an affidavit
which could have been truthful and which
might have gotten her released from
testifying in a jones case deposition ms
lewinsky also has testified that she
might have been able to file a truthful
affidavit which have accomplished that
purpose
for example
she told the fbi in an interview after
she obtained immunity on july 29 that
she had told linda tripp
that the purpose of an affidavit
was to avoid being deposed and that she
thought one could do this by giving only
a portion of the whole story so that
jones lawyers would not think the person
giving the affidavit had anything of
relevance to their case
again in the same interview with the fbi
ms lewinsky stated
that the goal of such an affidavit was
to be as benign as possible so as to
avoid being
deposed again in her grand jury
testimony on august 6th ms lewinsky
testified that i thought that signing an
affidavit could range from anywhere the
point of it would be to deter or to
prevent me from being deposed and so
that there could range from anywhere
between maybe just
something somehow mentioning you know
innocuous things
it's not disputed
that the president showed no interest in
viewing a draft of ms lewinsky's
affidavit did not review it
and according to ms lewinsky said he did
not need to see it
this
fact is obviously exculpatory
if the president were truly concerned
about what was going in to ms lewinsky's
affidavit surely he would have wanted to
review it prior to its summation
now to counter this inference
the house managers offer speculation
mr manager
mccollum
tried to downplay the significance of
this fact by asking you to engage in
sheer surmise
he said on friday
i doubt seriously the president was
talking about 15 other affidavits that
he'd supposedly seen of someone else and
didn't like looking at affidavits
anymore
i suspect and i would suggest to you he
was talking about 15 other drafts of
this proposed affidavit since it had
been around the horn a lot of rounds
well
as the able house manager himself stated
this suggestion is mere suspicion
speculation
it flies in the face of miss lewinsky's
direct testimony there's evidence of
only a few drafts and there's no
evidence that the president ever saw any
draft
now ms lewinsky was under no obligation
to volunteer
to the paula jones lawyers
every
last detail
about her relationship with the
president
and the fact that the president did not
advise her
or instructor to do so
is neither wrong nor an obstruction of
justice
the fact is that a limited
truthful affidavit might
have established that ms lewinsky's
testimony was simply not relevant to the
jones case
the president knew
and had told ms lewinsky
that a great many other women he knew
who had been subpoenaed by the paula
jones lawyers
had tried to avoid
and tried to avoid
the burden
the expense and the humiliation of a
deposition by filing an affidavit in
support of a motion to quash the
deposition subpoena and by arguing in
the affidavit that the subpoenaed woman
had no relevant evidence for the jones
case
the jones lawyers were casting a very
wide net for evidence that they could
use to embarrass the president
the discovery cut off in the case was
fast approaching that's the point which
you can't take any more discovery
and there was some chance both ms
and the president felt that she could
escape
deposition through
an accurate but limited affidavit
moreover
there is significant evidence
in the record
that at the time she executed her
affidavit
miss lewinsky honestly could believe
honestly believe that she could deny a
sexual relationship given what she
believed to be the definition of that
term
uh in an audiotape conversation which
linda tripp
uh secretly recorded
miss lewinsky declared i never even came
close to sleeping with the president we
didn't have sex
again i would remind you of mr
craig's
presentation yesterday concerning ms
lewinsky's understanding of the term
sexual relations which was the same as
the president's
now there's another part of the
chronology here and a circumstantial
evidence case often rests heavily on
chronology
that the house managers simply ignore
in their attempt to fit some of the
facts into a sinister pattern
miss lewinsky's name appeared on the
paula jones witness list
which the managers tell us accurately
the president's lawyers reviewed with
him on saturday december 6th
she was one of a great many people named
on the witness list
now if the president's concern
was so intense
about the appearance of her name on the
list
would he have waited
until
december 17th
to talk to her
there's no explanation for this delay
which is consistent with intense concern
on
the president's part except that her
appearance with a lot of others
was not particularly troubling to him
the main reason for his phone call
on december 17th to ms lewinsky uh the
unrebed the the unrebutted evidence
shows is that he wanted to tell
miss lewinsky that betty curry's brother
had died indeed uh three days after that
telephone call ms lewinsky attended
the funeral of miss curry's brother on
december the 20th
now insofar as you want to draw analogy
or if you draw inferences from
the
chronology of events in december
this long delay
is circumstantial evidence that the
president felt no particular urgency
either to alert ms lewinsky that her
name was on the witness list or make any
suggestions to her about an affidavit
remember her repeated testimony which is
direct evidence
no one ever asked her to lie
now
subpart two
of article 2
alleges that the president obstructed
justice
by encouraging ms lewinsky in that same
late night telephone call two of these
articles rest on the same telephone call
to give perjurious false and misleading
testimony if and when she was called to
testify personally in the jones
litigation
now it was interesting to me that a
couple of days ago
the house managers released a
response to our presentation
and they concede here
that
the president miss lewinsky did not
discuss
the deposition that evening of december
17th because monica they call her monica
had not been subpoenaed
well that's true
there was no
deposition subpoena received by ms
lewinsky until two days later
now the lawyers in the room know
something about what witness lists are
and what they contain
that the civilian part of the world may
not know
as lawyers get ready to go to trial and
the judge requires them to put their
witnesses on the witness list you put
every witness you can think of who might
conceivably be relevant
from mr aardvark to ms zanzibar
all of them go on the witness list
and that's what had happened here wasn't
until you get something like a a
subpoena for a deposition that you know
a witness is really going to be a
significant player in the trial
well let's look at the allegations here
and remember these allegations focus on
december 17th two days before ms
lewinsky is going to receive her
subpoena
i think you logically begin with the
direct evidence and the direct evidence
is the testimony of the two people
involved in the telephone conversation
ms lewinsky and the president
ms lewinsky has repeatedly stated that
no one ever urged her to lie
and that
this plainly applies to this december
17th
conversation
she said in her handwritten proper that
i had on the chart earlier that the
president did not ask her or encourage
her to lie
she made that statement when talking to
the independent council when her fate
was in the hands of the independent
council when her immunity agreement
could be
broken and she could be prosecuted she's
nevertheless continued to maintain that
nobody
asked her ever to lie she said in the
july 27 fbi interview neither the
president or nor mr jordan ever told her
she had to lie and she said that in her
grand jury testimony
it's interesting to hear
all the ways that the house managers and
they are very skillful try to minimize
the importance of this direct evidence
you'd think ms lewinsky's statements
under oath were irrelevant to this case
she gave this testimony
for the most part when she was subject
to prosecution
for perjury it simply cannot be blandly
dismissed
because it was given under
this threat indeed
mr manager hutchison and i'd like to
quote him
shares this same belief with me he told
you standing right here
that ms lewinsky's testimony is credible
and she has the motive to tell the truth
because of her immunity agreement with
the independent council where she gets
in trouble only if she lies
likewise the president
has
consistently
insisted he never asked ms lewinsky to
lie in his grand jury testimony last
august
he said that he and ms lewinsky might
have talked about what to do in a
non-legal context
at some point in the past if anybody
inquired about their relationship
although he had no specific memory of
such a conversation and he testified
that they did not talk
about this in connection with ms
lewinsky's testimony in the jones case
he was asked by one of the prosecutors
and in that conversation on december
17th or in any conversation in which you
informed her she was on the witness list
did you tell her you know you can always
say that you were coming to see betty or
bringing me letters did you tell her
anything like that
the president
i don't remember she was coming to see
betty i can tell you that i absolutely
never asked her to lie
there is thus no direct
testimony from anybody
that on december 17
the president asked ms lewinsky to lie
if called to testify in the jones case
here the house managers don't really
even rely on circumstantial evidence to
refute the direct testimony of the two
relevant witnesses they rely instead on
what they assert is logic
they claim that while the president
maybe didn't specifically tell her to
lie he somehow suggested that she give a
false account of their relationship
what you should infer according to them
is based upon what they may have said
about their relation
at other times previous times
to this late night december 17 phone
call
the president somehow suggested that she
say the same thing at her deposition
something like you know you can always
say you were coming to see betty or that
you were bringing me letters
their claim boils down however
to the inferences to be drawn from the
uncontested facts that in the past
before this time before this
december 17 phone call
the president and ms lewinsky had had
discussions about what she should say if
asked about her visits to the oval
office
both have acknowledged that
uh not surprisingly at the time these
conversations occurred
they were both concerned to conceal
their improper relationship
from others while it was going on
cover stories
are an almost inevitable part
of every improper relationship between
two human beings
by its very nature
the relationship is one that has to be
concealed
and therefore misleading cover stories
inevitably accompany that relationship
now to say that is not to excuse it
or to exonerate it
or justify it
but rather to emphasize that the
testimony about visiting betty
or bringing me letters is in the record
but it's not linked in any way to the
december 17th phone call or to any
testimony or affidavit with regard to
the jones case
here again i want to go to the direct
evidence that's relevant on count
two
because it undercuts the manager's
suggestion that
this discussion of the cover stories
actually occurred
in the context of a discussion about the
paula jones case
now
here on our chart we have a blow up of
ms lewinsky's part of ms lewinsky's
handwritten proffer to the independent
council on
february the first
which makes it clear that she does
recall having a discussion with the
president
in which
he said
that if anyone questioned her about
visiting him
she should say she was either bringing
him letters or visiting betty curry but
ms lewinsky states
there is truth to both of these
statements
was a cover story but there was some
truth in it
she also went out of her way
in this proffer
to emphasize
that while she did not recall precisely
when
the discussions about cover stories
occurred
they occurred prior to the subpoena in
the paula jones case that's what you see
in her paragraph 11.
her paragraph 11 refers back to
paragraph two
and her point is that while she and the
president did have these discussions it
was not in the context of her testimony
uh in paragraph four
also
uh as you see from the chart or from
your handout
uh as to the contents
of any possible testimony ms lewinsky
wrote that to the best of her
recollection she did not believe she
discussed the content of any deposition
during the december 17 conversation with
the president
now in an fbi interview
on july the 31st
after she had received immunity from the
independent council
the fbi agent noted
what ms lewinsky had told him
lewinsky advised
though they did not discuss the issue in
specific relationship to the jones
matter
she and clinton had discussed what to
say when asked about lewinsky's visits
to the white house
this is direct evidence nobody denies
that there was a discussion of cover
stories early in the relation but there
is no evidence that it occurred in
connection in any way with the jones
case
now
again despite
ms lewinsky's direct
and unrefuted testimony about the
december 17 telephone call
the house managers ask you to conclude
that the president must have asked her
to testify falsely because she had by
her own account on prior occasions
assured the president that she would
deny their relationship
think for a moment about that
they ask you to accept
their speculation
in the face of contradictory evidence
from both parties
and use that as a basis on which to
remove the president
again ms lewinsky never stated that she
told the president anything about
denying their relationship on december
17
or at any other time when she'd been
identified as a witness
indeed she testified
in the grand jury that that discussion
did not take place after she'd learned
she was a witness in the jones case and
again we have her grand jury testimony
displayed on the chart a grand juror is
asking her questions
question
is it possible
that you also had these discussions
about cover stories or denying the
relationship
after you learned that you were witness
in the paula jones case
ms lewinsky i don't believe so
juror
and these jurors were very good at
questioning witnesses throughout this
proceeding
can you exclude that possibility
ms lewinsky i pretty much can
i really
don't remember it
direct testimony
given when miss lewinsky was covered by
an immunity agreement that could only be
divested by her perjuring herself
there's another thing which i think is
relevant here and that is that ms
lewinsky has stated several times that
while these were cover stories
they were not untrue
in her handwritten proffer as you've
seen
she stated that
she asked the president what to say if
anyone asked her about her visits and he
said you could mention betty curry or
bringing me
letters
and she added that there was truth
to both of these statements and that
neither of those statements was untrue
indeed she testified
to the grand jury that she did in fact
bring papers to the president and then
on some occasions she visited the oval
office only to see miss curry
question the grand jury did you actually
bring the president papers at all yes
all right tell us a little about that it
varied sometimes it was just actual
copies of letters
and again in her august 6 1998 grand
jury appearance ms lewinsky testified i
saw betty on every time that i was there
most of the time my purpose was to see
the president but there were some times
when i did just go see betty
but the president wasn't in the office
ms lewinsky and miss curry were friends
and they did have a separate social
relationship
now the managers assert that these
stories were misleading
and the house committee report
on the articles of impeachment declared
that these stories about miss curry and
delivering papers was a ruse that had no
legitimate business purpose in other
words while the so-called
stories
were literally true the explanations
might have been misleading but the
literal truth here while it may appear
legalistic and hair splitting
is in fact a defense to both the perjury
and the obstruction justice charges
under the rule of law
while the president and miss curry and
ms lewinsky had discussed cover stories
while their improper relationship was in
progress there is simply no evidence
that they discussed this at any time
when
ms lewinsky was a witness in the jones
case
the next subpart
i want to consider is subpart 5.
subpart 5 alleges that at the deposition
the president allowed his attorney to
make false and misleading statements
to a federal judge
characterizing an affidavit in order to
prevent questioning
deemed relevant by the judge
it alleges obstruction solely because
the president did not
say anything
when his attorney mr bennett cited ms
lewinsky's
affidavit in an unsuccessful argument to
judge wright that evidence concerning ms
lewinsky should not be admitted at that
point because it was irrelevant to the
jones case
at one point mr bennett the president's
lawyer states that according to the
affidavit there's no sex of any kind in
any manner shape or form
now this
claim
which
also is presented in the perjury section
as mr craig pointed out is deficient as
an allegation of obstruction both as a
matter of fact and as a matter of law
but i will say one thing the direct
evidence on this
point
is uniquely available because there is
only one witness who can testify about
what was in his thoughts at a given
moment and the president has testified
at great length in his grand jury
testimony about what he was thinking at
this point
the president told the grand jury
that he was simply not focusing closely
on the exchange between the lawyers but
was instead concentrating on his own
testimony
he said i'm not even sure i paid much
attention to what he mr bennett was
saying i was thinking i was ready to get
on with my testimony here and they were
having these constant discussions all
through
i was worried about my own testimony
and i think mr craig
provided you with a background yesterday
that i won't repeat here but i would
refer you to about what was on the
president's mind at the time
now mr manager
mccollum made a very
polished and articulate presentation to
you
and he predicted that the president's
lawyers were going to argue that the
president sat in silence because he
wasn't paying attention
and we have indeed argued this and it is
the truth based upon what the president
has testified he was thinking about but
mr mccollum went on to argue that there
was circumstantial evidence available
from the videotape of the president at
this deposition
he stated
i quote him
we've already seen the video
and you know that he was looking so
intently remember he was intently
following the conversation with his eyes
i don't know how anybody can say this
man wasn't paying attention he certainly
wasn't thinking about anything else that
was very obvious from looking at the
video
well
we all saw the video during the house
manager's presentations and we saw a lot
of the president at the deposition
yesterday when mr craig played the first
part of it
if you
observe the president
throughout the time you've seen him on
the video in the deposition
you will conclude that the look on his
face was no different from when it was
during other discussions or arguments of
counsel about evidentiary or procedural
matters
the videotape does not fairly considered
indicate that the president was in fact
focusing on the lengthy colloquy among
his lawyers or that he knowingly made a
decision not to correct his own lawyer
now the president has received a great
deal of criticism
because at one point in his grand jury
testimony
when asked about
mr bennett's statement
the president responds to the prosecutor
that whether mr bennett's statement is
true
depends on what the meaning of the word
is is that is there's no sex of any kind
that's gotten its share of laughs
but when you read the president's grand
jury transcript
in context
this was a serious matter and it's
apparent that the president was not in
any way describing what was in his own
mind at the time of the deposition but
he's rather discussing mr bennett's
statement from the vantage point of the
president's later grand jury testimony
he's interpreting what his own lawyer
was saying mr craig pointed this out
yesterday
that
interpretation was not perjury in
article 1
and it's not obstruction of justice in
article 2.
what the exchange was
was that the president in response to
one of the prosecutors
explains why on one reading mr bennett's
statement may not be false
now it may be hair splitting
and it may be professorial and it may be
technical but the important thing is
it's a retrospective assessment the
president is not talking about himself
he's talking about how to construe mr
bennett's statement and what he says is
there is a way
in which mr bennett's statement at the
deposition is accurate
that is if mr bennett was referring to
the relationship between the president
and ms lewinsky on that date it was an
accurate statement because the improper
relationship was over a long time
earlier
now the relevant point here
is
that the president's
disquisition
on the word is and its meaning was not
an attempt to explain his own thinking
at the time of the deposition but was
rather his later interpretation of what
mr bennett had said at the deposition
in light of the president's direct
unequivocal testimony
this speculation about what was in his
mind is simply baseless and there is in
fact
no
evidence to support
the charge leveled in subpart 5 of
article 2.
there's another reason to reject the
charge
and that is that the law imposes no
obligation on the client
to monitor his or her lawyers every
statement and representation
particularly in a civil deposition
in which the client is being questioned
clients are routinely advised to focus
on the questions posed think carefully
about the answer answer only the
question asked and ignore distractions
and sometimes sad to say
the statements of one's own lawyer can
be a distraction and those of you who
are lawyers and have defended uh people
in depositions know that that's the
advice you give the client
uh
there was good reason
for the president to be thinking about
his own testimony
and leave the legal fencing to the
lawyers because whatever else may be
said about it there can be no doubt that
the jones case itself
was a vehicle for partisan attack
uh on the president and that he was
going to be facing a series of hostile
and difficult questions at the
deposition
now judge wright ultimately ruled
that giving miss jones every benefit of
the doubt
she'd failed both legally and factually
to present allegations that merited
going to trial
but while it was legally meritless while
it was going on the case did impose a
significant toll on the president both
personally and politically
and let's be clear about one other thing
while we're looking at this deposition
and while you review the significance of
the president listening in silence to mr
bennett's conduct as mr craig described
yesterday
judge wright in fact interrupted
mr bennett
in mid-sentence as he was describing
miss jones affidavit she didn't allow
him to complete his objection
in which he cited the lewinsky affidavit
she quickly interjected
this is sometimes what judges do to the
most learned of lawyers
she quickly interjected and said no just
a moment
let me make my ruling and then she
proceeded to allow the very line of
questioning that mr bennett was trying
to prevent so the president's silence
whatever motivated it had absolutely no
impact
on the conduct of the jones deposition
and also let's be clear about one other
thing
nothing
about this interchange between mr
bennett and judge wright blocked the
ability of the jones lawyers to obtain
information about the president's
relationship with miss lewinsky because
the jones lawyers had been briefed the
night before
in great detail
by miss linda tripp
miss tripp had already gotten her own
immunity agreement from the office of
independent council
and had set up a lunch with miss
lewinsky at the ritz-carlton hotel the
day before the deposition
friday january 16th
and at that lunch of course miss
lewinsky was apprehended by the office
of independent council and held for the
next 12 hours in the meantime however
miss tripp
goes back to her home where she meets
with the jones lawyers that friday night
before the deposition and loads them up
with all the information she has
obtained from her illegal
secret
audio taping of miss lewinsky
that's why they were able to ask the
questions they did with such specificity
and conviction indeed
there is one point
in the examination of the president
where he says
to the jones lawyer who's examining mr
fischer
he asks a question
and fisher says sir
i think this will come he asked a
question about
can you tell me why you're asking these
specific questions and fisher replies
sir i think this will come to light
shortly and you'll understand
well
it's ironic that
i'm making a presentation today on july
the 21st because it did come to light
just as mr fisher knew it would just as
miss tripp knew it would it came to
light
one year ago exactly when the story
broke in the washington post
this fleeting exchange
between
mr bennett and judge wright
before she overruled his objection
couldn't and didn't have any impact on
the jones lawyer's conduct
now i want to look briefly at one other
part of
subpart five because it alleges it
continues to to make one other
allegation such false and misleading
statements
at the deposition by mr bennett
allegedly were subsequently acknowledged
by mr bennett in a communication with
the judge
now if you look at mr bennett's letter
however
that's not at all what the letter says
mr bennett wrote to the judge
on september the 30th
of last year this is after the referral
had come to congress and after the house
of representatives had seen fit to
release miss lewinsky's grand jury
testimony
uh mr bennett does not as the article
allege
acknowledge that he himself made false
and misleading statements or that the
president
either by his words or silence made such
statements
what mr bennett does do in this letter
as you can see
is call the court's attention to the
fact that ms lewinsky herself
had testified before a federal grand
jury in august
and contrary to her to her earlier
statements she stated that portions of
her affidavit were according to her
faults and misleading
mr bennett's letter
bringing this to the judge's attention
was a matter of professional obligation
and responsibility it in no way is
evidence supporting
subpart five
could i take a break
mr chief justice um is mr kendall
indicating that he's about halfway
through his presidency
um i've been asked that we have a
temporary recess for
15 minutes
without objection it's so ordered
[Music]
anytime
thanks richmond guntersville alabama
good afternoon good afternoon i would
just like to say that i love bill
clinton i love him as a person he has
charisma alabama
the senate will be in order the chair
recognizes the majority leader mr chief
justice i believe that the senate is
ready to proceed now with the
presentation uh by mr council kendall
the chair recognized mr council kendall
thank you mr chief justice
subpart seven
we have two more
subparts to go i want to take them out
of order subpart seven
uh of article two alleges that the
president obstructed justice
when he relayed
told certain white house
officials things about his relationship
with ms lewinsky
that were false and misleading
now this is another example of
double billing
in the two articles uh this charge is
leveled in
uh article one and it appears here in
article 2.
yesterday mr craig explained why
these statements didn't constitute
perjury and i'd like to take just a few
minutes this afternoon to explain why
they don't constitute an obstruction of
justice either
first of all and most obviously
there is no way i said this in the
beginning there's no way
that the statements of the aids could be
in any way part of a scheme to deny miss
jones evidence
i think on this ground alone subpart 7
fails because if you look at what is
alleged in article two
it is that the president obstructed
justice
in order to delay impede etc
existence of evidence and testimony
related to ms jones lawsuit
there's no way here
that whatever the president said to his
aides
could have done that
uh the statements which this
subpart 7 addresses
were statements that the president made
very shortly after
the uh
uh
paula jones or the lewinsky publicity
had broken uh to mr bowles
mr podesta
mr blumenthal and mr ickes none of whom
were witnesses in the paula jones case
they were on none of the witness lists
and they had no evidence at all relevant
to the paula jones case since they've
been working for the president
they weren't working for the president
when he was governor of
arkansas in may of 1991 and since they
weren't individuals subject to discovery
so these four aides
just had no evidence whatsoever that
they could contribute to the paula jones
case
but there is another more fundamental
reason
why this article is flawed as a matter
both of the evidence and the
law the president has admitted
misleading his family his staff and the
nation
about his conduct with ms lewinsky
and he has expressed profound regret for
that conduct
subpart 7 however
alleges that he should be impeached and
removed for office
simply because he failed to be candid
with these particular four
white house aides and misled them
about the nature of his relationship
with ms lewinsky
now these allegedly impeachable denials
to the four aides occurred as i said
right after the publicity broke indeed
one of them occurred on january the 21st
last year uh and then also on the 23rd
and the 26th
this was at the very time
the president was denying he'd had
sexual relations with miss lewinsky in
nearly identical terms on national
television to whoever across the united
states
happened to be watching at that time now
having made this denial
to the entire country
it's simply absurd to regard it any
differently when made to four aids in
the white house directly and person to
person rather than through the medium of
television
the president talked to these
individuals about the lewinsky matter
because of his personal relationship and
his direct professional exposure to them
on a daily basis
he spoke to them however misleadingly
in an attempt to allay their concerns
once the allegations
about miss lewinsky became public
now no discovery here we haven't yet
found a place in which discovery would
would benefit the case for either side
but no discovery here
is going to illuminate the record in any
way these four witnesses have testified
before the independent council's grand
jury on several occasions
uh i think it's important to observe
also
that there is no way
this interchange between the president
and his aides could have affected
evidence because his statements to them
were hearsay which they would have
reported accurately to the grand jury
when asked and by hearsay
all they could testify to is what the
president told them and they could do
that accurately but their own testimony
based on whatever knowledge or
observation or direct sensory
evidence they might have was not
affected in any way by the president's
statements
none of these aides had any independent
knowledge of the relationship between
the president and ms lewinsky and
therefore the only evidence they could
offer would be a hearsay repetition of
what the president had told them and
that was the same public denial that he
had told
everyone including presumably any member
of the grand jury who had his or her
television set on that monday january
26th but under this strained theory
and you really have to focus on this
under this theory any citizen of the
united states who heard that denial
could form the basis for an allegation
of impeachable conduct and removal of
the president from office i think this
subpart of article 7 fails for a number
of reasons it's not related to paul
jones case and it violates common sense
let me turn to subpart 4.
this subpart
alleges that the president
obstructed justice
when he
intensified and succeeded in an effort
to secure job assistance
to ms lewinsky
in order to corruptly prevent her
truthful testimony
the claim here is of a quid pro quo this
for that
this job assistance was allegedly in
order to prevent her truthful testimony
now
i want to note a couple of things here
first of all
this word intensified
this word intensified is a pretty
slippery word
it doesn't say originated or began it
says intensified
and that allegation implicitly
recognizes it tries to avoid the thrust
of its own logic it recognizes that the
job search miss lewinsky was conducting
had begun long before there was any
connection to the paul jones case and
the undisputed facts are going to reveal
that vernon jordan and others were
trying to help her long before she
appeared on the list of uh witnesses
miss jones was considering calling the
second thing i want to emphasize is the
quid pro quo nature of the allegation
quid pro quo one of those good latin
terms uh meaning uh this for that in
order to
is the allegation of
subpart four the job assistance was in
order to
prevent ms lewinsky's truthful
testimony
well
i want to review the evidence of this
because there is not only no evidence in
the record there's a lot of
contradictory evidence both direct and
circumstantial
we've heard a great deal
in the various presentations about mr
jordan's assistance to ms lewinsky
but i was surprised to sit right over
there through 11 hours and 52 minutes by
my watch of the house manager's very
able presentation
and i heard almost nothing
about what actually happened
in new york city
as a result of mr jordan's efforts
but when we review the evidence
and it's all right here don't worry i'm
not going to review every page of it but
it is all here
uh when we review this evidence which is
available
all you got to do is read it we get a
very different picture from what we got
from the able house managers
there's no secret about it
nor is there any conflict
in the testimony of these witnesses
there's no need for further discovery
here as i'll show because the testimony
is consistent
now the proof that is in the record is
that there was no corrupt linkage
no assistance whatsoever which was
designed and focused to get ms lewinsky
to do anything
nothing which tied the job assistance to
what was going on in the jones case
mr jordan did help open doors
and miss lewinsky went through those
doors
and she either succeeded or failed on
her own merits
two of the companies declined to offer
her a job
and at the third she did get an
entry-level job which she received on
her own merits
there was no fix no quid pro quo no link
to the jones case and also there was no
urgency to mr
jordan's assistance to her
he started assisting her well before she
showed up on the jones witness list and
he helped her whenever he could
consistently with his own heavy travel
schedule there's the allegation of a
quid pro quo but there's nothing in the
evidence to support the pro part of it
what the house managers have tried to do
and they're they are skillful
prosecutors they are able
they are experienced and they are
polished and they know what they're
doing
they've tried to juxtapose unrelated
events
and by a selective chronology
try and establish
causation between two wholly unrelated
sets of an event of events
and it's there's an old logical
fallacy
that you've had enough latin today uh
that uh
just because something comes after
something it was be it was caused by the
preceding event it's like the rooster
crowing and taking credit for the sun
coming up when you look at the house
manager's case there's a lot of that
going on because we'll see there's no
real existence of causal connection and
we'll also see that a lot of the
chronology you've been given is
erroneous
as i said earlier
uh there is no
evidence either direct or circumstantial
to support this quid pro quo allegation
now let's start with the direct evidence
the most logical place to begin
uh it could not be more unequivocal uh
let's start with ms lewinsky
first of all her new york job search
began on her own initiative
long before any involvement in the jones
case
moving to new york was her own idea
and it was one she raised in july of
1997.
uh this geographical move did not affect
in any way
her exposure to a subpoena in the paula
jones case
under the federal rules of civil
procedure of course a witness can be
subpoenaed in any federal district no
matter where the case is pending
and indeed a great many of the
depositions in the paula jones case took
place outside the state of arkansas
and for this reason mr manager barr's
assertion that the president wanted miss
lewinsky to go to new york because it
would
and i quote
make her much more difficult if not
impossible to reach as a witness in the
jones case
that statement is entirely untenable she
was just as vulnerable
to subpoena in new york as she was in
washington and
indeed she was already under subpoena in
january when she was finalizing her move
this contention just doesn't withstand
scrutiny
now
ms lewinsky testified i was never
promised a job for my silence you can't
get any plainer than that she testified
that her job search had no relation to
anything she might do in the jones case
in her
july 27 interview with the fbi the fbi
agent recorded her statement that there
was no agreement with the president with
mr jordan or anyone else that she had to
sign a jones affidavit before getting a
job in new york she told the
fbi agent explicitly that she had never
demanded
from mr jordan a job in exchange for a
favorable affidavit and that neither the
president nor mr jordan nor anyone else
had ever made this proposition to her
now mr jordan
who is
an eloquent and exceedingly articulate
man
took care of that claim in his own
uh grand jury testimony
he was asked about
any connection between the job search
and the affidavit he said there was
absolutely none he said on march 5 as
far as he was concerned these were two
entirely separate matters
and in his grand jury appearance on may
the fifth he was asked whether the two
were connected and mr jordan said and i
and i quote unequivocally
indubitably no
the president has likewise testified
that there was no connection between the
jones case and ms lewinsky's job search
he told the grand jury
i was not trying to buy her silence or
get vernon jordan to buy her silence
i thought she was a good person
she had not been involved with me for a
long time in any improper way
several months
and i wanted to help her get on with her
life
it's just as simple as that
quid pro quo
no
the uncontested facts bear out these
categorical denials of the three most
involved people
miss lewinsky began looking for a job in
july of 1997
and the event that hardened her resolve
to move to new york
was a report by her ostensible good
friend miss lindsay tripp
on about october the 6th that one of ms
tripp's friends at the national security
council said that miss lewinsky would
never
ever get a job in the white house again
now it turns out
that this
disclosure like so much else miss tripp
said is false
miss tripp's
nsc friend said no such thing but it did
have a profound impact on miss lewinsky
who described it as the straw that broke
the camel's back it was plain to her
then she was never going to be able to
get another white house
job mr jordan's assistance to ms
lewinsky began
about a month before
ms lewinsky learned about six weeks
before she learned she was a possible
witness in the jones case
ms lewinsky testified that she had
discussed with linda tripp sometime in
late september or early october the idea
of asking for mr jordan's assistance and
miss lewinsky indicated she couldn't
recall if it were her idea or linda
tripp's idea but in any event mr jordan
became involved sometime later at the
direction not of the president but of
miss curry who was a long time friend of
mr jordan and who had discussed with ms
lewinsky
her job search
now miss curry had previously assisted
ms lewinsky in making contact with
ambassador bill richardson
at the u.n
ms lewinsky's first meeting was with mr
jordan on november the 5th
and ms lewinsky testified that the
meeting lasted about 20 minutes and that
they had discussed a list of possible
employers she was interested in
uh she never told mr jordan that there
was any time constraint on his
assistance and both she and mr jordan
traveled a great deal out of the country
and in the country in that november
december period
now
mr jordan
testified unequivocally
that he
never at any time felt any particular
pressure to get ms lewinsky a job
this is plain and powerful and
unrebutted testimony he was asking the
grand jury if he recalled any kind of a
heightened sense of urgency by miss
curry or anyone at the white house about
helping ms lewinsky during the first
half of december and he replied oh no i
do not recall any heightened sense of
urgency what i do recall is that i dealt
with it as i had time to do it
now let me just pause here and observe
that if there had been any improper
motive
or any
sinister effort to silence ms lewinsky
it would have been extremely easy
for the president to have arranged for
her to be hired at the white house
if there were some corrupt intent to
silence her that was an obvious solution
because she very much wanted to go back
to work at the white house
it mattered a great deal
but while she was interviewed a couple
of times by white house officials in the
summer of 1997
those interviews never resulted in a job
offer
the fix was not in
there was no corrupt effort to bring
miss lewinsky back give her a white
house job or indeed transfer her in any
way from her pentagon job now she
continued her job search efforts with
the assistance of some of the white
house people in late october or early
november she told her boss at the
pentagon mr kenneth bacon that she
wanted to leave and move to new york
city
she enlisted his assistance in trying to
help her get a private sector job and he
helped her because she'd done good work
for him he had a positive impression and
testified that he wanted to do whatever
he could for her
in november of
1997 her supervisor at the pentagon uh
indicated that ms lewinsky gave notice
of an intention to quit her pentagon job
at the year end
now before we get to the private sector
firms that miss lewinsky went to
i want to pause and
make the point that she had a united
nations delegation job
in her back pocket
back pocket is a male image perhaps in
her purse she had it in her hand and
available
all during this period
in early october
at the request of miss curry
mr podesta mr john podesta who's then
the white house deputy chief of staff
had asked ambassador bill richardson
to consider ms lewinsky for a position
at the u.n
the ambassador
testified
that he did not take this as a pressure
call
he said there was no pressure anywhere
by anybody to hire miss lewinsky
miss curry testified to the grand jury
without contradiction
that she was acting on her own as miss
lewinsky's friend in trying to help her
now ms lewinsky interviewed for the un
position on october 31 with ambassador
richardson and he through his staff
offered her a job on november the third
ambassador richardson testified to the
grand jury
that he never spoke
to the president or mr jordan about ms
lewinsky that he was impressed by her
that he made the offer on the merits and
that no one had pressured him to hire
he testified specifically to the grand
jury on april the 30th and i quote this
was my decision to hire
i did not do it under any pressure or
anything i felt that she would be
suitable for the job and i didn't feel i
had to report to anybody it's not in my
nature i don't take pressure well on
personnel matters
i'm a cabinet member
i don't have to account for anything
this was mine my choice my decision and
i stand behind it he also declared what
i did was routine
this fact is highly significant
because although this job was not
precisely the job ms lewinsky wanted
it was a job in new york and she kept
this open until january 5 when she
finally turned it down
now it was mr manager brian
who referred to this in passing
just kind of
walked around it he disparaged it in the
way that a good trial lawyer does to
recognize it's there but then move
around and away from it but it's an
important fact
and it tears a very large hole in their
circumstantial evidence case because
she had in her hand i will say this job
offer
all through this period of uh november
and december and into january it wasn't
precisely what she wanted but it was a
good job it was in new york city and
there was no urgent necessity for her
connected with her private sector job
search
once again
quid pro quo
no
now there's a lot of further direct
evidence
concerning her job search and this is
contained
in a great many interviews in grand jury
transcripts
from the people at the various new york
firms
mr jordan contacted on ms lewinsky's
behalf
again there is simply no direct evidence
whatsoever for many of these people of
any kind of quid pro quo treatment
while mr jordan made the contacts
on her behalf there was no urgency about
him there was no pressure and they were
wholly unrelated to the jones case
let's recognize the obvious here
the president's relation the improper
relation with miss lewinsky had been
over for many months
he continued to see her from time to
time
he did what he could to be of assistance
to her
as she sought employment in new york
because as he testified she was a good
person and he was trying to help her get
on with her life
mr jordan was able to open some doors
but once opened there was no
inappropriate pressure he really opened
three doors for at american express
at young and rubicam and at revlon
and she batted one for three
and actually in job searches as in
baseball i at least would take that
batting average any day of the week but
she succeeded on her own once she was
through the door and her getting through
the door had no relation to the paula
jones case
let's first of all take a look at what
happened with american express and see
whether in the direct to circumstantial
evidence there's any evidence of a quid
pro quo here
the independent council conducted a very
large number of interviews and also
summoned a great many witnesses from
each of these three sets of companies
mr jordan was a member of the american
express board of directors
and he telephoned
a miss ursula fairbairn the executive
vice president of human resources at
american express on december 10th or
11th
and he told ms fairbairn that he wanted
to send her the resume of a talented
young woman in washington to see whether
she matched up to any openings at
american express
miss fairbairn told the fbi that it was
not at all
unusual for american express board
members or other company officers to
recommend young people for employment
mr fairbairn ms fairbairn said that mr
jordan did not in fact mention any white
house connection
that the applicant had and he exerted no
pressure at all on her to hire the
applicant
ms fairbairn recalled that mr jordan
made another employment recommendation
about two months earlier and indicated
this was simply not
an unusual
request
now the office of independent counsel
also you see it on the chart interviewed
thomas schick
at american express he's the executive
president for corporate affairs and
communications
uh miss fairbairn had sent
the name and resume to mr schick because
she thought that that's where ms
lewinsky might fit in and he interviewed
ms lewinsky
on december the 23rd in washington
he decided after this interview not to
hire ms lewinsky because she was felt he
felt that she was lacking an experience
and he also thought that american
express was probably not the right kind
of company for given what she had told
him she was interested in at the
interview and that she'd probably be
better off going to a public relations
firm
now the decision not to hire he told the
fbi was entirely his own he felt no
pressure to either hire or not hire miss
lewinsky and never talk to mr jordan at
any time during this process
once again
quid pro quo
no
now the second company
is
actually two companies
and it's young and rubicam
and burson marsteller
mr jordan
called peter georgescu the chairman and
ceo of young and rubicam uh the large
new york advertising agency
uh mr jordan had no formal connection
with the company but he'd have been a
friend of mr georgescuz for over 20
years mr georgeski was interviewed by
investigators from the office of
independent council
and said that sometime in december 1997
mr jordan had telephoned him
and had asked him to take a look at a
young person from the white house for
possible work in the new york area
mr georgesku had responded we'll take a
look at her in the usual way
and he stated that that was kind of a
code between
he and mr jordan and it meant that if
there was an opening for which she was
qualified
she would be interviewed and hired but
there would be no special treatment he
testified that mr jordan understood that
and he also said that mr jordan did not
engage in any kind of sales pitch
about lewinsky
uh mr georgesko said that
he then
initiated an interview for the on behalf
of miss lewinsky but his own involvement
was arm's length and that she succeeded
or failed totally on her own merits
he recalled that mr jordan had made
another
similar request on a previous occasion
and he said that he and mr jordan
frequently exchanged opinions about
people in the advertising business on an
informal basis
as a result of this telephone call ms
lewinsky was interviewed by
another
person of ms celia burke
who was the director of
excuse me she was the managing director
of human resources at burson-marsteller
uh a public relations firm that was a
division of young and rubicam
according to ms burke this interview was
handled by the book and while the
lewinsky interviews were a little bit
accelerated they went through the normal
steps
miss burke testified that while no one
put she testified that nobody put any
pressure on her and she said that both
she
and the director of corporate practice
uh at burson-marsteller miss aaron mills
and another corporate practice associate
of mr ziad tobasi had all liked miss
lewinsky and thought she was well
qualified
the chairman of the corporate practice
group mr gus weil had decided not to
hire lewinsky
ms mills testified that the procedure
under which ms lewinsky was considered
involved nothing out of the ordinary
not a single one of these witnesses
testified there was any urgency
connected with mr jordan's request
mr mills all ms mills also told the fbi
that
despite the fact that ms lewinsky had
been referred by the chairman of young
and rubicam their consideration of her
was entirely objective
she thought that miss lewinsky was
poised and qualified for an entry level
position but mr weil decided to take a
pass
once again
quid pro quo
no
now mr jordan
was a member of the board of directors
of revlon
a company wholly owned by mcandrews and
forbes holding company and mr jordan's
law firm had done legal work for both of
these companies
the corporate structure here is
complicated
but i'll be talking basically about two
firms revlon i think we all know what
revlon does and its parent company
mcandrews and forbes holding
now mr jordan telephone his old friend
mr richard halperin at the holding
company on december 11th and said that
he had an interviewee or he had an
applicant that he wanted to recommend
and uh he gave mr halperin some
information about her
mr halperin testified to the grand jury
that it wasn't unusual
for mr jordan to call him with an
employment recommendation he done so on
at least three other times that mr
halperin could recall
on this occasion
mr jordan told mr halpern on the
telephone that miss lewinsky was bright
energetic
enthusiastic and he encouraged mr
halperin to meet with her
mr halpern didn't think there was
anything unusual about mr jordan's
request and he testified that in the
telephone call
mr jordan did not ask him to consider ms
lewinsky on any particular timetable no
acceleration of any kind
indeed far from there being some
heightened sense of urgency
mr halperin explicitly told the fbi
that there was no
implied time constraint or requirement
for fast action
now ms lewinsky came up to new york city
and she interviewed with mr halperin on
december 18 1997
and mr halperin described her
as follows as a typical young capable
enthusiastic washington d.c type of
individual i don't know if that's
pejorative or not
who described her primary interest as
being in public relations
he and ms lewinsky talked about the
various companies that mcandrews and
forbes controlled and ms lewinsky
identified revlon as a company that she
would like to be considered at and mr
halperin decided to send her there for
an interview
mr halpern sent her resume to another
uh person at the holding company not at
revlon at the holding company to mr
jamie dernan who was a senior vice
president there he got the resume in
mid-december and he decided to interview
her in early january now you have at the
holding company two sets of uh
interviews of ms lewinsky going on
when he returned in early january mr
dernan also scheduled an interview and
he met with ms lewinsky on january the
8th
his decision was made entirely
independently of mr halpern's decision
and he wasn't even aware that mr halpern
had seen ms lewinsky when he met with
her on january the 8th
now mr dernan
met with ms lewinsky in the morning
and he thought now this is his view
you're going to get two views of this
interview mr dernan thought that she was
an impressive applicant for entry-level
work he was impressed with her
particularly by her work experience at
the pentagon he told the fbi he felt she
would fit in with the parent company but
there weren't any openings there based
upon what she had said about what her
interests were he decided to send her
resume over to revlon because he thought
it matched up well with her interest he
sent the resume over and he left a
message and now we're going to come to a
revlon person he left a message with ms
allen seidman
who was the senior vice president for
corporate communications at revlon
now cut to ms lewinsky
ms lewinsky had a very good interview
with mr halpern both she and mr halpern
thought however for reasons the record
don't make clear
ms lewinsky's impression of the durnin
interview were dismal she thought the
interview had not gone well she thought
it had gone poorly she described herself
as being upset and distressed she had no
idea of his positive reaction to her and
this is not just a late analysis he'd
already sent her resume he sent a resume
over to revlon immediately after the uh
their interview but in any event uh ms
lewinsky was afraid it had gone poorly
that she'd embarrassed mr jordan so she
called up mr jordan and on that same day
later
january the 8th mr jordan spoke by
telephone to the ceo of mcandrews and
forbes his friend mr ronald perlman
he mentioned to mr pearlman that ms
lewinsky had interviewed at mcandrews
and forbes but he made no specific
requests and he did not ask mr perlman
to specifically intervene in any way
now later that day and i know this is
complicated mr dernan
happened to speak mr dernan is the
second interviewer of miss lewinsky
happened to speak to mr perlman
and pearlman mentioned he had a call
from mr jordan about a job candidate
perlman then said to dernan let's see
what we can do and dernan indicated that
he had already on his own initiative
been working on this had talked to miss
lewinsky and sent her resume over to
revlon mr pearlman later that day phoned
mr jordan back to say
everything is all right she appeared to
be doing a good job she the resume was
over at revlon mr jordan expressed no
urgency no time constraints mr pearlman
didn't say anything out of the ordinary
had happened because it hadn't
now
later that same day after speaking to mr
pearlman mr dernan phones miss seidman
at revlon he'd sent the resume over
earlier in the day he didn't say that mr
perlman had mentioned miss lewinsky to
him he simply said to miss seidman look
i've sent you a resume i've met with
this young woman if you think she's good
you should hire
according to mr dernan
mr paroma never said or implied that
miss lewinsky had to be hired and indeed
mr dernan had already interviewed her
and formed a positive impression
uh according to miss seidman who was at
revlon
mr dernan
gave her a similar account that he gave
to the grand jury he said that he
thought she ought to interview miss
lewinsky make her own decision hire if
she thought she was a good candidate
only
the record is crystal clear that miss
seidman
over at revlon
had no knowledge that mr pearlman had
ever spoken to anyone about miss
lewinsky
ms seidman testified that she made an
independent assessment of miss lewinsky
she interviewed her the next day she
told the grand jury that she'd found
miss lewinsky to be a talented
enthusiastic bright young woman who was
very eager i like that in my department
at the conclusion of the interview she
intended to make an offer
to miss lewinsky but it was contingent
on the opinion of two other people
a miss jenna sheldon who was a manager
of human resources at revlon and miss
nancy risden who was manager of public
relations for corporate affairs
miss seidman testified that after they
had both interviewed ms lewinsky ms
risden told her that she'd found her
very impressive and miss sheldon had
also been very impressed
miss risden told the fbi that she'd been
impressed with miss lewinsky who
although she had no public relations
experience was bright and articulate
on the basis of all this ms seidman
decided to offer ms lewinsky
an entry-level job as public relations
administrator
the offer was made and ms lewinsky
accepted and i repeat the record
evidence is uncontradicted
that the fix was not on at all in this
process
this was the third company miss
lewinsky had interviewed with and on
this series of interviews she was
successful
nobody
in at any of these companies suggested
there was any quid pro quo link the only
person
only person in this record who talked
about trying to have ms lewinsky use
signing of the affidavit as leverage to
get a job
was none other than linda tripp
that paragon
of faithful friendship
on the audio tapes it's miss tripp who
frequently urges ms lewinsky not to sign
an affidavit until she had a job in new
york not clear if miss tripp knew about
the u.n job that miss lewinsky had
she on the audio tape miss lewinsky
sometimes professes agreement with miss
tripp's advice saying that she will not
sign an affidavit until she has a job
but as ms lewinsky testified to the
grand jury and again mr whiskey is
testifying under the threat of perjury
which will
which will uh blow away her immunity
agreement she was lying
to miss tripp when she said she would
wait to sign the affidavit until she got
a job
as miss lewinsky testified to the grand
jury her statement to miss tripp about
mr jordan assisting her in a quid pro
quo sense was not true she said it only
because miss tripp was insisting that
she promised her not to do this but in
fact the affidavit was already signed
when ms lewinsky made that promise
once again
quid pro quo
no
that's some of the direct evidence
now let's look at the circumstantial
evidence
the alleged circumstantial evidence
uh the quid pro quo theory
rests
on assumptions about why things happen
and on facts about when things happen
the former is
requires logic but the second is a
matter of fact
i mentioned previously that
article 2 or the subpart 4 here uses the
word intensified it didn't say that the
job search began as an effort to silence
miss lewinsky it only says that it
intensified as a result of that process
the original charge
made by the independent council and it's
there in the independent council's
referral at page 181
was an allegation that the president
helped ms lewinsky obtain a job in new
york at a time when she would have been
a witness against him
however the house committee looked at
the evidence i think in the five volumes
and
even though they haven't referred to it
here very much decided that that theory
would not get off the runway so they
revised their claim and gave us a kind
of wimpified version uh alleging not
initiation but intensification
now
under the right circumstances it's plain
that helping somebody find a job
is a perfectly
acceptable
thing to do there's nothing wrong with
it mr manager hutcheson
told you that and i quote here there's
nothing wrong with helping somebody get
a job
but we all know there is one thing
forbidden in public office we must avoid
quid pro quo which is this for that
now he went on to assert
that the president's conduct crossed the
line
as he put it when the job search
assistance became tied and
interconnected those are his words with
the president's desire to get a false
affidavit and then he went on to say
you will see
that's a prediction that mr manager
hutchinson made to you
you
will see
that they are totally interconnected
intertwined interrelated and that is
where the line has crossed into
obstruction
now mister manager hutchinson pointed to
a critical event
for their quid pro quo theory and that's
the entry
on december 11 1997
by judge wright was the judge in the
paul jones case of an order pertaining
to discovery in the paula jones case
this is the critical event according to
the managers
but let's look closely at this so-called
critical event
because it's the only claim
only factual claim the managers make of
some causal relationship
between the job search
and the jones case
and that claim is dead wrong and it's
demonstrably dead wrong
the managers have argued that what
brought mr johnson into action to help
ms lewinsky find a job
what really jumpstarted the process
was judge wright's december 11th order
and that order concerned discovery of
relationships the president had
allegedly had during a certain period of
time with women who were state or
federal employees
in the house
chief counsel shippers
powerfully
made the point about how important this
december 11th order was
why the sudden interest he asked why the
total change in focus and effort nobody
but betty curry really cared about
helping ms lewinsky throughout november
even after the president learned that
her name was on his prospective witness
list did something happen to move the
job search from a low to a high priority
on that day
oh yes
something happened
on the morning of december 11
1997
judge susan weber wright
ordered
that paula jones was entitled to
information regarding these other women
now
mr manager hutchinson again
emphasized that the impact of this
december 11th order was dramatic
he stood here and told you that the
president's attitude suddenly changed
and what started out
as a favor for betty curry
in finding miss lewinsky a job
dramatically changed into something
sinister after
ms lewinsky became a witness
and so mr manager hutchinson says what
triggered let's look at the chain of
events the judge the witness list came
in the judge's order came in that
triggered the president into action and
the president triggered vernon jordan
into action
that chain reaction here is what moved
the job search along
remember what else happened on that day
december 11th again that was the same
day that judge wright ruled that the
questions about other relationships
could be asked by the jones attorneys
mr manager
hutchinson
presented in his very polished and able
presentation a chart to you it was
exhibit one and i've taken the liberty
of borrowing it for our own purposes
but you see that he has outlined in
detail what happened on december 11th
here the very first item is that judge
susan weber wright issues order allowing
testimony of lewinsky then second
meeting between lewinsky and jordan
leeds provided
recommendation calls placed and then
later the president and jordan talk
about a job for lewinsky
well that's what the chart says
but when you look at the uncontested
facts
this isn't even smoke and mirrors
it's worse
first of all
ms lewinsky entered
mr jordan's building for their meeting
at 12 57
on december 11 as we see here from the
chart
on the entry chart of mr jordan's law
firm
mrs lewinsky's name is misspelled but
she identified this as
her entry into the law firm
but this
did not spring from magically the entry
of the judge's order it was scheduled
three days earlier
on december 8 and even that telephone
call was pursuant to an agreement made
between ms lewinsky and mr jordan two
weeks before that had nothing whatsoever
to do with the judge's order
indeed after her first meeting with mr
jordan on november 5
mr ms lewinsky testified that she had a
follow-up conversation
by telephone with mr jordan around
thanksgiving
and he advised her he was working on the
job search as he had time for it he
asked her to call him back in early
december
mr jordan testified that he was out of
the country
from
the day after thanksgiving until
december 4th
he also testified that on december 5th
this is before the witness list uh ms
curry called and reminded him that ms
lewinsky was expecting his call he asked
miss curry to have ms lewinsky call him
and she did so on december 8 and they
agreed to meet at mr jordan's office on
december 11. so this meeting this
sinister meeting was arranged by three
people who had no knowledge whatsoever
about the paula jones witness list at
the time they acted now ms lewinsky
herself was also out of washington for
most of the period from thanksgiving to
december the fourth first in los angeles
and then overseas
inexplicably but i think significantly
because it says something about the
strength of the case the house managers
ignore this key piece of testimony that
when the meeting was set up
it's uncontradicted
the point is that the contact between mr
jordan
and ms lewinsky resumed
in early or in in in december
not because of something having to do
with the order but because they had
agreed it would
the gap is attributable the gap in
timing to mr jordan's travel schedule
now let's look at when this discovery
order was entered
it was in fact entered late in the day
of december 11
after the conclusion of a conference
call among all the council in the paula
jones case
we have here
on the chart a blow up
of the clerk's minutes
now
it's a great accommodation to lawyers
when in a case
judges will have conference telephone
calls because it means you don't have to
travel to the same city and there were a
number of these held in the jones case
this is a conference call
that began as the clerk's minutes
indicate at 5 33 p.m little rock time in
the afternoon that would be 6 33
in washington dc
and it ended at 6 50 p.m in little rock
or 7 50 in washington dc now quite late
in the conference call
judge wright took up other matters and
advised council that an order on the
plaintiff's motion to compel testimony
had been filed and barry that's barry
ward the judge's clerk will fax a copy
of that order on the motion to uh to
compel to counsel
so sometime after 7 50 p.m
council get
uh the witness list
notice that
this proceeding is so late in the day i
don't know if you can see it but when
the uh clerk's minutes are filed they're
filed not on december the 11th but on
december 12th
finally
while we don't even have evidence of a
telephone call
between the president and mr jordan
we're back now to
mr hutchinson's mr manager hudson's
chart number one we don't have any
evidence that the president in fact ever
placed a call to mr jordan on this date
the president was out of the city but if
the call occurred
it must have occurred by 5
55 pm now
let's again look at this chart december
11 is so important that
the managers have put it on the chart
twice it's the only date on any of the
chart that appears
in any of this chart that appears twice
uh the president and jordan talk about a
job for lewinsky clearly what they're
telling you is that first you get the
order that energizes that jump starts
the process and then the president talks
to vernon jordan
well as i said
if a call occurred on that day
uh the earliest you could have had any
knowledge of the order would have been 7
50 p.m
there is a problem though
when you
think that maybe the president and
vernon jordan talked on this date even
if we don't have evidence of it
and the problem is
that at 7 50 p.m
mr vernon jordan
was high over the atlantic ocean in an
airplane
he was on his way to amsterdam
he testified
that i left on united flight 946 at 5 55
from dulles airport
that is where mr jordan was
on the evening of
december
11. he'd taken off even before the
conference call this this makes no sense
the manager's theory just makes no sense
his meeting with miss lewinsky and his
calls on her behalf had taken place
earlier in the day the president could
not have spoken to him about the entry
of judge wright's discovery order the
entry of that order had nothing
whatsoever to do with mr jordan's
assistance to ms lewinsky
this claim of a causal relation
totally collapses when you look at the
evidence
now the other charts purporting to show
causation
are also riddled with errors i only want
to show
a few of them and again we've borrowed a
chart from mr manager hudson hutchinson
his chart number seven
now he showed you this chart
and it purports to be an account of what
happened on january the 5th
1998.
you see how the president and ms
lewinsky
appear to be
conferring about
the affidavit that she's going to be
filing in the jones case
but when you look at the real facts
the chart becomes a fiction
mr manager hutchinson told you and i
quote
let's go to january 5th
this is a sort of summary this chart is
a sort of summary what happened on that
day
ms lewinsky meets with her attorney mr
carter for an hour
carter drafts the affidavit for ms
lewinsky just a few minutes later
and mr uh manager hutchinson continued
uh
frank carter drafts the affidavit she is
so concerned about she calls the
president the president returns ms
lewinsky's phone call now the suggestion
here and this is our old circumstantial
evidence problem the suggestion from
this fact pattern
is that ms lewinsky obtained a draft
affidavit from her lawyer
mr carter on january 5 then in a call
with the president later that day she
offered it to him for his review
possible yes
true no
this is true this this the facts here
simply do not bear out this chart why is
that well it's because mr carter's grand
jury testimony is very clear that he
drafted the affidavit on the morning of
january 6
and he even billed for it on that
morning he did not draft it and miss
lewinsky did not have it on january 5th
there's no causation here no linkage
the theory on this chart doesn't
stand up
and if i may take something else from
the house managers not simply their
chart but borrow mr manager bryant's
expression that dog won't hunt
ms lewinsky could not have offered
to show the president a draft affidavit
she herself could not have had on
january 5th
the idea that the telephone call on that
date is about that affidavit is sheer
unsp supported speculation and even
worse it's speculation demolished by
fact
let's kick the tires of another exhibit
uh
chart number eight
which was shown to you by mr manager
hutchinson purports to describe the
events of january the 6th
and again it sets forth a chain of
events which makes it look as though mr
jordan
was himself intimately involved in
drafting miss lewinsky's affidavit
mr manager hutchinson told you when he
showed you this chart and i want to
quote his exact words
the next exhibit is january 6.
on this particular day miss lewinsky
picks up the draft affidavit
at 208 to 2 10 p.m she delivers that
affidavit to whom mr jordan at 3 48 he
telephones ms lewinsky about the draft
affidavit and at 3 49
you will see in red both agree to
complete a portion of the affidavit that
created some implication that maybe she
had been alone with the president
so mr jordan was very involved in the
drafting of the affidavit and the
contents of
that that's the theory
proposed by the chart that's the
hypothesis
which they offer on the basis of the
circumstantial evidence but there are
problems that absolutely destroy it
because when we look beyond
the suggestive juxtapositions and
consider material overlooked by the
managers a very different picture
emerges
the key fact
that chart 8 tries to establish
is the statement that at 3 49 mr jordan
telephone ms lewinsky to discuss the
draft affidavit and they allegedly
agreed to delete implication that she
had been alone with the president
there's a very serious difficulty with
this theory
the chart wisely states that both agreed
to delete the implications that she had
been alone with the president but that's
not what the evidence shows
ms lewinsky testified that she spoke to
mr jordan because she had concerns about
the draft affidavit
according to her testimony when asked
whether mr jordan agreed with what were
clearly ms lewinsky's ideas about
changes in the affidavit ms lewinsky
said yes i believe so
now mr jordan recalled a conversation
in which ms lewinsky raised the subject
of her draft affidavit
remembered her saying that she had some
questions about the draft of the
affidavit but his testimony was emphatic
that he was not interested in the
details that the problem she had with
what had been drafted for her signature
were for her to work out with her
counsel and that she would have to talk
to her lawyer about it and ms lewinsky
did talk to her lawyer about it
the record is perfectly clear about that
indeed it couldn't be clear
although you wouldn't know this from
chart eight that the idea of deleting
the reference to her being alone with
the president came from her own lawyer
mr carter
he testified to the grand jury this is
the lawyer who'd actually drafted the
affidavit
that and he was referring to the passage
about her being alone with the president
he said paragraph six
has in its draft form as the last part
of that last sentence and would not have
been a private meeting that is not
behind closed doors
according to mr carter
this paragraph was modified
when we sat down in my office on january
7th the day after the events described
on chart eight
mr carter further testified that before
the meeting on the seventh before the
meet
it was my opinion that i did not want to
give paula jones attorney any kind of a
hint of a one-on-one meeting what i told
monica was
if they ask you about it
you will tell them about it but i'm not
putting it in the affidavit i was not
going to give them that lead to go after
in the affidavit because my objective is
not to have you be deposed
it's clearly mr carter
who deleted the reference to being alone
with the president
the bottom line is that the insinuations
on
that chart just don't
survive scrutiny i want to say a final
thing about all the charts involving
circumstantial evidence
you remember how many telephone calls
were up on those charts
i'm going to let you in on a little
secret it's a secret that a lot of you
who are lawyers know
it's pretty easy
to get telephone call records and to
identify telephone calls
but it's a common trick to put them up
even though you don't know what's going
on in the telephone calls and ask people
to assume some insidious
relationship
between events and the telephone call
no matter how many telephone calls are
listed on a chart
you don't know without testimony what
was happening in that phone call unless
the mere existence and there are cases
where the mere existence of a phone call
is probative but not not in these cases
here they're trying to weave a web
and no particular call is of significant
importance
the uncontroverted evidence shows that
in fact mr jordan spoke to the president
on many many many occasions
he was a friend he's been a friend of
the president since 1973
and a call between them was a common
occurrence
when asking the grand jury if he
believed he mr jordan believed that the
pattern of telephone calls to the
president was striking mr jordan replied
it depends on your point of view i
talked to the president of the united
states all the time so it's not striking
to me
mr jordan also testified that he had
never had a telephone conversation with
the president in which ms lewinsky was
the only topic
the house managers asked you to believe
simply on faith that if
two things happen on the same day they
are related but in fact this relation is
logical but not necessarily factual to
take i just want to make this point with
a couple of telephone calls let's take
mister manager hutcheson's chart for
december 17 1998 the day of the
president's deposition in the jones case
this chart
suggests there are two calls
uh
between mr jordan and the president
after the president
had concluded his deposition uh one call
is at 5 38 the other is at
702
the chart does not tell you several
important things
first these two calls each lasted two
minutes
second and more significantly mr jordan
testified to the grand jury as to both
telephone conversations
on saturday the 17th he said in the two
conversations i had with the president
of the united states we did not talk
about monica lewinsky or the deposition
mr jordan was asked
or the questions asked him in the
deposition and he replied that is
correct
in another exchange with the prosecutors
they asked mr jordan did the president
ever indicate to you in these two
telephone conversations that ms lewinsky
was one of the topics that had come up
mr jordan replied he did not
and finally the prosecutors asked did
the president ever indicate to you in
these two conversations that your name
had come up in the deposition as it
related to miss lewinsky and mr jordan
answered he did not
the managers
in the absence of evidence
that anyone endeavored to obtain ms
lewinsky a job
in exchange for her silence indeed in
the face of direct testimony
that all of those evolved involved that
it didn't happen ask you to simply
speculate
they ask you to speculate that since
they've thrown a lot of telephone calls
up there they must have some sinister
meaning
and they ask you to speculate that a lot
of those phone calls must have been
about ms lewinsky
and they ask you to speculate further
that in one of those unidentified
unknown phone calls somebody must have
said
let's get ms lewinsky a job in exchange
for her silence there is no evidence for
that it's not there it's just a theory
with regard to all this evidence
about the job search
when you look at the dates of various
events when you have the right
chronology in mind and when you look at
the relevant and uncontested facts these
facts are there they don't have to be
discovered there's just no evidence of
wrongdoing of any kind in connection
with miss lewinsky's job search efforts
in new york
now this is not a case
of the manager's
uh
presentation resting on even
circumstantial as opposed to direct
evidence they don't even have
circumstantial evidence here
all they have is a theory about what
happened which isn't based on any
evidence either direct or circumstantial
nothing in this evidence is really
contested when you get right down to it
strictly as a matter of who said what to
whom or when
when lawyers
ask you to keep your eye on the big
picture
when they ask you don't lose the forest
for the trees don't get lost in the
details
that's usually because the details those
stubborn facts
refute
and contradict the big picture
and so it is here you can keep adding
zero to zero to zero
for a very long time indeed forever and
you'll still have zero
the big picture here just doesn't exist
and no matter how many times the house
managers keep making the assertion
there is just no evidence of any kind
i realize that it has taken a good bit
of time
and painstaking perhaps even painful
attention
for each one of you to walk through
these facts in a lawyerly manner
i am also keenly aware of the old saying
that when all is said and done with a
lawyer
there's more often said than done
but we needed to take a look carefully
and specifically at this evidentiary
material with regard to these five
grounds in the same way that miss mills
took you through very specifically
yesterday with regard to the other two
grounds
to try and dispel
the popular misconception that we were
either unwilling or unable to rebut the
facts we have rebutted the facts
the simple fact is that there is no
evidence
in the record to support the allegation
that the president obstructed justice
in his december 17th telephone call with
miss lewinsky in his statements to his
aides and statements to betty curry with
relation to gifts or the job search
it's sometimes been claimed by the
managers
that we have adopted
a so what defense trying to take
lightly or to justify
the improper actions that are at the
root of this case
well
senators with all respect that argument
is easy to assert
but it's false it's a straw man asserted
only to be knocked down
we've tried in our presentations the
last two days and today
to treat the evidence in a fair and a
candid and a realistic way
about the facts as the record
reveals we've tried to show you that the
core charges of obstruction of justice
and perjury
cannot be proven we're not saying that
the alleged
conduct doesn't matter
we're saying that perjury didn't occur
and obstruction of justice didn't happen
we haven't tried to sugarcoat or excuse
conduct that is wrong
i think that mr manager boyer
used the right phrase
when he referred
to
self-inflicted
wounds
there's no doubt
that there are self-inflicted wounds
here
wounds that are very real and very
painful and very public
there's just no question about that the
question before you
is whether these self-inflicted wounds
rise to such a level
of lawless
and unconstitutional
conduct
that they leave you no alternative no
choice
but to assume the awesome responsibility
for reversing the results of two
national elections
on that question
what the situation demands
is not eloquence which the very able
managers have in abundance
but rather a relentless focus
on the facts
the law
and the constitution all of which are on
the side of the president
it's a great honor for me to stand here
this body has been called
the anchor of the republic
and it's that constitutional
stability that that political
sanity
that is needed now
there there's a story which is perhaps
apocryphal
that when thomas jefferson
returned from france where he'd served
as ambassador
while his colleagues were writing the
constitution
that he met with george washington and
he asked washington
why they had found it necessary to
create the senate
washington is said to have silently
removed the saucer from his teacup
and poured the tea
into the saucer
and told jefferson that like the act he
had just performed
the senate
would be designed to cool the passions
of the moment
historically this place has been
uh really a haven
of sanity
balance wisdom you've debated
controversial uh
issues
which have been passionately felt with
with candor with courage and civility
and so once again
i think it is your responsibility
and yours alone committed to you by the
constitution to make a very somber
judgment
uh the president has spoken powerfully
and personally of his remorse for what
he's done
others have pointed out that
the poisonous partisanship
led
the other body to send you articles of
impeachment on the narrowest partisan
vote in its history
i think that the bipartisan manner
however
you've conducted this impeachment trial
is a welcome change from the events of
the last year
we asked only that you give this case
and give this country
the constitutional stability
and the political sanity
which this country deserves
the president did not commit perjury
he did not obstruct justice
and there are no grounds
to remove him
from office thank you
this is the majority leader
mr chief justice i ask unanimous extent
we recessed the proceedings for
15 years but
senators be prepared to resume at five
minutes after four because we have to
hear the eloquence of one of our former
colleagues
without objection it's so ordered
as the senate begins this 15-minute
recess we once again are interested in
your reaction to what you've seen here
on the sixth day of the impeachment
trial of the president you know really
not sweeping this under the rug
let's carry it through and uh
we'll see what happens
thanks for your call on the line four
acquittal billings montana
hello hi yes i am calling for it will be
in order
chair recognize the majority leader
thank you mr chief justice i believe the
senate is prepared now to hear the final
presentation
to be made by white house counsel
and at the conclusion of that i would
have a brief wrap up statement to make
about how we would hope to proceed on
friday and generally on saturday but
i'll do that at the close of this
presentation you look for
the chair recognizes mr council bumpers
to continue the presentation of the case
for the president
mr chief justice
i distinguished house managers
from the house of representatives
colleagues
i have seen the look of disappointment
on many faces because i know a lot of
people thought you were rid of me once
and for all
and i've taken a lot of ribbing
this afternoon but i have seriously
negotiated with some people particularly
on this side
by an offer to walk out and not deliver
this speech in exchange for a few votes
i understand three have it under active
consideration
it is a great joy
to see you and it is especially pleasant
to see an audience
which represents about the size of the
cumulative audience i had over a period
of 24 years
i came here today
for a lot of reasons one was that i was
promised a 40-foot cord
and i've been shorted 28 feet
chris dodd said that he didn't want me
in his lap
and i assume that that
he arranged for the cord to be shortened
i want to especially thank some of you
for your kind comments and the press
when it
received some publicity that i would be
here to close
the debate on behalf
of the
white house council
and the president
i was a little dismayed by senator
bennett's remark
he said yes senator bombers is a great
speaker
but i never he was never persuasive with
me because i never agreed with him
i thought he could have done better than
that
you can take some comfort colleagues in
the fact
that i'm not being paid
and when i'm finished you probably think
the white house got their money's worth
i have told audiences
that
over
24
years that i went home almost every
weekend
and returned usually about dusk on
sunday evening
and you know the plane ride
international airport
when you can see the magnificent
washington monument and this building
from the window of the airplane
and i told these students
at the university in a small liberal
arts school at home hendrix
after 24 years of that literally
hundreds of times
i never failed to get goosebumps
same thing is true about this chamber i
can still remember as though it were
yesterday
the awe i felt when i first stepped
into this magnificent chamber so full of
history
so beautiful
and last tuesday as i returned
after only a short three-week absence
i still felt that same sense of awe
that i did the first time
i walked in this chamber
colleagues i come here with some
sense of reluctance
the president and i have been close
friends for 25 years
we fought so many battles back home
together in our beloved arkansas
we tried mightily all of my years as
governor in his and all of my years in
the senate when he was governor to raise
the living standards in the delta area
of mississippi arkansas and louisiana
where poverty is unspeakable
with some measure of success not nearly
enough
we tried to provide health care for the
lesser among us
for those who are
well off enough they can't get on
welfare but not making enough to buy
health insurance
we have fought
above everything else to improve the
educational standards
for a state that for so many years
was at the bottom of the list or near
the bottom of the list
of income
and we have stood side by side to save
beautiful pristine areas in our state
from environmental degradation
we even
crashed
a twin-engine beach bonanza trying to
get to the gillette [ __ ] supper
a political event that one
misses
at his own risk
and we crash this plane
on a snowy evening
on a rural airport
off the runway sailing out across the
snow
jumped out
jumped out
and ran away unscathed
to the dismay of every budding
politician in arkansas
the president and i have been together
hundreds of times
at parades
dedications
political events
social events
and in all of those years and all those
hundreds of times we've been together
both in public and in private
i have never one time
seen the president conduct himself in a
way
that did not reflect the highest credit
on him
his family
his state
and his beloved nation
the reason i came here today with some
reluctance
please don't misconstrue that
it has nothing to do with my feelings
about the presence i've already said
but it's because we are from the same
state and we are long friends and i know
that that necessarily diminishes
to some extent the effectiveness of my
words
so if bill clinton the man
bill clinton the friend
were the issue here
i'm quite sure
i would not be doing this
but it is the weight of history
on all of
us and it is my reverence for that great
document you heard me rail about it for
24 years
that we call our constitution the most
sacred document to me next to the holy
bible
these proceedings go right to the heart
of our constitution where it deals with
impeachment
the part that provides the gravest
punishment
for just about anybody the president
even though the framers said we're
putting this in to protect the public
not to punish the president
our colleagues you have such an awesome
responsibility
my good friend the senior senator from
new york
has said it well he says this
a decision to convict
holds the potential
for destabilizing the office of
presidency
and those 400 historians and i know some
have made light of that about those
historians are they just friends of bill
and last evening
i went over that list of of historians
many of whom i know
among them see van woodward
in the south
we love him
he is the preeminent southern historian
in the nation
i promise you
he may be a democrat he may even be a
president he may be even a friend of the
president
when you talk about integrity
he is the walking personification
exemplification
of integrity
well colleagues i've heard so many
adjectives to describe
this gathering in these proceedings
historic
memorable
unprecedented
awesome
all of those words all of those
descriptions
are apt
and to those i would add the word
dangerous
dangerous not only for the reasons i
just stated but because it's dangerous
to the political process
and it's dangerous to the unique mix
of pure democracy
and republican government
madison and his colleagues so
brilliantly
crafted and which has sustained us for
two hundred
and ten years
mr chief justice this is what we lawyers
call dicta this costs you nothing
it's extra
but the more i study that document
and those four months at philadelphia in
1787
the more odd i am
and you know what madison did the
brilliance was in its simplicity
he simply said man's nature
is to get other people
to dance to their tune
man's nature
is to abuse his fellow man sometimes
and he said the way to make sure
that the majorities don't abuse the
minorities
the way to make sure that the bullies
don't run over the weaklings
is to provide the same rights for
everybody
and i had to think about that a long
time before i delivered my first lecture
at the university of arkansas last week
and it made so much sense to me
but the danger
as i say is to the political process
and dangerous for reasons feared by the
framers
about legislative control
of the executive
that single issue
and how to deal with
impeachment
was debated off and on for the entire
four months of the constitutional
convention
but the word dangerous is not mine
it's alexander hamilton's
brilliant
good looking guy
mr ruff quoted extensively on tuesday
afternoon and his brilliant
statement here
he quoted alexander hamilton precisely
and it's a little arcane isn't easy to
understand
so if i may at the expense of being
slightly repetitious let me paraphrase
what hamilton said
he said the senate had a unique
role in participating with the executive
branch
and appointments
and two
it had a role
it had a role in participating with the
executive
in the character
of a court
for the trial of impeachment
but he said
and i must say this
and you all know it
he said it would be difficult to get a
what he called well constituted
court
from wholly elected members
he said passions would agitate the whole
community
and divide it
between those who were friendly
and those who had inimical interest to
the accused namely the president
and then he said and this is his words
the greatest danger
was that the decision would be based on
the comparative strength of the parties
rather than the innocence or guilt
of the president
you have a solemn oath
you have taken a solemn oath
to be fair and impartial
i know you all i know you as friends and
i know you as
honorable men and i am perfectly
satisfied
to put that
in your hands
under your oath
this is the only
caustic thing i will say in these
remarks this afternoon
but the question is
how did we come to be here
we're here because of a five-year
relentless
unending
investigation
of the president
50 billion dollars
hundreds of fbi agents spanning across
the nation
examining
in detail the microscopic lives
of people
maybe the most intense investigation not
only of a president but of anybody ever
i feel strongly about this state this
because of my state
and what we have endured
so you'll have to excuse me
but that investigation
has also shown that the judicial system
in this country can and does get out of
kilter unless it's controlled
because there are innocent people
innocent people
who have been financially and mentally
bankrupt
one woman told me two years ago
that her legal fees
were 95
dollars
she said i don't have ninety five
thousand dollars and the only asset i
have is the equity in my home
which just happens to correspond to my
legal fees of ninety five thousand
dollars
and she says the only thing i can think
of to do is to deed my home
this woman was innocent never charged
testified for the grand jury a number of
times
and since that time she has accumulated
an additional two hundred thousand
dollars
and attorney fees
jo bear's pursuit of jean valjean and
les miserables pales by comparison
i doubt that there are few people
maybe nobody in this body who could
withstand such scrutiny
and in this case those summoned
were terrified not because of their
guilt
but because they felt guilt or innocence
was not really relevant
but after all of those years and 50
million dollars
of white water travel gate foundation
you name it
nothing
nothing
the president was found guilty of
nothing
official
or personal
we're here today because the president
suffered a terrible
moral lapse
a marital infidelity
not a breach of the public trust
not a crime against society the two
things hamilton talked about in federal
newspaper number 65 i recommend it to
you before you vote
but it was a breach
of his marriage vows
it was a breach of his family trust
it is a sex scandal
h.l menken said one time when you hear
somebody say this is not about money
it's about money
and when you hear somebody say this is
not about sex it's about sex
you pick your own adjective to describe
the president's conduct
here are some that i would use
indefensible
outrageous
unforgivable
shameless
i promise you the president would not
contest
any of those or any others
but there's a human element in this case
that has not even been mentioned
that is the president and hillary and
chelsea are human beings
this is intended only as a mild
criticism
of our distinguished friends my house
but as i listen to the presenters to the
managers make their opening statements
they were remarkably well prepared and
they spoke eloquently
more eloquently than i really had hoped
but when i talk about the human element
i talk about what i thought was
on occasion unnecessarily harsh and
pejorative descriptions of the present
i thought that the language should have
been tempered somewhat
to acknowledge that he is the president
to say constantly that the president
lied about this and lied about that
as i say
i thought that was too much for a family
that has already been about as decimated
as a family can get
a relationship between husband and wife
father and child has been incredibly
strained
if not destroyed
there's been nothing but sleepless
nights
mental agony for this family for almost
five years
day after day from accusations of having
assassinated or had vince foster
assassinated on down
it has been
bizarre
but i didn't sense any compassion
and perhaps none is deserved
the president has said for all to hear
that he misled
he deceived
he did not want to be helpful to the
prosecution
and he did all those things to his
family
to his friends
to his staff
to his cabinet
and to the american people
why would he do that
well
he knew this whole affair
was about to bring unspeakable
embarrassment and humiliation
on himself
his wife whom he adored
and a child that he worshipped with
every fiber in his body
and for whom he would happily have died
to spare her this
or to humiliate ameliorate her shame
and her grief
the house managers have said
shame and embarrassment is no excuse for
lying
well the question about lying
that's your decision
but i can tell you
you put yourself in his position
and you've already
had this big moral lapse
as to what you would do
we are none of us perfect
sure you say he should have thought of
all that beforehand and indeed he should
just as adam and eve should have
just as you and you and you and you
and millions of other people
who have been caught in similar
circumstances
should have thought of it before
did i say none of us are perfect
i remember chaplin the
chaplain's not here is he
it's too bad he ought to hear this story
this evangelist was holding this
great
revival meeting and in the close of one
of his meetings he said is there anybody
in this audience who has ever known
anybody who even comes close to the
perfection of our lord and savior jesus
christ
nothing
he repeated the challenge and finally a
little bitty guy in the back of the
audience kind of held up his hand and
said you are you saying you've known
such a person
stand up
you stood up and he said tell us share
it with us
who was it
he said my wife's first husband
[Laughter]
make no mistake about it
removal from office
is punishment
it is unbelievable punishment even
though the framers
didn't quite see it that way
again they said and it bears repeating
over and over again they said they
wanted to protect the people
but i can tell you this
the punishment of removing bill clinton
from office would pale compared to the
punishment he has already inflicted on
himself
there's a feeling in this country that
somehow or other bill clinton has gotten
away with something
mr leader i can tell you he hasn't
gotten away with anything
and the people are saying
please don't protect us from this man 76
of us think he's doing a fine job
65 to 70 percent of us don't want him
removed from office
some have said
we're not respected on the world scene
the truth of the matter is this nation
has never enjoyed
greater prestige in the world than we do
right now
you saw carlos menon our president of
argentina just here recently
say to the president
mr president the world needs you
the war in bosnia is under control
the president has been as tenacious as
anybody could be about middle east peace
and in ireland
actual peace and maybe the middle east
will make it
and he has the indians and the
pakistanis talking to each other as
they've never talked to each other in
recent times
vaishlav hollow said mr president
for the enlargement of the north
atlantic treaty organization
there's no doubt in my mind that it was
your personal leadership that made this
historic development possible
[Applause]
king hussain
mr president i've had the privilege of
being a friend of the united states and
president since the late president
eisenhower and throughout all the years
that have passed
i've kept in touch
but on the subject of peace
the peace we're seeking i have never
with all due respect and all the
affection i held for your predecessors
have known someone with your dedication
clear-headedness
focus and determination to help resolve
this issue
in the best way possible
well i'm not i've got nelson mandela and
other world leaders who've said similar
things in the last six months
our prestige i promise you in the world
is as high as it's ever been
when it comes to the question of perjury
you know there's perjury and then
there's perjury
let me
ask you if you think this is perjury
on november 23rd
1997
president clinton went to vancouver
british columbia
and when he returned
monica lewinsky was at the white house
at some point
and he gave her a marble
carved
marble
bear
i don't know how big it was
question before the grand jury august 6
1998
what was the christmas present
or presents that he got for you
answer
everything was packaged in the big black
dog or big canvas bag from the black dog
store
in martha's vineyard
and he got me a marble bear's head
carving sort of you know
a little got a little
sculpture i guess you'd call maybe
was that the adam vancouver
yes
question on the same day of the same
grand jury
question okay good
when the president gave you the
vancouver bear on the 26th
28th i guess it is no 26th
[Applause]
when the president gave you the
vancouver bear
on the 28th
did he say anything about what it means
hmm
well what did he say
answer
i think he
i believe he said
that the bear is the maybe
indian symbol for strength
you know and to be strong like a bear
and did you interpret that
to be strong in your decision
to continue to conceal the relationship
no
house judiciary committee report to the
full house
on the other hand knowing the subpoena
requested gifts
his giving miss lewinsky more gifts on
december 28 seems odd
but ms lewinsky's testimony reveals
why he did so
she said that she never questioned that
we would ever do anything but keep this
private
and that meant to take whatever
appropriate steps needed to be taken to
keep it quiet
the only logical inference is that the
gifts including the bear
symbolizing strength were a tacit
reminder to ms lewinsky that they would
deny the relationship
even in the face of a federal subpoena
she just got through saying no
and yet this report says that's the only
logical entrance
and then the brief that came over here
accompanying the articles of impeachment
said on the other hand more gifts on
december 28th
ms lewinsky's testimony reveals the
answer she said she was never questioned
she said that she never questioned
that we were ever going to do anything
but keep this private and that meant to
take whatever appropriate steps needed
to be taken to keep it quiet
again they say in their brief the only
logical inference
is that the gifts including the bear
symbolizing strength
were a tacit reminder to mrs lewinsky
that they would deny the relationship
even in the face of a federal subpoena
is it perjury
to say the only logical inference is
something when the only shred of
testimony and the record is no that was
not my interpretation
i didn't imply i didn't infer that
and yet here you have it in the
committee report and you have it in the
brief
of course that's not perjury first of
all it isn't under oath
but as a trial lawyer i'll tell you what
it is is wanting to win too badly
i tried three four maybe 500 divorce
cases
incidentally you're being addressed by
the entire south franklin county
arkansas bar association
[Music]
i can't believe there were that many
cases in that little town but i had a
practice
in surrounding communities too
and in all those divorce cases
i would guess that in 80 percent of the
contested cases perjury was committed
and you know what it was about
sex
extramarital affairs
but there's a very big difference in
perjury about a marital infidelity in a
divorce case
and perjury about
whether i bought the murder weapon or
whether i conceal the murder weapon or
not
and to charge somebody with the first
and punish them as though it were the
second
stands justice our sense of justice on
its head
there's a total lack of proportionality
a total lack of balance in this thing
the charge and the punishment are
totally out of sync
all of you have heard or read the
testimony of the five prosecutors who
testified before the house judiciary
committee
five season prosecutors
and each one of them
veterans said under the identical
circumstances
the identical circumstances of this case
we would never charge anybody because we
know we couldn't get a conviction
and in this case
the charges brought and the punishment
sought
are totally out of sync
there is no balance there is no
proportionality
but even stranger you think about it
even if this case had originated
in the courthouse
rather than the capital
you would never have heard of it
do you reconcile what the prosecutor
said with what we're doing here
impeachment was debated off and on in
philadelphia for the entire four months
as i said
the key players were
gunner morris
senator specter of brilliant
pennsylvanian
george mason
the only man this
reputedly to have been so brilliant that
thomas jefferson actually deferred to
him
and he refused to sign the constitution
incidentally even though he was a
delegate because they didn't deal with
slavery and he was a strict abolitionist
and then there was charles pinckney
senator hollings from south carolina
just a youngster 29 years old i believe
edmund randolph from virginia who had a
big role in the constitution in the
beginning the virginia plan and then it
was of course james madison
the craftsman
they were all key players in drafting
this impeachment provision
and uppermost in their mind during the
entire time they were composing it
was they did not want any kings they had
lived under despots they had lived under
kings they had lived under autocrats and
they didn't want
any more of that
and they succeeded very admirably
we've had 46 presidents and no kings
but they kept talking about corruption
maybe that ought to be the reason for
impeachment
because they feared some president would
corrupt the political process
that's what the debate was about
corrupt the political process and
ensconce himself
through a phony election
maybe as something close to a king
they followed the british rule
on impeachment because the british said
the house of commons may impeach
and the house of lords must convict
and every one of the colonies
had the same procedure house
senate though in all fairness house
members james alexander hamilton was not
very keen on the house participating
but here was the sequence of events in
philadelphia that brought us here today
they started out with mal administration
and madison said that's too vague what
does that mean
so they dropped that
they went from that to corruption
and they dropped that
then they went to malpractice
and they decided that was not definitive
enough
and they went to
treason
bribery
and corruption
and they decided
that still didn't suit them
but bear in mind one thing during this
entire process
they are narrowing
they are narrowing the things you can
impeach the president
they were making it tougher
madison said if we aren't careful
the president will serve
at the pleasure
of the legislature the senate he said
and then they went to treason
and bribery
and somebody said that's still not quite
enough
and so they went to treason
bribery
and george mason added or other high
crimes and misdemeanors
against the united states
and they voted on it
and on september 10 they sent the entire
constitution to a committee they called
the committee on style and arrangement
which was the committee that would draft
the language in a way that everybody
would understand it would be well
crafted
from a grammatical standpoint
but that committee
which was dominated by madison and
hamilton
dropped
against the united states
and historians will tell you
that the reason they did that
was because redundant
because that committee had no right
to change the substance of anything
and they would not have they would not
have dropped it
if they hadn't felt
that it was redundant
and then
they put in for good measure
and we can always be grateful
the two-thirds majority
now this is one of the most important
points
of this entire presentation
the term first of all treason and
bribery nobody quarrels with that and
we're not debating trees and bribery
here in this chamber we're talking about
other high crimes and misdemeanors
thank you
and where did high crimes and
misdemeanors come from
it came from the english law
and they found it
in english law
under a category which said
distinctly
political offenses
against the state
let me repeat that they said
high crimes and misdemeanors
wants to be because they took an english
law where they found it in the category
that said offenses
distinctly political
against the state so colleagues please
for just one moment
forget the complexities of the facts
and the tortured legalisms
and we've heard them all
brilliantly presented on both sides and
i'm not getting into that
but ponder
this
if high crimes and misdemeanors was
taken from english law
by george mason
which listed high crimes and
misdemeanors as political defenses
against the state
what are we doing here
if as hamilton said
it had to be a crime against society or
a breach of the public trust
what are we doing here
even perjury
concealing
or deceiving
an unfaithful relationship
does not even come close
to being an impeachable offense
nobody has suggested that bill clinton
committed a political crime against the
state
so colleagues if you honor the
constitution you must look at the
history of the constitution and how we
got to the impeachment clause
and if you do that and you do that
honestly according to the oath you took
you cannot you can censor bill clinton
you can hand him over to the prosecutor
for him to be prosecuted
but you cannot convict him
and you cannot indulge yourselves the
luxury or the right to ignore
this history
there's been a suggestion
that a vote to acquit
would be something of a breach of faith
with those who lie in flanders field
anzio and
bunker hill and
gettysburg and wherever
i didn't hear that i read about it
but i want to say
and incidentally
i think it was chairman hyde who alluded
to this and said those men fought and
died
for the rule of law
i can remember a cold november third
morning in my little hometown of
charleston arkansas i was 18 years old
i just gotten one semester in at the
university when i went into the marine
corps
and so
hours to report to little rock to be
inducted
my it was cold
the drugstore was the bus stop
i had to be there by eight o'clock to be
sworn out
and i had to catch the bus down at the
drugstore at three o'clock in the
morning so my mother and father and i
got up at two o'clock and got dressed
and went down there
i'm not sure i can tell you this story
and the bus came over the hill i was
rather frightened anyway about going i
was quite sure i was going to be killed
only slightly less frightened that betty
would find somebody else while i was
gone
the bus came over schoolhouse hill
and my parents started crying
i'd never seen my father cry i knew i
was in some difficulty
now as a parent
at my age
i know
he thought he was giving not his only
begotten son but one of his forgotten
begotten sons
can you imagine you know that scene it
was repeated across this nation millions
of times
and then happily
i survived that war saw no combat
was on my way to japan
when it all ended
i've never had a terrible problem with
dropping the bomb though that's been a
terrible moral dilemma for me
because the estimates were that we would
lose as many as a million
men in that invasion
but i came home to a generous
government
who provided me under the gi bill
an education and a fairly prestigious
law school which my father could never
have afforded
and i practiced law in this little town
for 18 years
loved every minute of it
but i didn't practice constitutional law
and i knew very little about the
constitution but when i went into law
school i did study constitutional law
though mr chief justice it was fairly
arcane to me
and trying to read the federalist papers
and tocqueville all of those things law
students are expected to do
that was tough for me
i confess
so after 18 years in law practice i
jumped up and ran for governor and i
served for governor as governor for four
years and i still
i guess i knew what the rule of law was
but i still didn't really have much
reverence for the constitution i just
did not understand any of the things i
just got through telling you
no
my love for that document
came
day after day and debate after debate
right here in this chamber
some of you perhaps read an op-ed piece
i did a couple of weeks ago
when i said i was perfectly happy for my
legacy of the 24-year senator to be i
never voted for a constitutional
amendment
and it isn't that i wouldn't
i think they made a mistake in not
giving you fellas four years
you're about to cause me to rethink that
one
[Laughter]
and the reason i developed this
love of it is because i saw
madison's magic working time and time
again
keeping bullies from running over weak
people keeping majorities from running
over minorities
and i thought about all the unfettered
freedoms we had
the oldest organic law in existence
made us the envy of the world
mr chairman we've also learned that the
rule of law includes presidential
elections
that's a part of the rule of law in this
country
we have
an event
a quadrennial event in this country
which we call presidential elections
and that's the day when we reach across
this aisle and hold hands democrats and
republicans
and we say
win or lose
we will abide by the decision
it is a solemn event presidential
elections
and it should not they should not be
undone lightly
or just because one side has the clout
and the other one doesn't
and if you want to know what men
fought for in world war ii for example
or in vietnam
ask senator in no way
he left an arm in italy
he and i were the president at normandy
on the 50th anniversary
but we started off in anzio
senator domenici were you with us
it was one of the most awesome
experiences i've ever had in my life
certified war hero
i think his relatives were in an
internment camp so ask him what was he
fighting for
or ask
bob carey
certified
medal of honor winner
what was he fighting for
probably got a quite different answer
our senator chaffey
one of the finest men ever to grace this
body and certified marine hero of
guadalcanal
ask him
and senator mccain
a genuine hero
ask him
you don't have to guess
they're with us and they're living
and they can tell you
and one who is not with us here in the
senate anymore
robert dove
asked senator dole what he was fighting
for
senator dole had what i thought was a
very reasonable
solution
to this whole thing
that would handle it fairly
and expeditiously
the american people are now and for some
time
have been asking
to be allowed a good night's sleep
they're asking for an end to this
nightmare
it is a legitimate request
i'm not suggesting
that you vote for or against the polls
i understand that
nobody should vote against the polls
just to show their medal and their
courage
i have cast plenty of votes against the
polls and it's cost me politically a lot
of times
this has been going on for a year though
and in that same op-ed piece i talked
about
meeting harry truman my first year
as governor of arkansas
spent an hour with him
an indelible experience people at home
kidding me about this because i very
seldom make a speech that i don't
mention this meeting
but i will never
forget what he said
put your faith in the people trust the
people
they can handle it
they have shown conclusively time and
time again
that they can handle it
colleagues this is easily the most
important vote you will ever cast
if you have difficulty
because of an intense dislike of the
president
and that's understandable
rise above it
he is not the issue
he will be gone
you won't
so don't leave a precedent from which we
may never recover
and almost surely will regret
[Applause]
if you vote to acquit
mr leader you know exactly what's going
to happen
you're going to go back to your
committees you're going to get on this
legislative agenda you're going to start
dealing with medicare and social
security and tax cuts and all those
things which the people of this country
have a non-negotiable demand that you do
if you vote to acquit you go immediately
to the people's agenda
but if you vote to convict
you can't be sure
what's going to happen
james g blaine
was a member of the senate when andrew
johnson was tried in 1868
and 20 years later
he recanted
and he said i made
a bad mistake
and he says as i reflect back on it
all i can think about
is having convicted andrew johnson would
have caused
much more chaos and confusion in this
country than andrew johnson could ever
conceivably have tried
and so it is with william jefferson
clinton
if you vote to convict in my opinion
you're going to be creating more havoc
than he could ever possibly create after
all he's only got two years left
so don't for god's sakes
heightened people's alienation
that is an all-time high toward their
government
the people have a right and they are
calling on you to rise above politics
rise above partisanship
they're calling on you to do your solemn
duty
and i pray you will
thank you mr chief justice
the chair recognizes the majority leader
mr chief justice
i believe that that concludes the white
house presentation
i remind all senators that we will
reconvene tomorrow beginning at 1 pm on
friday under the provisions of senate
resolution 16 we will begin the question
and answer period for not to exceed 16
hours
the majority will begin the questioning
and as we go forward in that process we
will alternate back and forth across the
aisle i've discussed this proposition
obviously with senator daschle and we've
discussed it in our our conferences we
looked at a number of other alternatives
but we thought that this would be a fair
way to proceed and we would have a
question i would begin from this side
from
a senator that will be named and then go
to the other side and back and forth
we think this provides fairness and i
hope all members will entrust the chief
justice to be fair during this portion
of the deliberations
and for the managers and council to of
course be
succinct in their answers and respond to
the question that's actually asked
at this time i would anticipate
approximately five hours of questions in
our answers being used tomorrow or
friday
we would then reconvene on saturday at
10 a.m
and again resume the questioning
alternating back and forth
we have not set any definite time for
saturday we'll need to see how the
questions go
we don't really know whether we'll need
five hours or 10 hours or the full 16
but if we reach a point on saturday
where we need to conclude the day's
proceedings and we feel that there's
still more questions that would need to
be asked
then after
communication on both sides of the aisle
we would decide how to go forward it's
my hope
that we can complete this question
period
during the day friday and saturday and
concluded saturday
i hope the senators will
be thoughtful in their questions they
must be in writing
please be brief with your written
presentation dissertations would not be
appreciated in writing at this point
and we will do our best mr chief justice
to
deal with
the question of repetition or redundancy
and try to have some process that
senator daschle and i will will use to
get the senator's questions to the chief
justice
i thank all senators for their attention
during the past two weeks both in the
presentation
of the case by the house managers and
the presentation by the white house
council obviously the senators have been
here attentive and listened i think
we've learned a great deal
and i appreciate the way the senate has
conducted itself and now i move the
senate stand and adjournment under the
previous order in the absence of
objection it is so ordered
the senate back in session tomorrow at
one o'clock thanks for the call possibly
time for one more call from cape cod
you with us massachusetts
yes
quickly
[Music]
high crime of webster's third
international dictionary a crime of
infamous nature contrary to public
morality but not technically
constituting a felony an offense which
the u.s senate deems to constitute
adequate grounds for removal of
president vice president or any civil
officer
deserving of impeachment
thanks cape cod for that call up next
live gavel to gavel coverage of the
united states senate senator lot just
arriving off the house floor of the
senate starting momentarily
the senate will convene as a court of
impeachment the chaplain will offer a
prayer
spirit of the living god
fall afresh on us
we need your strength
the wells of our own resources run dry
we need your strength to fill up our
diminished reserves
silence strength to flow into us
with artesian resourcefulness
quietly filling us with renewed power
you alone can provide strength to think
clearly
and to decide decisively
bless the senators today
as they trust you as lord
in the inner tribunal of their own
hearts
you are the sovereign of this land
but you are also sovereign of the inner
person inside of each senator
may these hours of questions
bring exposure of truth
and resolution of uncertainties
oh god of righteousness and grace
guide this senate
at this decisive hour
you are our lord
and savior
amen amen
senators may be seated
the sergeant-at-arms will make the
proclamation
hear ye hear ye hear ye
all persons are commanded to keep silent
on pain of imprisonment while the senate
of the united states is sitting for the
trial of the articles of impeachment
exhibited by the house of
representatives against william
jefferson clinton
president of the united states
if there's no objection the journal of
proceedings of the trial are approved
today
personal to the provisions of senate
resolution 16 the senate has provided up
to 16 hours during which senators may
submit questions in writing
directed to either the managers on the
part of the house of representatives or
counsel for the president
the chair recognizes the majority
leaders
thank you mr chief justice
this afternoon the senate will begin the
question and answer period for not to
exceed 16 hours as provided in senate
resolution 16.
i have consulted several times about
this procedure with senator daschle and
others
and we have determined that the majority
will begin the questioning process with
the first question and we will then
alternate back and forth
and now as i noted yesterday uh this
hasn't been done in quite a while and so
we'll just have to
go forward in a way that
we feel is fair and comfortable and
we ask that you
give the benefit of doubt to us and how
we
send the questions up to the chief
justice senator daschle and i will try
to make sure that the time stays pretty
close to even as we go through the day
of course the chief justice
i'm sure we'll make sure that the
deliberations and the answers are fair
we hope the answers will be succinct
and that they will respond to the
question
one question that has arisen from
senators on both sides is can we direct
the question to both sides
the white house counsel and the house
manager simultaneously and the answer is
no under our rules uh you'll need to we
will direct the question to one side or
the other and uh our questions uh from
either side may go to either one of the
the parties but
only one would answer that question of
course there is the possibility for a
follow-up question that might be
directed to one side or the other so
we'll we'll just uh deal with that as we
go forward now i would expect for the
information all senators that we would
go approximately five hours today
i don't know how many questions we can
get done in an hour but i suspect by six
o'clock on friday
we would have exhausted
a series of questions that would entitle
us to a break at that point
but again we'll just have to see how we
feel about it and uh we wouldn't stop
obviously in the middle of a question we
would resume again on saturday at 10 a.m
10 a.m alternating between the both
sides and
the schedule at this point is undecided
we need to see how many questions are
left that senators really feel need to
be asked
and then again we'd have to see how the
day progresses i did have senators come
up and talk to me yesterday about
uh you know we would need some
reasonable limit on that so i'm thinking
in general terms about not going beyond
four o'clock
on saturday but we will we'll converse
and we'll make those announcements after
consultation uh as we go forward uh
tomorrow uh or uh during the day even
tomorrow
i hope we can complete our questioning
period by the close of business tomorrow
but uh if we go with the times i
basically mentioned you're talking about
10 hours not 16
so we'll have to consult and determine
if we want if that's uh we've asked the
basic questions or we would want to
continue it
later or even over on monday
i believe mr chief justice that that uh
completed the explanation and i wanted
to give this time
i do have the first question uh prepared
to send to
the chief justice but i thought perhaps
he had some further business he might
want to address before i did that yes uh
i would like to advise council on both
sides that the chair will operate on a
rebuttable presumption
that each question can be fully and
fairly answered in five minutes or less
mr chief justice i do send the first
question
to the desk
senators allard bunning coverdell and
craig
asked the house managers
is it the opinion of the house managers
that the president's defense team in the
presentation
mischaracterized any factual or legal
issue in this case if so please explain
mr chief justice and
distinguished colleagues and members of
the senate
uh there are first of all let me thank
you for the opportunity to respond to
questions and we hope that we can do
that in a succinct manner today
there are a number of um
mischaracterizations and and
statements that we disagree with that
the the president's defense team made
and i will not attempt to to cover all
of these i would like to highlight just
just a few of these and perhaps might
in a short manner exceed the rebuttal
rebuttable presumption of five minutes
mr craig made argument
on behalf of the president that this
is a lot about an oath versus oath
perjury case article one is the perjury
allegation
one word against another person's word
he said she said
however we would submit that
there was not discussed in their
presentation the fact that there is
ample corroboration
which is
provided for under the law as being
necessary but we believe that factually
there was
much corroboration that is another
person or other evidence to support the
fact that the president did commit the
perjury and in particularly the those
aspects of the perjury charge that deal
with the the personal relationship that
ms lewinsky and the president had
very clearly white house records and
phone logs along with ms lewinsky's
incredible recollection of particular
names and events and and the
circumstances surrounding these
particular occasions that have already
been highlighted in
in the past and we all know
uh
about those types of telephone
conversations and she was very clear
and the facts the people have all
corroborated her on her presence in the
white house at certain times
number two the secret service uh
testimony that placed her inside the
oval office on occasion alone
the
fact that there have been
contemporaneous statements made by ms
lewinsky
describing the details of this
relationship
and as we all know the law permits this
contemporaneous statement to to in this
case to at least eight
friends and and two professional
counselors of detailing the particular
relationship
while it was ongoing
the blue dress is very clearly
corroboration and the dna testing that
resulted from that
also the transfer of ms lewinsky from
the white house and
and the later surreptitious efforts
with mrs curry miss curry to to sneak
her back into the white house
again indication that efforts had been
made to move her to relocate her away
from the president to protect him
from those circumstances
also the president's prepared statement
in the grand jury is another example
that was not not mentioned
and in particular i highlight the
statement that he made
that would lead you to believe that this
relationship evolved over a period of
time
and that being that he uh
was was sorry that what had started out
as a friendship turned into this type of
relationship where in fact
miss lewinsky's testimony is very clear
that uh that relationship began
immediately the very first day that he
actually spoke to her
mr ruff's statement that the manager's
case was misleading
uh is also incorrect i believe he used
words like fudging the facts
which is brew and be wary of a
prosecutor who feels like he must
deceive the court
and this comes as somewhat of a surprise
to many of us on this table
who are who know that mr ruff is
familiar with the facts of this case
and just last month when he testified
before the judiciary committee he said i
have no doubt that the president walked
up to that line that he thought he
understood
reasonable people now reasonable people
and you maybe have reached that
conclusion that he could have crossed
over that line
and that
what for him was truthful but misleading
or non-responsive or misleading and
evasive was in fact false
he didn't tell you in this presentation
that just a month ago he took the
position that reasonable reasonable
people can disagree
and yet uh before this senate and and
the audience that we have watching he
asserts that anyone who would
accuse his client of perjury
is guilty of fudging the facts and
brewing which is brewing
and deception
and even mr craig unfortunately borrowed
many of those same words in that
characterization
it may be good theater but it's simply
not the case that these managers are
engaged in that type of practice before
the senate and the american people
white house counsel sheryl mills spoke
in a similar manner and tone to this
house about inconvenient and stubborn
facts
oh those stubborn facts
in her meticulous presentation she
passed over she completely missed
the second occasion wherein president
clinton attempted to coach miss curry
did anyone hear about the second event
as carefully as she tried to make
innocent the wrongful effort of the
president to tamper with a potential
witness she just as carefully skirted
the entire similar episode two or three
days after the first one where he again
tampered with her testimony according
according to ms curry
he spoke with her just recapitulating
remember that in our presentation
likewise in her review of witness
tampering she mischaracterized by the
law the law stating that a threat an
actual threat was required
18 usc 1503 states that obstruction of
justice occurs when a person corruptly
endeavors to influence the testimony of
another person and corruptly has been
interpreted by the district court here
in d.c to mean acting for an improper
purpose
and clearly
this was an improper purpose when the
president was trying to get her to
testify falsely but a threat is not a
part of the law and not needed
and i will
quickly just if i might just mention two
more quick ones uh mr ruff stated that
the president gave the same denial to
his aides that he gave to his country
and family recall specifically him
saying that he just has said said
nothing different to the american public
and his family that he told the aides
that we we talk about john podesta
sidney blumenthal
well that's not right
he told the president told mr podesta
and this is mr podesta talking he told
me that he never had sex with her and
that that he never asked you know he
repeated the denial but he was extremely
explicit in saying he never had sex with
her in any way whatsoever that they had
not had oral sex in blumenthal mr
blumenthal
he told mr blumenthal an entirely
different story that monica lewinsky
came at me and made a sexual demand
on me and that i the president rebuffed
her he said that i've gone down that
road before and caused pain for a lot of
people and i'm not going to do that
again she threatened him miss lewinsky
threatened the president she said that
she would tell other people that she had
an affair and that she was known as a
stalker among her peers and she hated
that and if she had an affair with the
president she wouldn't be a stalker
anymore
that is not the story that he told the
american people and that he told his
family these are embellishments that are
very important because he anticipated
that they would go into the grand jury
and repeat those
those misstatements
and finally the affidavit
of monica lewinsky
white house defense lawyers spoke so
eloquently about the procurement of this
affidavit as he glided through how the
president believed that monica lewinsky
could have filed a truthful affidavit
while still skirting
their sexual relationship sufficiently
to sufficiently to avoid testifying in
the paula jones case
and this is an important issue as it was
specifically raised in the answer before
the senate
the president's lawyers brought this
this statement into this senate as part
of their answer
that he could have
advised her that she could have filed an
affidavit that would have been truthful
while still at the same time denying
a sexual relationship sufficiently that
she would not be called as a witness
that's uh
i know opposing counsel makes light of
the hair splitting and the legal
gymnastics that people have talked about
here but that's an incredible statement
that you could
do the twister enough to to to
go and go into a deposition where that's
the purpose of being there is to
discover this type of information who he
might have had an affair with
and have her tell a truthful affidavit
and still not be able to testify had she
told a truthful affidavit she would have
been immediately called
plus the president
was given an opportunity by ms lewinsky
to review the affidavit remember the
statement that that
he didn't need to he'd seen 15 just like
it
you know if he had that that out for her
where she could have told the truth and
still not been able to testify don't you
think he owed it to her
to cause her not to have to commit
perjury in that affidavit which she did
not to have to commit a crime wouldn't
he have shared that with her if he had
had that information at that time
and i would suggest it that he didn't
and and with those uh and i have others
that i'd like to talk to but in the
interest of time and fairness i will
stop my presentation at this point and
thank the senate
mr chief justice
recognize the minority leader could i
inquire as to the length of time that
response took approximately nine minutes
thank you
uh senator sarbanes asks
uh
would you please
comment on any of the legal or factual
assertions made by the managers in their
response to the previous question from
senators allard bunning coverdell and
craig
thank you mr chief justice uh
it may be that i will need to
call on some of my colleagues uh to be
of assistance here but let me begin and
uh we will strive mightily to stay
within uh the rebuttable five minutes
mr manager bryant began by suggesting
that there really is corroboration on
the key issue that he focused on which
as you know is the
nature of the specific details of the
relationship between the president and
ms lewinsky and he suggested that among
the corroborating
matters that he would point to were
her recollection of events which is
alleged to be detailed records
reflecting that she was indeed in the
white house on particular days secret
service records uh dna testing
none of those have anything to do with
the essential issue that congressman
brian reyes because nobody disputes the
fact that ms lewinsky was in the white
house engaged in inappropriate conduct
and with the president on a particular
day the only point that i think the
manager raises that is sort of new and
that needs to be addressed is this
notion
that contemporary consistent statements
made to third parties about
these events are somehow
corroborative
ms lewinsky's testimony in this regard
and as all of you who've had the pain of
struggling through an evidence course
will know
or have had the pain of trying lawsuits
in which this issue arises
so-called prior consistent statements
are not in fact viewed as some
corroborating evidence that can be
introduced
by the prosecutors in this setting for
they know
and i'm sure those of you who suffered
through these pangs know as well
that the law rejects the notion that
merely because you tell the same story
many times
it is corroborative of the underlying
credibility of the witnesses version and
that there are only certain very limited
areas in which prior consistent
statements are in fact admissible just a
couple of others and then i'll turn this
briefly over to ms ms mills uh
manager bryant suggests that i've
somehow uh
gone too far and suggesting that
the prosecutors here have in my words
engaged in fudging
i
have never suggested that
the entire presentation is so infected
and i made very clear in my comments to
the senate the other day
the specific examples which i think we
documented quite fully but beyond that
let me go back to his reference to my
earlier testimony before the house
judiciary committee in which i did
indeed in response to questions comment
that the president may well have walked
up to the line believing he didn't cross
it but that reasonable people might
conclude otherwise the only problem with
that example as broached by mr manager
bryant is that i was talking there and
the record is very clear
talking about his testimony in the jones
deposition which is everyone in this
room will fully understand is not before
you because the house of representatives
specifically decided that the
president's testimony in the jones
deposition was not a basis for
impeachment and if that without having
used i hope all of my time mr chief
justice i'll allow ms mills if she would
to come forward and respond specifically
to the point raised with respect to her
presentation
thank you
i just want to adjust briefly
two issues that the house managers raise
with regards to the statute on a
structures obstruction of justice with
respect to witness tampering the house
manager is focused on 1512 with respect
to miss curry which does require a
threat or intimidation and indeed
specifically addressed that they wanted
to focus on 1512
when they were addressing her
the situation where the president spoke
with her
with regard to 1503 though to the extent
that the house managers
suggest that the president's actions in
his conversation
with ms lewinsky violated 1503
i think probably you all might recall
from my presentation that we discussed
the aguilar case in which uh it is
clearly necessary that you have a nexus
between the actual conduct
and um the official proceeding that
would be going forward and in that case
we had a judge who lied to an fbi agent
who indicated that he was going to that
this matter might come up in a grand
jury proceeding and mr chief justice in
his opinion indicated that that was
insufficient to find the nexus that was
necessary
to violate 1503
and if you all have my package you can
look back and i provided you with a
specific quotation so in this instance
we clearly wouldn't have the nexus
between the president's conversation
with miss curry who was not yet a
witness there was no suggestion that she
was going to be a witness in the jones
case indeed no one had even mentioned
that fact to him as you actually did
have in aguilar and in addition i think
with regard to both statutes the
specific intent is not fulfilled and
that's something we spoke about when i
gave my presentation before
with regards to the president's
conversation with ms curry which
happened on the 18th and again on a
subsequent day
in that instance it also happened prior
to all of the um
all of the media attention and other
matters that came out so in effect all
of the same issues apply because there
was no
at that point no indication that the
independent council was involved in this
matter and the president still was
concerned about the jones proceeding
indeed he was concerned that the media
attention was going to be significant
and he was accurate as it began to grow
and grow
thank you
as chief justice we send our next
question to the desk
[Applause]
senators enzi and coverdell
asked the house managers
please elaborate on whether the
president's defense team failed to
respond to any allegations made by the
house managers
bob
mr chief justice ladies and gentlemen of
the senate uh as to the areas that were
not
covered by the president's defense team
i think that my fellow manager bryant
already mentioned one but i thought it
was significant that in the
questioning of betty curry or the
statements made to betty curry after the
president's deposition on january 17th
where he came brought her into the
office and he went through that series
of questions i was never alone right and
that series of questions everybody is so
familiar with
uh
they discussed that primarily in the
terms that she was not a witness but
during three days of presentation they
never discussed the fact that it was two
days later that the same series of
questions
or statements or coaching were addressed
to miss curry and so the president's
defense that well i was just trying to
refresh my recollection on the facts so
i could respond to media inquiries does
not make sense
in light of the fact that it was done on
one day the series of questions but
betty curry testified that two days
later she was called into the office the
same series of statements declarations
coaching was made to her
and and the only possible explanation
for that is that the president was
trying to make a very clear statement to
her this is what i remember this is what
i want you to do and for three days for
three days of presentation the
president's
defense lawyers never never mention that
now i want to come back to what miss
mills just said because this was a big
issue in the presentation of mr ruff
in fact i have the
uh the quotes here i hope that that will
be uh turned over to you
uh
that
whenever
uh betty curry was questioned they say
well she wasn't a witness there was
never any clue that she was going to be
a witness that the jones lawyers never
anticipated that she was going to be a
witness that it was never put at all on
the witness list and that's very
significant i just want to drive this
point home this is mr ruff
talk about prosecutorial fudging how
about defense fudging uh mr ruff miss
courage is neither an actual nor a
prospective witness that's his
presentation in the entire history of
the jones case miss curry's name had not
appeared on any witnesses list nor was
there any reason to suspect that miss
curry would play a role in the jones
case discovery was down to its final
days as council rough and finally yet in
the days weeks following the deposition
the jones lawyers never listed her never
contacted her never added her to any
witness list that is the presentation of
mr ruff and it was also that of miss
mills but yet if you look at the facts
in the jones case the deposition was
included on january 17th there was the
holiday on the 18th and in fact on
january 22nd within
uh
five days of the deposition
she was a subpoena was issued for betty
curry
within five days a subpoena was issued
for betty curry and in fact on the 23rd
there was a supplement to the witness
list by the jones lawyers which included
betty curry's name as 163
and this was served on mr uh bennett uh
and miss and the other lawyers for the
president in addition i have which i
will distribute to you the actual
subpoena that was issued for betty curry
as i testif as i indicated excuse me uh
which was issued on january 22nd and the
proof of service in which betty curry
was served as a witness in that case on
january 27th the proof of service and so
the statements by mr ruff that there was
never any indication that the jones
people knew that she was going to be a
witness is totally
not within the record in fact it is
clear that the subpoena was issued it
was served whenever that
deposition was over of the president
both the president left there and the
jones lawyers left there knowing
immediately that the president was that
the betty curry was going to be a
witness she was had to be a witness with
the president asserting ask betty asked
betty asked betty so many times during
that and that is why the president came
back had to deal with betty curry being
a witness and the jones lawyer went out
and immediately amended the witness list
asked to do that and then uh served a
subpoena which was served on betty curry
that is the record those are the facts
and we will distribute this to you
uh senator levin asked white house
counsel
would you please comment on any of the
legal or factual
assertions made by the managers in their
response to the previous question
thank you mr chief justice
let me respond very briefly to manager
hutchinson's last remarks
because i owe him
indeed
an explanation and he is correct in one
respect
i did not
accurately reflect the fact that after
the
january 21st story in the washington
post
the
jones lawyers did in fact attempt to
track the entire independent council
investigation and i think mr hutchinson
will tell you indeed issued any
a long list of subpoenas and for that
misleading statement i apologize and i
trust
we will hear equally candid assessments
uh
from the managers but more importantly
let me return to the substance of that
issue
because it is important to note
without the chart being up there that
indeed at the moment which is the
critical moment when the president was
talking to betty curry whether it be on
the 18th or whether it be on the 20th or
the 21st or the 20th the 21st you
remember is when the story breaks
the the answer is the same he had no
reason to believe
at that stage and that's the critical
stage because that's what's in his mind
and that's what you have to ask if
you're talking about obstruction of
justice or witness tampering
at that stage he had no more reason to
know that ms curry was going to be a
witness
than
he did as we explained it both i and ms
mills in our earlier presentations
the fact that the jones lawyers once
this story became a matter of public uh
knowledge which it did on the 21st
thereafter dumped a series of subpoenas
and deposition notices literally in the
closing days of discovery does not bear
on the question of what was in the
president's mind which is the critical
moment for testing his intent
at the moment when he first had his
conversations with betty curry
anybody
thank you mr chief justice
senators grassley thurman grassley
chaffee and chaffee and craig
direct to the house managers president
clinton has raised concerns about
whether the articles of impeachment are
overly vague and whether they charge
more than one offense in the same
article how do you respond to these
concerns
mr chief justice and members of the
senate i will be pleased to do my best
to address this question
the president has made two claims
against the forum in which the articles
of impeachment have been drafted
i would submit to you that neither of
these claims has any merit and i'll be
pleased to address both claims as
briefly as i can
first the president claims that the two
articles of impeachment are vague and
lack specificity and therefore prevent
him from knowing what he has been
charged with
second the president asserts that the
articles are flawed because they charge
multiple offenses in a single article
with respect to the first claim it is
clear from the president's trial
memorandum and his presentation here
that president clinton and his counsel
know exactly what he is being charged
with
and i would submit to you that if
president clinton had suffered from any
lack of specificity in the articles he
could have filed a motion for a bill of
particulars he did not choose to do so
moreover articles of impeachment have
never
they have never been required to be
drafted with the specificity of
indictments after all this proceeding is
not a criminal trial if it were then we
as the prosecutors would not only be
entitled to call witnesses but would be
required to call them to prove our case
we would certainly not be put in the
position of defending the
appropriateness of witnesses now
president clinton wants all the benefits
of a criminal trial without bearing any
of its burdens
impeachment is a political and not a
criminal proceeding and that has been
clear from the
institution of this proceeding in our
constitution as recognized by justice
joseph story the constitution's greatest
interpreter during the 19th century
impeachment is designed not to punish an
offender by threatening deprivation of
his life
liberty or property but to secure the
state by divesting him of his political
capacity
justice story thus found
the analogy to indictment to be invalid
and i would quote what justice story had
to say which is directly
pertinent to this question the articles
need not and indeed do not pursue the
strict form and accuracy of an
indictment they are sometimes quite
general in the form of the allegations
but always contain or ought to contain
so much certainty as to enable the party
to put himself upon the proper defense
and also in case an acquittal to avail
himself of it as a bar to another
impeachment now indeed alexander
hamilton had commented on the same point
uh in the federalist
we have heard many references to
federalist number 65 and this trial to
date i will refer once again to what
alexander hamilton said in the
federalists on this particular point
there hamilton stated that impeachment
proceedings and i quote can never be
tied down by such strict rules either in
the delineation of the offense by the
prosecutors
or in the construction of it by the
judges
as in common cases serve to limit the
discretion of courts in favor favor of
personal security by that he means in
criminal cases
i think that this statement from
alexander hamilton refutes the argument
of the president's council directly
and i would i would also point out that
unlike the judicial impeachments of the
1980s president clinton has not
committed a handful of specific misdeeds
that can be
easily listed in separate articles of
impeachment
in order to encompass the whole
assortment of misdeeds that caused the
house of representatives to impeach the
president the judiciary committee looked
to the more analogous case that of
president nixon in 1974
in the proceedings with respect to
president nixon the committee also was
faced with drafting articles of
impeachment of a reasonable length
against a president who had committed a
series of improper acts designed to
achieve an illicit end
the first article impeachment against
president nixon charged in an order to
cover up an unlawful entry into the
headquarters of the democratic national
committee and to delay impede and
obstruct the consequent investigation
and for certain other purposes he
engaged in a series of acts such as and
i quote making or causing to be made
false or misleading statements to
lawfully authorize investigative
officers
endeavoring to misuse the central
intelligence agency and endeavoring to
cause prospective defendants and
individuals duly tried and convicted to
expect favored treatment and
consideration in return for their
silence or false testimony the article
did not i repeat did not
list each false or misleading statement
did not list each misuse of the cia and
did not
list each prospective defendant and what
they were promised now that is the
record
anyone who's familiar with the nixon
case the president nixon case is
familiar uh with those facts in like
fashion the articles of impeachment
against president clinton charged him
with providing for jurious faults and
misleading testimony concerning four
subjects such as his relationship with a
subordinate government employee and
engaging in a course of conduct designed
to prevent obstruct and impede the
administration of justice which course
included four general acts such as an
effort to secure job assistance for that
employee
i would submit to you
that an argument can be made that the
articles of impeachment against
president clinton were drafted with more
specificity than the articles
that were drafted against president
nixon i will do my best to briefly
address the second claim which has been
asserted
by the president's lawyers
against the form of the articles of
impeachment that is that they are
invalid for charging multiple offenses
in one article
now the articles of impeachment allege
that president clinton made one or more
for juria's faults and misleading
statements to the grand jury and
committed one or more acts in which he
obstructed justice once again these
articles are modeled after the articles
adopted by the house committee on the
judiciary against president nixon and
were drafted
with the rules of the senate
specifically in mind the senate rules
explicitly contemplate that the house
may draft articles of impeachment in
this manner and prior rulings of the
senate have held that such drafting is
not deficient and will not support a
motion to dismiss
rule 23 of the rules of procedure and
practice in the senate when sitting on
impeachment trials now states that an
article of impeachment shall not be
divisible for the purpose of voting
thereon at any time during the trial
now when the senate committee on rules
and administration amended rule 23 in
1986 it explained that and i quote this
at length but this is this goes right to
the heart of the matter and this is what
the rules committee in this report said
said the portion of the amendment
effectively enjoining the division of an
article into separate specifications is
proposed to permit the most judicious
and efficacious handling of the final
question both as
a general matter and in particular with
respect to the form of the articles
that propose the impeachment of
president richard m nixon
the latter did not follow the more
familiar pattern embodying an
impeachable offense in an individual
article but in respect to the first and
second of those articles set out broadly
based charges alleging constitutional
and
improprieties followed by a recital of
transactions illustrative or supportive
of such charges the wording of articles
one and two again referring to the nixon
articles expressly provided that a
conviction could be had there under if
supported by one or more of the
enumerated specifications
it was agreed to write into the proposed
rules language which would allow each
senator to vote to convict under either
the first or second articles if he were
convinced that the person impeached was
guilty of one or more of the enumerated
specifications
the senate rules
themselves thus specifically contemplate
that an article of impeachment may
include multiple specifications of
impeachable conduct
as in the case of president nixon the
senate itself has recognized the article
the articles against president nixon as
an appropriate motto model to be
followed the house has
in the articles now before the senate
simply followed
that model moreover i would point out
in conclusion
the senate has convicted a number of
judges on such omnibus articles
including judges archbald ritter
and
claiborne i would submit
to the members of the senate that the
articles
of impeachment against president clinton
present his offenses and their
consequences
in an appropriately transparent and
understandable manner
they are not constitutionally deficient
thank you
bob
the senators uh this proposal this
question is sent by senators dodd and
leahy would you please comment on any of
the legal or factual assertions made by
the managers in their response to the
previous question by senators thurman
grassley chaffee and craig
particularly what would have stopped or
limited the house in specifying
precisely the statements on which the
articles were based
in our case we're talking about an
allegation of perjury
in the nixon case the 1974 nixon case he
was not charged with perjury and i think
our argument was that perjury is a
different kind of thing you have to be
very specific in what you charge and you
have to be very clear as to what the
statement is
when you are charging perjury and that
is the tradition of our criminal justice
system and of our jurisprudence now the
the danger here is that if you don't and
you're overly broad as we contend
article one is
is that at any given moment you can fill
the the the vessel with what your
meaning is and let me just give you a
little history of these allegations
of grand jury perjury against the
president
the star referral had three allegations
mr shippers the star referral was
september ninth mr shippers when he made
his presentation to the judiciary
committee had two allegations one was
different
he incorporated one of stars
when starr appeared and testified on
november 19th in front of the judiciary
committee
he almost spent no time on this at all
one or two sentences but he added a new
charge which was that the president was
not truthful
when he testified that he had been
truthful in the deposition
uh and then we appeared and made our
representations in our defense on behalf
of the president
on the basis of what mr starr had
written in his referral and what mr
shippers had presented
to the judiciary committee and in
addition to what mr starr had said when
he appeared
but then when mr shippers gave his
closing argument the following day and
we saw the new articles we had
by my count
ten
allegations from mr shippers two had to
do with the definition of sexual
relations three had to do with the
prepared statement two had to do with
things that were never alleged again and
never surfaced again in the course of
the case
and three had to do with mr bennett and
his proffer of the lewinsky affidavit
then on nov on december 16th we had a
whole new additional collection of
report of allegations
and um on january 11th the trial brief
here set forth eight examples just to
highlight the danger
of not being specific of not tying
yourself to a definition
let me compare for example
the trial brief
that was submitted by the house managers
three days
before mr rogan made his presentation
the precise
statement
that mr the president is accused of
testifying falsely in front of the grand
jury was that he was
lying when he said that the reason that
he was seeing
betty curry was to quote refresh his
recollection in the trial brief
they make that reference one two three
four times
but the statement that's specific here
in the trial brief is he's there he he
lied when he said he was gonna refresh
his recollection that's not even
mentioned in mr rogan's presentation he
changes it and he says
he lied when he said he wanted to
ascertain what the facts were trying to
ascertain what betty's perception was
very different statement requiring a
very different defense and two days
before three days before we even hear
the allegations on the floor of the
senate we still don't know precisely
what they are
chief justice if i may uh
absorb whatever rebuttable time is uh is
still
available to us
may i for just a moment sir surely thank
you
uh
i want to talk briefly about just two
aspects of manager kennedy's
presentation first of all he asked why
didn't we
seek a bill of particulars well
let me all remind the senators although
i don't think any of you were here at
the time of the impeachment trial of
judge louderback
who
also sought a bill of particulars and
the house of representatives at the time
made it clear that the managers do not
have the authority to rewrite
the articles or they certainly have i
suggest attempted to do so on the fly
but that it would have required a remand
to the house of representatives
in order to have a bill of particulars
to judge what they themselves meant when
they passed these articles second just
very briefly i spoke to the issue of
multiplicity or duplicity the other day
and the question of whether rule 23's
revision makes any difference as i
pointed out and i won't embarrass them
any further one member of this body
spoke at length about the importance of
not
loading up multiple offenses into one
count
well after the revision of rule 23
clearly with no sense that this body had
been precluded
from dealing with the critical issue of
whether a two-thirds vote can sensibly
be taken
on an article that contains multiple and
particularly as my colleague mr craig
indicated multiple nonspecific
violations
thank you mr chief justice
senators thompson grassley thurman
allard frist burns and imhoff
direct this question to the president's
council
if the president were a federal judge
accused of committing excuse me the same
acts of perjury and obstruction of
justice and the senate found sufficient
evidence that the acts alleged were
committed should the senate vote to
convict
this will uh
sound half-hearted but it's not i'm glad
you asked that question
uh
this really goes right to the heart
of the manager's argument here which is
that there is no difference
in the consideration of the of the
impeachment process
between an allegation
against a federal judge and an
allegation against the president of the
united states
i will not repeat the extended
discussion of this subject
of a few days ago
but let me try to summarize very briefly
it is absolutely crystal clear from the
history of the drafting of the
impeachment clause
that the concern of the framers was
is there such
actions as so subvert
our government that we can no longer
persist in permitting in their case the
president of the united states
to remain in office
that question must be
dramatically different when you ask it
about
the conduct of one of a thousand judges
beyond that
it is also clear that there has been
extended debate in many forums and at
many times
over the in the past 210 years about
indeed just what the standard is
for the impeachment of judges
and i
hesitate to do this and i do it
apologetically mr chief justice but the
chief justice himself
in an earlier time and in an earlier
guise
spoke to this issue and made it clear
this is during his tenure as assistant
attorney general for the office of legal
counsel when the issue was being debated
whether there was a non-constitutional
non-impeachment device for
disposing of judges alleged to have
engaged in misconduct that may not fall
within the high crimes and misdemeanors
provision of the impeachment clause that
indeed the good behavior standard for
judges was
something far broader than the standard
to be applied under the high crimes and
misdemeanor standard and indeed that
debate was
resumed many years later in the context
of a further effort to establish a
non-constitutional device for removing
judges
that history
and just the core question
do you ask the same questions about
the trauma that the nation suffers when
you are removing a judge and you are
removing a president the answer must be
no
you must ask what's the nature of the
perjury that's been committed what's the
nature of the offense that's been
committed what's the factual setting in
which it occurs and ultimately does it
so
subvert
the accused ability to perform the
duties of his office that you must
remove him
that question for judge nixon convicted
and in prison has got to be
different from different is much too
milder word
stunningly different from the question
you ask against the backdrop of our
history when you ask whether the
president of the united states
should be removed
and the will of the electorate
overturned thank you mr chief justice
uh senators dorgan and baucus and
schumer
uh to the president's council
in councillor ruff's presentation he set
forth a timeline that undermined the
manager's theory the judge wright's
december 11th discovery order triggered
an intensification of the presidents and
jordan's efforts to assist lewinsky in
finding a job
in response to mr ruff's presentation
the managers handed out a press release
outside the senate chamber asserting
that it was the december 5th issuance of
the witness list in the jones case and
not the judge's discovery order on the
11th that triggered the intensification
of the job search
this does not appear consistent with
assertions made by the house managers in
their trial brief and oral presentations
please comment
it was the assertion very clearly voiced
in mr manager hutchinson's presentation
and very clearly made
in the trial brief
of
the
house managers that it was indeed the
december 11th order
that i used the word jump started
yesterday that catalyzed that that
pushed forward the uh jobs
brief you you see them say this sudden
interest was inspired by a court order
entered on december 11
1997.
now
their position could not have been clear
until we began our presentations and
then all of a sudden it wasn't the
december 11th order it was instead
the december 5 witness list
well there are a number of things
to be said about that
one of them was
that they have very clearly said
that there was no urgency at all after
the witness list
arrived to help ms lewinsky
they've said that mr jordan met with the
president on december five
but
that meeting had nothing to do with ms
lewinsky
uh this was in the majority report at
page 11. they said that very clearly uh
so they've now suddenly because it's
been clear
that the december 11th order
was entered at a time when mr jordan was
flying to europe he could not have known
about it he had met with ms lewinsky
earlier that day and indeed that
december 11th meeting had sprung from
actions taken by miss lewinsky in a
phone call with mr jordan in november
they had said that
they'd agreed that when mr jordan
returned to the country they would set
up a meeting
they did that on december 5th
or they she tried to get in touch on
december 5th they tried to get they
finally succeeded in getting in touch on
december 8th and that was not at a time
she knew she was on the witness list so
the point is these were two entirely
separate
chains of events going forward the job
search and the witness list and nothing
supports the intensification theory
presented by the managers certainly not
this new well it wasn't the december
11th order it was the december 5th order
senators asked ashcroft and hatch is
there anyone on the floor who can't hear
me
the white uh
the white house makes much let me see
who this is for the house managers
the white house makes much of the fact
that vernon jordan was on a flight to
holland on december 11th before judge
wright ruled that afternoon that other
women who may have had relationships
while in president clinton's employ were
relevant to the jones suit however the
president was faxed a witness list on
december 5th and actually reviewed it no
later than the 8th
thus isn't the white house argument that
the president had no incentive to assist
ms lewinsky's job search until december
11th
just a red herring
thank you mr chief justice
and i appreciate the opportunity to
respond here and just let me say by
way of preface
that
we're lawyers we're trying to do three
things at once usually have an opening
statement where you outline where you
want to go in a case then you have a
presentation of the evidence then you
have a closing argument and we're trying
to do it all at the same time and for
that reason as i said at my very
beginning of my presentation that you
need to pay attention to the record and
to the facts that's what you depend upon
and i get carried away in my argument
i'm arguing just as they're arguing
their theory of the case we're both
arguing a point of view here and it's up
to you to make the determination i have
great respect for these counselors
they're they're admirable they're doing
a great job for their client and they're
presenting their theory of the case
we're arguing our point of view and it's
the facts that make the determination
now let me go back
to
and you have it in front of you my
presentation exhibit c which i guess is
the third exhibit which is really the
white house exhibit that mr ruff had up
here for a number of days because they
were really trying to hammer home this
statement that i made in my presentation
i hope that you all have that
uh
well i'll tell it to you then uh thank
you
exhibit c which i hope that you'll have
we asked them to distribute that is a
statement that mr ruff portrayed for me
which uh in my presentation i said the
judge the witness list came in the
judge's order came in that triggered the
president into action and the president
triggered vernon jordan into action
now there's two things that i'm pointing
to as the trigger mechanisms for the job
search intensification one of them is
the witness list that comes in on
december 5 the president knows about at
the latest on december 6. the other
thing that intensified that effort was
the judge's order on december 11. now
they went through this long
circumstance of mr jordan being in
holland in the time of a phone call with
a judge and all of that
showing that the judge's order december
11 could not have triggered any action
on the 11th there is no question about
that that is obvious from the facts as
it was obvious when i made my
presentation the meetings on the 11th
with vernon jordan and monica lewinsky
were triggered by the witness list
coming on the fifth that the president
knew about on the sixth that he
discussed with vernon jordan as well
now uh
we say that the judge's order of the
11th which was filed that day uh the
only thing was filed of the 12th was
their memorandum of that telephone
conversation that triggered additional
action down the road the
job search was not over the activity
continued into january
and so that all put pressure on the
ultimate fact in january when the job
was obtained the false affidavit was
filed
now let me just point to a couple other
things along that line we need to look
at this because they basically make the
point that there's not any connection
between the false affidavit and that's
my characterization
that was filed and the job search but if
you look at the
testimony of vernon jordan and that is
uh exhibit i think they're getting them
out now
f that i'm presenting to you the sworn
testimony of vernon jordan which was on
march 3 of 1998 he testifies and answers
to a question counselor the lady comes
to me with a subpoena in the paula jones
case that i know
and as i've testified here today was
about sexual harassment
you didn't have to be an einstein to
know that that was a question that had
to be asked by me at that particular
time because heretofore this discussion
was about a job
and then he says
the subpoena changed the circumstances
and i think this is important
that
mr jordan who's filled with common sense
he says you don't have to be an einstein
you don't have to be learned like mr
ruff or any of the other white house
counsel to apply common sense common
sense tells you that whenever he knew
about the subpoena
it escalated to a new arena and
obviously the witness list would have
the same impact and so mr jordan himself
makes the connection
the job search was one thing but
whenever she became a witness in the
jones case that changed everything that
changed the circumstances and let me
tell you that's a friend of the
president who is making that statement
and so we have to take this picture
that
they were related as they were
going two tracks they became
interconnected and became one track the
final point and this was raised in the
job search issue that that the call by
mr jordan
to mr pearlman
uh the ceo
of the parent company of revlon really
had no impact on
monica lewinsky getting a job because
there's a misinterpretation as how well
she did in the interview but if you look
back to the testimony grand jury
testimony there was a connection because
mr jordan calls mr pearlman
and as he characterized it make it
happen if you if it can happen mr
pearlman then calls mr durnam
and then mr durnam calls miss siedman
who was actually doing the interview the
next day with monica lewinsky and so the
person who is going to make the decision
whether to hire monica lewinsky got the
word down through the channel
before that interview took place before
the decision was made and of course the
important thing is what's the intent not
the result but the intent and i think
that you can see that there was an
intent to make sure that monica lewinsky
was taken care of again she was on board
part of the team
before she actually
would have to give testimony or the
president would have to give testimony
this question is from senator boxer and
it's to counsel for the president
in light of the confession of manager
hutchinson that judge wright's order had
no bearing on the intensity of the job
search can you comment on the balance of
his claim on the previous question
chief justice could i object to the form
of the question
that was not proper characterizing what
uh i just uh stated
uh i don't i don't think the manager i'm
not sure whether the managers can the
managers object to a question
very well i think uh the parliamentarian
says they can only object to an answer
and not to a question which is kind of
an unusual thing but
mr chief justice i was going to remark
that they can if they have the courage
uh
i want to link up
my response to manager hutchinson's most
recent comments with the previous
discussion about vagueness
if there was ever a moving target
we've just seen it in motion
well it really wasn't december 11th
because now we know it didn't happen on
december 11th so let's go to december
19th or maybe january 8th
and somewhere in there we're gonna find
uh the right answer i suggest to you
that that
is uh reflective
of
both the difficulty we have had in
coming to grips with these charges and
candidly the difficulty that the house
uh might have had in figuring out what
those charges really were
let me just respond uh briefly to mr
manager hutchinson's argument
uh and let me focus first on another
portion of his presentation
and which he states
and there and he's referring now to ms
lewinsky she's referring to a december
6th meeting with the president
uh in which as you'll recall
she has testified that there was a brief
discussion about her efforts to get a
job through mr jordan and the president
sort of vaguely said yes i'll i'll do
something about that
and this is
mr manager hutchinson's characterization
of that moment and december 6th you'll
recall uh is the day after the witness
list comes out
and uh the day on which he learns of it
so you can see from that that it was not
a high priority for the president either
it was sure i'll get to that i will do
that
but then the president's attitude
suddenly changed what started out as a
favor for betty curry dramatically
changed after ms lewinsky became a
witness and the judge's order was issued
again on december 11.
but to the extent that the managers now
seek to drag the intensification process
back into the december 5th or 6th period
which is when ms lewinsky went on to the
witness list
you must look at what they say
page 11 majority brief mr jordan met
prince president clinton the next day
december 7th
but they didn't discuss the job at all
now it's absolutely clear that the
president knew that ms lewinsky was on
the witness list when he met with mr
jordan
on december 7th
and yet the issue of monica lewinsky
didn't even surface
i'm getting some help here
the first the first their words page 11
majority brief majority report the first
activity calculated to help ms lewinsky
actually get a job took place on
december 11th
there was no urgency
now
it's possible of course
as their trial brief reflects
to
bob and weave and dodge around the facts
here
but their trial brief says
there was obvious and referring to the
period after she appears on the witness
list there was obviously still no
urgency to help ms lewinsky
and even they acknowledge that the
december 7th meeting with mr jordan was
unrelated to ms lewinsky
but let me
point because i think this really goes
to the heart of it
to what the managers ask you to think
about
in this context in which now whether we
can
call it a confession or simply an
acknowledgement
what they ask you to do
when you heard the recitation about the
december 11th events
we now know mr jordan is flying over the
atlantic at the critical moment
and here is what mr manager hutchinson
asks you to do
with vernon jordan
distinguished citizen distinguished
lawyer
now if we had mr jordan on the witness
stand which i hope to be able to call mr
jordan you would need to probe where his
loyalties lie listen to the tone of his
voice look into his eyes and determine
the truthfulness of his statements
you must decide whether he's telling the
truth or withholding information there's
only one message there
vernon jordan must have been lying
or at least there's enough question
about his credibility and his honesty
and his decency to explore whether he
was lying
if you predicate that question
on the shall we say erroneous recitation
of events
on december 11th
you need to know nothing more
about what
the timeline and the chronology and the
manager's theory of this case is all
about
thank you mr chief judson
this question is from
senator sessions
graham of texas smith of new hampshire
imhope allard roberts it's directed to
the house managers
in defense of the president ms mills has
repeatedly stated and has just
reiterated that the crime of witness
tampering requires some element of
threat intimidation or pressure
isn't it true that section 1512 b
criminalizes anyone who corruptly
persuades or engages in misleading
conduct with the intent to influence the
testimony of any person in an official
proceeding please explain
mr chief justice we appreciate the
question from the senators since it
bears on
a number of different questions and a
great deal of the evidence that you all
have heard in this case
one can talk around the law one can talk
about the law one can ignore the law
and as we've seen one can break the law
but one has to deal with the law
in court and in these proceedings
and that is why throughout these
proceedings the senators have heard us
as the house managers on behalf of the
house of representatives and as the
presenters of this case against the
president
refer repeatedly and explicitly to the
actual language of the statutes which
form the basis for the articles of
impeachment against president william
jefferson clinton
council mills
has in fact misrepresented
the law of tampering with witnesses as
set forth very explicitly
in section 1512 of title 18 of the
united states code
in her arguments two days ago
ms mills quite expressly stated
that one of the elements that a
prosecutor must charge
and that must be found here
if indeed article two which is
obstruction of justice should lie as the
basis for a conviction thereon
one must find
that tampering under 1512
requires
threats or coercion
nothing could be further from the truth
now if in fact ms mills had stated to
this body
that one of the bases one of several
bases on which a prosecutor or we as
house managers
could indeed
show this body
that tampering with a witness would lie
includes
as an alternative as an option
threats or coercion
she would have instead of being
misleading been absolutely correct that
was not her position
section 1512
of the united states code
expressly does not require
threats of force
intimidation or coercion it may be based
on
the person
corruptly persuading another person
or engaging in misleading conduct toward
another person both of which are terms
the definition for which are not found
in the ether but are found
yet further reading in title 18
neither of them requires threats
intimidation or coercion
moreover in considering whether or not
section 1512 or indeed
its companion section 1503
also
obstruction of justice under the u.s
criminal code
which also
does not require
for a conviction to lie thereon
threats
of force intimidation or coercion but
also
may be and is based on corruptly
influencing
those terms are expressly defined and
dealt with not only in the definitional
provisions of title 18 and including
specifically definitions that apply to
these provisions these sections but also
in the case law
and we would respectfully direct the
attention of the senators in reviewing
the law of obstruction of justice and
the law of tampering with witnesses
to some of the very cases cited by
the attorneys for the president in their
effort to deflect attention away from
these particular provisions of the law
as they apply to the conduct of the
president
for example in her presentation
presidential council mills relied on the
supreme court case of usv aguilar in her
statements
in that case the court held that a lie
told to a criminal investigator
was insufficient to prove witness
tampering
what ms phil mills failed to disclose
however was that the court's decision in
that case in that aguilar case
was based on a specific finding not
applicable to the facts of this case
that the evidence was insufficient to
prove that the defendant could have even
thought
that the investigator was a potential
witness at the time that he lied to him
the overwhelming body of evidence in
this case as we have heard yet this
morning most recently response to
questions
is that not only
could the president
and the president did in fact reasonably
presume
indeed almost invite
the lawyers in the jones case to
subpoena miss curry as a witness but we
have found contrary to the prior
misleading statements of council ruff
she was in fact
subpoenaed and called as a witness
therefore we believe
that on both arguments raised by council
for the president seeking to deflect
attention away from and render
inapplicable
both obstruction provisions 1503 and
1512
because they won
require as we have shown they do not but
they would argue they require
coercion threats intimidation or force
or two because the president they are
inapplicable because because the
president could not have reasonably
believed or did not know that miss curry
was a witness could reasonably be
expected to be a witness at the time of
the coercion that it took place
i would yield for one minute to house
manager graham i think the time i will
not yield one minute to house manager
graham
senator byrd to the president's council
alexander hamilton in federalist essay
number 65 states that the subjects of
impeachment are
those offenses which proceed from the
misconduct of public men or in other
words from the abuse or violation of
some public trust
putting aside the specific legal
questions concerning perjury and
obstruction of justice how does the
president defend against the charge that
by giving false and misleading
statements under oath such misconduct
abused or violated some public trust
mr chief justice uh
this too goes
to the very heart
of
the deliberations in which you must
engage
at the end of these proceedings
as i've tried
to make clear
in my earlier arguments
it is not enough simply i think to ask
does a particular
generic form of misconduct however
serious it may be
lead in inexorably to the conclusion
that the president of the united states
has committed an impeachable offense
as the framers made clear and
i think the history that lay behind
their deliberations and the history that
has followed made clear
when we speak of
the kind of political in caps which is
what it was in federalist 65
offenses against the man in his
public role
we speak of offenses
which this body must ultimately judge
as being
so violative of
his public responsibilities
that our system cannot abide his
continuing in office
let us assume for a moment and we will
disagree with each and every element of
the accusation but let us assume for the
moment that this body were to conclude
that the president lied in the grand
jury
about
his relationship with ms lewinsky
that in and of itself does not lead
to the judgment and in our view must not
lead to the judgment
that
he is to be removed from office
it must give you pause you must think
carefully about it but ultimately you
must ask
despite our
rejection of any such conduct whether it
be a judge or a president or any other
civil officer
have the framers instructed us
to remove
from his office and to overturn the will
of the electorate a president who
admittedly if you conclude
that he did
violate the law in this regard
has violated a public trust in the
broadest sense as each of us does
who serves the public if we do anything
other than that which are our proper and
assigned responsibilities and do them
with the utmost of integrity each of us
violates that trust if we don't meet
that standard but the one thing we can
be certain of
is that the framers understood
the frailties that they were dealing
with they understood the nature of the
offense that had been the background of
impeachment proceedings in england and
certainly
the framers in their debate made it
clear
that it has to be at the highest level
of public trust the breach of the public
trust
that
embodied in the words treason
bribery selling your office
and similar other
high crimes and misdemeanors
and so all i ask the senators in this
regard
is not to simply leap as the managers
would have you do it
from the definition of the offense or
the statute governing the conduct
but to ask the constitutional question
as i know you will the framers
question if we haven't convinced you on
the facts i hope we'll convince you that
the framers would have asked
is our system so in danger
that we must
not only
turn the president over
to the
same rule of law that any other citizen
would be put under
after he leaves office but must we
cut short his term and overturn the will
of the nation
and in our view
in the worst case scenario you can
find
the answer to that question
must still be no
thank you mr chief
senator lot asks the house managers
do the managers wish to respond to the
answer just given by the president's
council
mr chief justice members of the senate
we would briefly respond
to the
response just given by council for the
president
we believe that
the response
and the position taken by the council
for the president here really involves
two
great errors
one error
is in establishing
a standard of conduct
for the presidency that is too low
the other error
is in attempting to minimize
the significance of the offenses that
this president
has been charged with and which we
submit to you
the evidence
supports
the charges
now we do not submit
that any president
this president whoever it may be
should be impeached and removed from
office
for trivial or insubstantial offenses
we believe that an essential part of the
focus of your inquiry
must be on whether there was a serious
corrupt intent involved in the
underlying conduct
a president should not be impeached and
removed from office for a mistake of
judgment
he should not be impeached and removed
for a momentary lapse
instead
he should be impeached and removed if he
engages
in a conscious and deliberate and
settled choice to do wrong
a conscious and deliberate and settled
choice to violate
the laws of this land
and we submit
that he must be impeached and removed if
he does that
because in doing so
he has violated his oath of office
in doing so he has turned away
from the unique role
which he has under our constitution
as the chief executive
charged with ensuring that the laws be
faithfully executed
he steps aside from that role
and takes on the role of one who attacks
the rule of law
and it is for that reason
that we believe
that this president
should be removed
and we would further submit
that the
attempt to minimize the significance
of the conduct of this president
does
a disservice to the laws of this land
the attempt to minimize this course of
conduct which started out as an effort
to deprive
a plaintiff in a civil rights case
of her
just day in court
is a serious course of conduct
a course of conduct which brings
disrespect on the office of the
presidency and indeed undermines the
integrity of the office of the
presidency the integrity of the judicial
system
and it is for all of those reasons that
we would submit to you
that the president's council's efforts
uh to persuade you that this course of
conduct is not impeachable or not
persuasive and should not be accepted by
the senate in this case
uh senators torricelli and rockefeller
asked
to the president's council
the house managers have made the overly
broad argument that nothing in the text
structure or history of the constitution
suggests that officials are subject to
impeachment only for official conduct
can this unbending argument be
reconciled with the following statement
from justice james wilson
our president is amenable to the laws in
his private character as a citizen and
in his public character by impeachment
and with the standard adopted by a
bipartisan majority in the watergate
proceedings
mr chief justice
senators
i could
probably simply say no
given
the articulate framing of that question
and i would have said as much
as needed to be said
i think the managers have
in their straw man building
role
tried to suggest that our position
somehow
is so distant from constitutional
realities and the realities of the
operations of our government
that we could not conceive of a
situation in which
private conduct no matter how egregious
would lead to removal and of course
that's not the case
none of us could contemplate a setting
in which even personal conduct
if
and i need not go through any examples
was so egregious that
the people simply could not contemplate
the notion of the president remaining in
office but other than that if there is
one message that comes out not only of
judge wilson but of the entire debate of
1787
and all
of the commentaries since then
is that indeed the focus of attention
must be
and this goes back to in large measure
to senator byrd's question
must be on the public character of the
man
the political and broader sense
character of the man and of his acts
and if you look back at the 1974
writings of the house judiciary
committee both majority and minority so
this is not a partisan
view
it makes it absolutely they make it
absolutely clear
that the house then believed something
which they must either not believe today
or have ignored as they engaged in their
discussions
which is that the test to be applied
is whether
the president in this case has so abused
a public trust so abused the powers of
his office
that he goes to the very
heart of what the framers had in mind in
1787 when they
carefully defined and carefully limited
the range of activity that could lead to
contemplation of removal
and that is not a range of activity that
with all due respect touches any
where near the conduct that you have
before you today
senator nichols asks the house managers
the president's council stated the
president did not commit perjury please
respond
mr chief justice i trust that the
presumption of five minutes is a
rebuttable one correct
i will uh do my best not to have to go
beyond
the time i thank the senator for the
question
first as just as a predicate obviously
in five minutes
i could not do a comprehensive review
on the perjury aspects of this case so
let me just start with a preliminary
issue and we can move on with different
questions and revisit the issue at
another time if anybody wants a lesson
in legal schizophrenia
please read the president's trial brief
on this very subject
they skirt the issue by saying nowhere
in the president's grand jury deposition
did he ever affirm the truth
of his civil deposition testimony
but they won't come out and say he lied
they won't come out and say he perjured
himself and they tried to ignore the
actual fact of when the president was
asked questions about his oath that he
took during the grand jury i read
therefrom
question to the president you understand
the oath requires you to give the whole
truth that is a complete answer to each
question sir answer i will answer each
question as accurately and fully as i
can question to the president now you
took the same oath to tell the truth the
whole truth and nothing but the truth
on january 17th 1998 in a deposition in
the paula jones litigation is that
correct sir
answer i did take an oath there
question did the oath you took on that
occasion mean the same to you then as it
does today answer i believe then that i
had to answer the questions truthfully
that's correct the colloquy goes on it
is in your materials
they attempt to say that that somehow
inoculates the president
from having to admit that he perjured
himself
during the paula jones deposition but
let's take a quick look
at some of the answers he gave during
the paula jones deposition
that he affirmed in his grand jury
testimony that we now know
is false question to the president
if she paul if she monica lewinsky told
someone she had a sexual affair with you
beginning in november 1995 would that be
a lie answer it's certainly not the
truth it would not be the truth question
i think i used the term sexual affair
and so the record is completely clear
have you ever had sexual relations with
monica lewinsky as that term is defined
in deposition exhibit number one answer
i have never had sexual relations with
monica lewinsky i've never had an affair
with her
and then they go on to ask him
is it true that when monica lewinsky
worked at the white house
she met with you several times answer i
don't know about several times there was
a period when the republican congress
shut the government down the whole white
house staff was being run by interns she
was assigned to work back in the chief
of staff's office we were all working
there i saw her on two or three
occasions then and then when she worked
at the white house i think there were
one or two times when she brought some
documents down to me
question at any time were you and monica
lewinsky in the hallway between the oval
office and the kitchen area answer i
don't believe so unless we were walking
back to the dining room with pizzas i i
just don't remember i don't believe we
were in the hallway no this colloquy
goes on and on i invite the senate to
review the president's deposition
testimony he clearly was giving answers
that were false they were not a part of
the record he wasn't doing it to protect
himself from embarrassment he was doing
it to defeat paula jones's sexual
harassment case and when the president
testified in august before the grand
jury
he never denied the truth of those
testimonies he refused to admit that he
lied during the deposition he reiterated
the truth of those because he knew he
would be subject to perjury so the
question for the president's council is
simply this and it is a simple question
and it doesn't need to be parsed did the
president lie under oath on january 17th
when he was asked questions about the
nature of his relationship with monica
lewinsky did he lie when the united
states supreme court had said she that
paula jones had a right to proceed in a
sexual harassment case did he lie when
judge susan weber wright ordered him to
answer those basic questions under oath
and if the answer to that question is
yes
then we have an incredible admission if
the answer is no i invite them to point
to the record where that is demonstrated
us to the president's council from
senators conrad and torricelli
the house of representatives reject two
rejected two proposed articles of
impeachment including an article
alleging perjury in the jones deposition
do you believe that the senate may
consistent with its constitutional role
convict and remove the president based
on the allegations underlying the
rejecting article rejected articles
including the allegations of perjury
mr chief justice
article two was defeated
but more importantly
article one
specifically
incorporates by reference or tries to
incorporate by reference all the
elements of article two
and the house of representatives when
they voted
to reject
article two
i think voted also to eliminate these
issues that you've just heard about now
we predicted and our prediction has come
true that
the managers would like to argue this
case
if you look at the final point if you
look at the majority report
that has come that comes out before the
vote occurs on all four articles
and you go to article one
and you try to find out where in article
one
they define
those perjurious statements
that compose subpart two which is
the civil deposition
you will see in that majority report
they say
go look at article 2 which is the
argument about the
civil deposition
and the house of representatives
specifically voted to take out all those
accusations and allegations of
misconduct with respect to the civil
deposition now i have testified as has
mr ruff
before the judiciary committee
on this issue
and i have said that the president's
responses in the jones deposition were
surely evasive
that they surely were incomplete
that they surely were intended to
mislead
and it was wrong for him to do all that
but they were not produced and if you
want to try a perjury case
about all the things and the statements
that the house of representatives did
not want to accuse him of
that would be inconsistent i think with
your duty
as of
members of this court
you cannot impeach the president on the
issues that are included in article two
he was not impeached
that you cannot remove thank you
see justice i believe we've had an equal
number of questions although the time
they might not be exactly equal but i
would ask unanimous consent that would
take a uh 15-minute recess at this point
in the absence of objection it's so hard
as the senate stands in a short recess
in this seventh day of the impeachment
trial of the president the first day of
the questioning by the senators of the
house managers and the president's
council 16 hours allotted over the next
several days so far
senators have used about an hour and 40
minutes of that time this again another
opportunity for you to phone us with
your comments and observations and what
you've seen in these seven days of the
impeachment
the senate will convene as a court of
impeachment the chaplain will offer a
prayer
almighty god
you have taught us to seek and maintain
unity
you've also taught us that this unity
is so precious that we should be willing
to sacrifice anything
in order to maintain it
except the truth
help us to affirm the great
undeniable truths that twine the bond of
oneness
we are one nation under your sovereignty
our patriotism binds us together
inseparably
our commitment to the constitution
is unswerving
in these bonds that cannot be broken
the senate has been able to deal with
the arguments
issues and opinions of this impeachment
trial
continue to inspire the senators with
civility
as they work through answers to the
questions raised today
refresh and rejuvenate
those who may be weary or burdened
dear god
preserve the unity of this senate
for its future leadership of our beloved
nation
in your holy name
amen
the deputy sergeant-at-arms will make
the proclamation
hear ye hear ye hear ye
all persons are commanded to keep silent
on pain of imprisonment while the senate
of the united states is sitting for the
trial of the articles of impeachment
exhibited by the house of
representatives against william
jefferson clinton president of the
united states
if there's no objection the journal of
proceedings of the trial are approved to
date
pursuant to the provisions of senate
resolution 16
there are 11 hours and 54 minutes
remaining during which senators may
submit questions in writing
directed to either the managers on the
part of the house of representatives or
the council for the president
the majority leader is recognized
thank you mr chief justice and thank you
chaplain uh for your opening prayer i
know we all listened and and
appreciated the admonitions that were
given in that that prayer
uh
i want to say again i appreciate the
participation by all the senators
yesterday 50 questions were asked i
think a lot of good questions and
obviously good responses we have a
considerable amount of time left for
questions
but again it's our intent to
go today as long as the senators feel
that they have a need for further
questions we don't uh it's up to 16
hours doesn't require 16 hours so i
think we should go forward and and try
to ask the the needed questions and and
then uh get a sense of where we are as
we go uh through the day uh but at any
rate uh it would be our intent not to go
later than uh 4 p.m
we hope to take a one-hour lunch break
sometime around 12 to 12 30 but it'll
depend on you know how the question is
going we'll also uh take a a break here
and an hour hour and a half something
like that
following today's session the senate
will reconvene on monday at 1 pm and
resume consideration of articles
impeachment all members will be notified
of the details of monday's schedule and
beyond that
once we've had an opportunity for a
consultation with between senator
daschle and myself and we get a feel of
exactly
what
s-res 16 provides in terms of activities
on monday
and tuesday
in a continuing effort to make this as
bipartisan and fair as possible uh
you'll note yesterday while we
alternated back and forth uh some of the
questions were directed from uh this
side to the president's council and and
the reverse and i'm sure that'll happen
again some today we begin with the first
question yesterday uh and uh and you
concluded so today we would uh reverse
that and uh senator daschle will ask the
first question and then we'll go through
the process until we complete those uh
questions with us ending with the last
question sometime today
if that mr chief justice i view the
floor
this question is directed to the house
managers from senator reed of nevada
would you please tell us whether you
provided notice to counsel for the
president or to any official of the
united states senator senate of the
manager's discussion with the office of
independent council regarding an
informal interview of ms lewinsky and
the intention of the office of
independent council to file a motion in
court to compel ms lewinsky to meet with
the managers if you provided no such
notice to counsel for the president or
the senate please tell us why not
mr chief justice and senators
distinguished colleagues
this has
i know the answer to your question i'm
not aware of any such notice that was
provided
as described in the question
i would like to make some clarification
on this and in terms of
the
witness of monica lewinsky the potential
witness
as
we have been in an evolving discussion
over the last few weeks in terms of if
we are allowed to call witnesses by the
senate
what who those witnesses might be what
our list might look like
and obviously the name of monica
lewinsky comes up as
as a potentially
very important witness to these
proceedings
as
many of us in this chamber have had
experience in in the law
we very much would like to talk to some
of these witnesses
uh the core group that we have
considered however
are
in essence in the white house control
they either are employed by the white
house or
are close friends and associates
associates of the white house and and
i'm sure the white house through the
attorneys would be very willing to
cooperate with us in making those people
available
however miss lewinsky presents a very
unique situation in that she is uh
geographically some other place i'm not
sure where she is maybe los angeles
maybe new york maybe washington but she
has attorneys that we have to deal with
and it would be very critical as any
attorney in this body knows
that before you
you actually talk to a witness and a
witness of that importance to this
proceeding that you you
for your producer for that testimony
that you talk to her and it was intended
to be a conversation to discuss it with
her
we understand i have personally not seen
the immunity agreement that she has but
we understand
there is a cooperation proceeding and
that that agreement is between her her
attorneys and the independent counsel
the oic not not congress not the
managers not the senate uh so we have no
duty no no legal standing as as i
understand it to go in and enforce that
agreement were she not to want to meet
with us and cooperate
pursuant to the terms of those
agreements
to the agreement we did contact the oic
to to arrange that meeting and once we
understood that
the attorneys did not want to cooperate
and furnish their counsel to their
clients meet with us then we asked the
oic to pursue
further
the effort to have mr winsky come in and
meet with us on an informal basis as
again anyone would do in a in
preparation for calling a witness at a
trial thank you
this is a question from senators
fitzgerald hatch smith of oregon
thurman senator thurman directed to the
house managers
how do you address the white house's
argument that removal is a
disproportionate remedy for the alleged
acts of perjury and obstruction of
justice and should there be any
particular concern about establishing a
precedent that a president can commit
felonies while in office and remain
president of the united states
mr justice
i think the proportionality question
yesterday was
was very good
in that there is a psychology to be used
in judicial decisions
i think there are different factors that
will influence that decision-making
process and the ideals that that you as
a sitting judge and juror will use to
strive to to attain them
it's important i think also to have
reasonableness and just solutions if
you're going to individualize the case
as some may hope to do
i think as a society if you take a step
back we're kind of caught in two diverse
trends at the moment you have one trend
whereby judges like to seek the
individualized solutions to
particularize cases and the other trend
is
we'll apply the law to individualized
cases
so let me give you two two best examples
of both of those with regard to the best
example of individualized solutions to a
particular case would be our juvenile
justice system
that's where the court will come in and
use a variety of means because
reformation is in fact the goal and
that's what we do in the juvenile court
system
as a side note of that i think in in
society with regard to
it could be a an act of of a firing it
could be an administrative hearing for
removal it could even be a governor
who had an employee
who had an illicit affair
and and it was a political appointee and
that governor decided maybe he decided
applying proportionality he would remove
his own political appointee for having
an affair
so the individualization can occur out
there the other example i'll comment on
is is the justice according to law
and that other trend out there caught in
our society our legislatures not only
here in washington but across all the in
our state jurisdictions you have
legislatures that are beginning to take
some of the decision-making processes
away from judges and they're saying
specifically in federal sentencing
guidelines as an example that if in fact
a person is convicted of a particular
crime or possession of cocaine the
legislature are now telling these judges
exactly this is in fact what your
sentence will be so we we're kind of
caught i want you to know
as you are sitting as as judges and
jurors in this diverse trend that's
occurring in our society and i i and i
know that as you listen to lectures even
from the supreme court justices they are
well aware of these trends and so you're
you're sitting and you have to come in
your own conscience on how to best make
that particular decision i will note
though that we have stressed
uh the latter we have stressed that the
the rule of law and it's important to
our society not only to serve the public
and social interest
but you
are the guardian
when in fact there are crimes against
the state
who is there to serve the public
interest
especially if in fact
it is the president the vice president a
judicial officer or
or other civil officers here where you
have the president of the united states
who's been accused of perjury and
obstruction of justice for which are
crimes against the state and as
blackstone said are side by side with
bribery
who is the guardian then of the public
interest
so in the question of proportionality it
is you
it is you so when mr craig began by
arguing that this trial is not about
vindicating the rule of law that only
criminal courts are charged with that
duty
i would respectfully
submit
that the president's council is
confusing the punishment of a particular
criminal case or controversy in a court
with your duty of congress to ensure
that future officers entrusted with
power granted by the people may not
while their offices eviscerate the
proper administration of justice which
is a cornerstone of our republic i now
yield to mr grant
i know i got a minute
great
great minds can differ on this one can
you have a high crime
and for the good of the nation
removal is not appropriate
and i was asked that yesterday and i
kind of
wanted to make a case about why i think
this is not trivial but it's a great
question the problem we have here is
that you run into the judge cases
when you find that the judge perjured
himself
you remove the judge the president is
different than the judge i'll certainly
certainly
concede that but we don't want i think
in the use of proportionality create a
standard that doesn't make any sense
that confuses people
the law loves repentance baptists love
repentance i'm a baptist we
my church everybody gets saved about
every other week
the
the idea that if you'll come forward
and you admit your wrongs you get a
different result is is loved in the law
another thing to consider about
proportionality is the impact on society
i think you should consider that i think
very much you should consider even if
this is a high crime the impact on our
society if you decided to make the
ultimate punishment
the death penalty
of political crimes is removal from
office and i started that train of
thought three months ago impeachment is
equivalent to the political death
penalty and every felony doesn't allow
you to have the death penalty
what i hope you will be able to do as a
wise body
is not leave this confusion behind
whether or not it's a crime
ladies and gentlemen senate it can be a
high crime
and you then have to decide the impact
on society
but if you leave us confused
about whether or not this is a crime or
not
the impact on society is far greater
than if you make the
decision
of it's a crime
but proportionally
is not what the death penalty would call
for it would not be political death
penalty case
thank you very much
this question is from senator lay to the
house managers did any of the managers
consult with any member of the senate
before seeking aid from kenneth starr to
speak with mrs ms lewinsky
did you discuss whether this violated
the senate's 100 to nothing vote on
trial procedure
mr chief justice uh members of the
senate the question is certainly a valid
question to ask we did not consult with
any senators about this we don't think
that what we wanted to do to talk to
miss lewinsky had anything to do with
the rules that you've passed we do not
want to violate those rules and we don't
think that we have
as anybody who knows if you have a
witness that you're going to produce you
have a right to prepare that witness
it's as plain and simple as that i've
practiced a lot of trial law before i
came to congress a number of you have if
you're going to have a deposition given
it's going to be your witness you're
going to go down and try to talk to that
witness and prepare that witness you
have the right to do that and the
obligation to do that has nothing to do
with the formal proceeding of taking the
deposition
which is covered by the rules that you
passed as to how and when depositions
will be taken it has nothing to do with
the issue of her testimony actually here
where the opposing counsel would have a
right to be present it has everything to
do with the right of anyone to prepare
their witness to get to know their
witness to shake hands to say hello to
put a face on that it is normal practice
to do this and we see in no way how that
abrogates this and
rule or in any way violates what you set
forth as a matter of fact we think we
would have been incompetent and derelict
as presenters of the witnesses if we get
a chance to present them if we hadn't
talked to her we tried to do this
some time ago
we suggested to her attorneys that it
would be appropriate to quietly have
this discussion to meet her as you
normally would i think they were
apprehensive they wanted the court order
i guess to force this to occur and
that's why we have eventually gone to do
that thank you
a question from senators lot and thurman
to the house managers
please give specific examples of
conflicting testimony or an incomplete
record where the calling of witnesses
would prove beneficial to the senate
thank you mr chief justice good morning
to everyone
i want to echo what my colleagues have
said that we're trying to be prepared
we're trying to move through this
process expeditiously
but we do believe that
we need to call witnesses and secondly
that we should be prepared
and without any delay to proceed forward
in the event we are granted that
opportunity and one of the reasons that
the calling of witnesses is important is
because there exists conflict in the
testimony the white house counselors the
president united states has denied each
and every allegation under the two
articles that have been submitted to
this body
i have focused on the obstruction of
justice and each of the seven elements
of the obstruction of justice has been
denied by the president this puts it all
an issue for example let's start with
the issue of the line to the age the
president united states said he was
truthful with his aides to mr john
podesta and mr sidney blumenthal and yet
if you look at the testimony of mr john
podesta
where he says the president came in and
denied
having any sex of any kind with miss
lewinsky and goes into the details of
that that is in direct conflict with the
testimony of the president united states
and the same thing is true with the
testimony mr blumenthal versus the
testimony of the president of the united
states if you go to another conflict and
the testimonies between the president
and monica lewinsky in a number of
different areas
first of all in regard to the gifts
the president said
and i told her that if they asked for
gifts she had to give them
that's the president's testimony and yet
miss lewinsky says that in that
conversation the president said when
asked about the gifts giving them to
betty he says i don't know or let me
think about it again direct conflict
between monica lewinsky and the
president
in regard to
monica lewinsky and coaching her
testimony or suggesting to her that
maybe you can sign an affidavit you can
always say you were coming to see betty
or that you were bringing me letters
this is the testimony of monica lewinsky
what does the president say in regard to
that he said that he never
talk to her about a cover story in a
legal context in other words it's a
denial of obstruction of witness
tampering in contrast to the testimony
of monica lewinsky obviously there's a
conflict in the details of the
relationship there's a conflict between
the testimony of monica lewinsky and
vernon jordan in three different areas
miss lewinsky said that she shared with
mr jordan some details of the
relationship mr jordan says that was not
accurate
miss lewinsky says
in a particular meeting that mr jordan
where they discussed about
notes that she had been keeping and mr
jordan said go home and make sure they
are not there mr jordan denies that uh
in
in another area on the affidavit ms
lewinsky says that she brought to mr
jordan the affidavit and he assisted in
making some corrections mr jordan does
not recall that so there's conflicts
between miss lewinsky and mr jordan
there's conflicts between miss curry and
mr and the president
in regards to the coaching incident the
miss curry said the statements were made
and taken in the sense that the
president wished me to agree with this
with the statement the president says i
was trying to get as much information as
quickly as i could
and obviously
betty curry testified before the grand
jury before the president did and there
was never any follow-up questions i
would want to ask her what did you say
in response did you provide any
information that the president was
soliciting at that particular moment
according to the defense that he has
asserted and so there is a conflict
there
there is a conflict between the
president and the in a witness that we
would offer from the deposition the
president denies that he focused on what
attorney bennett was stating in
reference to the false affidavit i
believe that we can offer a witness it
could be in the form of an affidavit or
a deposition that would testify that he
was focusing he was paying attention and
so there's clear conflicts in the record
that can only be established through the
presenting of additional questions or
additional witnesses the need for
witnesses is so basic and fundamental to
our truth-seeking system of justice in
this country that words fail me in
making the case that we should call
witnesses and that you should permit it
in this proceeding
we are sympathetic totally with the time
frames and the time constraints of the
united states senate and for that reason
we will pair our witness list we will
accommodate a quick session
the white house counselor said this is
going to drag on for months well if it
drags on for months it is because they
want it to drag on for months we will do
all that we can to end this in a timely
fashion and the american people and the
united states senate needs to understand
that why are the white house counselors
so concerned about witnesses
many of these witnesses are friendly to
them we're it in a true seeking endeavor
and i would respectfully submit that the
calling of witnesses would help resolve
the conflicts that i have recited
this is a question from senator dodd to
the council for the president
do you believe that a fundamental
question of fairness and due
process
has been
raised by the failure of the house
managers to notify you of the proposed
lewinsky interview
or
by your exclusion from that interview
and do you
[Music]
wish also to respond to mr hutchinson's
comments
if i may mr chief justice i'll use
most of my time on the first part of
that question and try to perhaps squeeze
in a few
comments on the second part
i am not going to seek here this morning
to vindicate the interests of this body
that is for others
but i do think it useful to
speak for a bit about the interests of
the accused the president of the united
states
it's odd as i think we listened to the
managers explain
what they were seeking to do
to put that in the context of what we
know was actually happening here
it was suggested that
they wanted to just have a conversation
like any lawyer getting ready for a
trial
would want to have a conversation
with a witness before he or she put the
witness
into a deposition or on trial
that
it was sort of normal for a trial lawyer
to do this
i think one of the managers suggested
they just wanted to say hello
put a face on it
and they even suggested
that counsel for ms lewinsky wanted a
court order to force their client to
testify
well
as we'll all see once the record is made
available to everyone that last point
is sure nonsense
but i suggest
the earlier suggestions that just a
friendly little chat
was all they were looking for
it's belied by the notion that what we
have here
is the managers using
their quote institutional role unquote
to get the independent counsel
to join with them
and use the authority that he has under
the immunity agreement to threaten ms
lewinsky with jail
to threaten her
with violation of her immunity agreement
and opening up the prospect of
prosecution if they do not meet
in a friendly little conversation just
say hello just like to meet you
gathering with the managers
can you
imagine
what that little conversation is going
to look like
held in the independent council's office
with the people there who have the
capacity to put ms lewinsky in jail
while there is this friendly little
conversation
just say hello
normal everyday
discussion between a trial lawyer and
the witness he'd like to get to know
from the perspective of my client
for the moment putting aside the rules
which you all agreed on as to how we
ought to proceed
can we really say
that it's just normal
just okay
to have one side using
the might and majesty of the independent
council's office
threatening a witness
with violation of an immunity agreement
if she doesn't agree to fly across the
country and meet for this friendly
little chat i think not
i don't know whether i've got a minute
or two left but
on the issue of conflicts
this is of course something that
has been the subject of much discourse
over the last few days
but let me just take a couple of
examples put to you by manager
hutchinson
the issue of the statements made by the
president to mr podesta and mr
blumenthal there's no conflict in
testimony here
president indeed
said that he was trying to keep his
aides from becoming witnesses he even
said that he didn't even remember his
conversation with mr podesta but he took
as true this is what he said in the
grand jury he accepted as true
if mr blumenthal said this is what that
conversation sounded like mr podesta
said that's what the conversation was
there was no conflict the president
indeed adopted in the grand jury what
those people would say and of course he
didn't
put them into the grand jury in order to
repeat
some or to mislead the grand jury as to
their knowledge
they told they testified truthfully in
the grand jury when they recited their
conversations with the president but i
want to move just a second to something
you've never heard before in the entire
days that we've been sitting here
we heard little hints about how vernon
jordan might be a liar
of what he said
about december 11th and all of a sudden
just five minutes ago this body heard
for the first time that he's not only
maybe a liar
about the
job search but he's maybe a liar about
destroying evidence
words fail me
this is a question from senator abraham
to the president's council
is it your position that ms lewinsky was
lying in her grand jury testimony her
grand jury deposition and her fbi
interviews when she said that the
president engaged in conduct with her
that constituted sexual relations even
under his narrow interpretation of the
term in the jones deposition
is it your position that she was also
lying when she gave essentially the same
account contemporaneously with the
occurrence of the events to her friends
and counselors
uh
senator our position is
not that she's lying our position is
that there are two different versions of
what happened and that there's a
discrepancy
now in my presentation to the senate i
acknowledge that there was a disparity
between what the president had recounted
and what ms lewinsky says happened when
it comes to recalling
and reporting these specific
rather graphic and intimate details
concerning their activity
i pointed out that with respect to other
central elements of the relationship
there was no disagreement
that they acknowledged that there was a
relationship that they tried to conceal
it
but i also suggested and i suggest to
you today that
not every disagreement not every
discrepancy
is the food or the stuff or the subject
of a perjury charge
i also made the observation that perhaps
this kind of conflict and testimony as
to who touched who
when where and why
was not the kind of conflict
that this institution would want to
resolve through testimony on the floor
and if you have any doubts about that
point i would suggest you do read ms
lewinsky's august 20th testimony before
the grand jury which is very
complete
and entirely and vigorously dedicated to
eliciting
every single gritty detail of what went
on between them
i said also that i thought that this
disagreement this disparity was of
questionable materiality let me explain
why
on january 29th
judge wright ruled that ms lewinsky's
testimony about her relationship with
president clinton was unnecessary
and maybe even inadmissible
that she had had no information relating
to the core issues of the case
she made that ruling after all the
allegations about that relationship
had been made public
and the judge knew what had been
reported in newspapers
and
what was generally understood about it
at that point
she had been there when the president
testified about this
and she concluded that ms lewinsky's
testimony was not required at least for
the paula jones case
in truth ms lewinsky was an ancillary a
peripheral witness in the paula jones
case she had absolutely no first-hand
knowledge
about what happened in the excelsior
hotel
when ms jones claimed that then governor
clinton
made an unwelcome sexual overture to her
ms lewinsky had nothing to add or
subtract no ability to testify
about that
issue
so on the issue of the materiality to
the jones case
as to the truth of what actually
happened
between them it's clear it's
unquestionable if no materiality
whatsoever she was a peripheral witness
on issues
not having to do with the core issues of
the case in a case that had
no legal merit please recall that the
judge
concluded that the case had no legal or
evidentiary merit
please also remember that the jones
lawyers when they were asking these
questions
of president clinton
presumably knew the answers to these
questions
about the relationship because they'd
been fully briefed the night before
now as to the question the materiality
of this testimony in this issue who
touched whom when where
and why to the grand jury let me just
say this
the house managers claim that
one or the other
must be lying because both cannot be
correct
they argue that if you believe monica
lewinsky on this issue you must
disbelieve
bill clinton and if you disbelieve bill
clinton
you must conclude that he knowingly
perjured himself when he denied under
oath having this kind of contact
with ms lewinsky
now this
direct issue
was addressed by the panel
of expert prosecutors
that we brought to testify before the
judiciary
and they all agreed
that this kind of issue would never be
the subject of a perjury prosecution and
i would urge you to go back and look at
some of the testimony that they
gave to the judiciary committee
they talked about the oath on oath issue
they talked about what is
independent corroborative
evidence and what is not
and they concluded that
no reasonable no responsible prosecutor
would bring this kind of case based on
that kind of an issue
we're not arguing with the managers
about the law
we're not arguing with the managers
about the disparity we're talking about
prosecutorial practices what in reality
would be
a criminal prosecution
and
i submit to you that no reasonable no
responsible prosecutor would bring this
kind of a case based on that kind of
evidence thank you
this is a question from senator daschle
addressed a counsel for the president
do you believe that it is a requirement
of due process and fairness that you'd
be allowed to participate in the
lewinsky witness debriefing
sought by the managers and do you
believe that the house
would have asked for the same right
if the
white house
had attempted to interview ms lewinsky
mr chief justice that
question raises
an interesting mix
of issues
because i think in one respect the house
managers are correct
that once the senate determines
that it's prepared to go forward i trust
it will not but if it does
determine that is prepared to go forward
in some way with respect to the
depositions of witnesses
at that point with the senate having
made that decision
it would be appropriate for both sides
to seek voluntary
consensual
typical opportunity to meet with any
witness
in a setting that doesn't involve having
the prosecutor with life or death
authority over that witness doing the
debriefing or being present while you
talk to the witness
thus although i will take the
opportunity if offered to sit in on any
meeting
between the managers
and the independent council
and any witness
because i would certainly like to know
what the mood and the atmosphere and the
nature of that process really sounds
like
the issue here i think
is not so much
whether
it would be nice to sit in on that
meeting
but whether there can be any hope
for due process fairness
and opportunity
for both sides or certainly the my side
i won't speak for the managers
to have
an opportunity for reasonable fair and
open
discussion voluntarily with any witness
who will talk with us
not
not to be too rhetorical about this with
the looming
presence
of the prosecutors sitting in the room
with us
as everyone who practices in this
district knows indeed
it is a matter of law
that a prosecutor may never
interfere
with the access of any witness to
defense counsel
i can't think of much more interference
than being required to sit in the room
with the prosecutor
and with another prosecutor
while that kind of discussion goes on
so the answer is
fairness no
if it's my only opportunity to meet with
ms lewinsky i'll take it but i trust
that as a matter of due process
it will not be
this is a question from
senators dewine collins and murkowski to
the house managers
with all of the conflicting testimony
that exists on the record between monica
lewinsky and betty curry for example
how are we to resolve the questions of
perjury and obstruction of justice
without observing the demeanor of
witnesses
uh
i don't think there is uh
any way to resolve the conflicts and
their testimony without calling the
witnesses now you can read the
transcripts and you could look at those
and you could try to determine uh you
know whether there's any corroborating
evidence uh you know how you can believe
it and make some of those kinds of
evaluations
but particularly whenever you're
looking at
whether it's monica lewinsky or betty
curry there's the follow-up questions
there's the demeanor that
allows you to determine who's telling
the truth and who you believe and
in contrast to mr ruff tries to make the
point that somebody's lying here and
maybe somebody is lying but but a jury
in this case the senators can look at
this and say well someone is not
recalling uh the same way someone is
more believable because their
recollection is is uh is better it's
corroborated so it and or you could
conclude that someone is lying but it
always doesn't break down that simply
but you have to evaluate that and that's
how you resolve it but let me just come
back
i think what we see here today is that
the white house counselor do not want to
talk about the facts they do not want to
talk about this case they do not want to
talk about obstruction of justice just
like in the house they want to talk
about the process
they want to talk about everything
that's going on except for the case of
obstruction of justice and
it probably will be the news story later
on today the questions that they have
raised about this but the fact is that
it is very simple that
they have access to betty curry
uh every time the president has has
talked and tried to coach betty curry i
don't think the president invited the
independent counsel in when that was
under investigation or the paula jones
lawyers i don't think that happened
uh i don't think that
at least the news clips when i saw
betty curry hugging the president i
don't think he invited the house
managers in
and i didn't necessarily expect him to
but we have to be prepared and i'll just
tell you right now so nobody's surprised
if we get to call vernon jordan i do not
want to delay the united states senate
in order to be prepared for that so i'll
confess today that i called up bill
hundley the lawyer for vernon jordan and
to visit with him now
i hope that uh if you talk to any
witnesses that if you feel like it's
fair that you'll give us a chance to
join with you in that but obviously this
is an adversary process that we're
engaged in and i think that we today in
this question answer session that you
all so graciously extended to us you
know should focus on the obstruction of
justice charges because that's what you
have to determine on the perjury
allegations because that one is what we
have to determine today and i thank the
chief justice and the senators
this question is from senators colin
edwards
uh to whom is it addressed
oh
well it's to the house managers
uh
throughout this trial both sides have
spoken in absolutes that is if the
president engaged in misconduct
prosecutors claim that he must be
convicted and removed from office while
the president's lawyers argue that such
conduct does not in any way rise to an
impeachable offense
it strikes many of us as a closer call
so let me ask you this even if the
president engaged in the alleged conduct
can reasonable people disagree with the
conclusion that as a matter of law he
must be convicted and removed from
office yes or no
[Applause]
absolutely and this is a hard case
in a couple of areas and i think it's an
easy case in many areas
the constitution reads that upon
conviction the person shall be removed
and you've got to put it in context of
the judge cases because that's where it
gets to be hard for this body
because the the precedence of the body
when you apply the same legal standard
of high crimes and misdemeanors
to the fact that a judge who was
convicted of perjury was removed by the
body and you conclude in your mind that
this president committed perjury you've
got a dynamic you have to work through
mr bumper says there's perjury then
there's perjury
i would suggest to you that the
allegations of perjury and obstruction
of justice in this case are not trivial
it's not about a speeding ticket or a
a trivial matter it's about the activity
of the president when he was defended in
a lawsuit in a sexual harassment lawsuit
when he was told by the supreme court
you've got to play and you've got to
play fairly
if you determine that he committed the
crime of perjury
and you determined that he committed the
crime of obstruction of justice
based on the president of the senate i
think you'd have a hard time
saying under the
situation in this case that that's not a
high crime
but i would be the first to admit
that the constitution is silent on this
question about whether or not every high
crime has to result in removal and if i
was sitting where you're at
i would probably get out on my knees
before i made that decision because the
impact on society is going to be real
either way
if you find this president guilty in
your mind
from the facts that he's a percher any
obstructed justice
you've got to somehow reconcile
continued service
in light of that event and i think it's
important for this body
to not have a uh
disposition plan
that doesn't take in consideration the
good of this nation
i have argued to you
that when you found that a judge was a
perjurer
you couldn't in good conscience send him
back in a courtroom
because everybody that came in that
courtroom thereafter
would have a real serious doubt
i will argue to you that when you find
this president guilty of perjury if you
do
that he has violated his oath
and that by
a consequence of that
some public trust has been lost
and i would show to you the body of
evidence from this question do you trust
william jefferson clinton the american
people will tell you three out of four
say no
but the american people will also tell
you
that i understand what happened here
and
some want them removed and some don't
and you got to consider what's best for
this nation
i will uh yield to mr boyer in a second
but
the point is that i'm trying to make as
not articulately as i can is that i know
how hard that decision is it has always
been hard for me
it's never been hard to find out whether
bill clinton committed perjury or
whether he obstructed justice that ain't
a hard one for me
but when you take the good of this
nation
the upside in the downside
reasonable people can disagree on what
we should do
just like to remind all of you that the
the impeachment process is intended to
cleanse
the executive or the judicial office
when it's plagued with such a cancer
as perjury or obstruction of justice
which violates
the oath required to hop to hold those
high offices
now
what may be turning in the gut of some
of you is are the precedents of the
senate when in fact you have turned out
of office you have exercised your
judgments of proportionality when these
judges violated their oaths and had
perjury you said they shall be removed
from office
now there are some that are going well
i'm uneasy
in this case with the president
that's what may create a little problem
here i would suggest to you
that you actually have findings of fact
that the senate has findings of fact
that the president in fact he lied or he
did not lie or he committed an
obstruction
that you actually have findings of fact
and then you can move beyond to the
questions of application of the law but
when the senate has performed such a
cleansing
and removed judges nixon claiborne and
hasting all three of them impeach for
perjury in some form
and in in judge hastings case even
though he had been acquitted of the
criminal case
the congress
in particular the senate you have a duty
to preserve the integrity of public
office and that is what his impeachment
was precisely designed to do
this is a question from senators
voinovich jeffords and chafee
to the house managers
in her interview with the office of the
independent council ms lewinsky stated
that on january 5th 1998 the president
told her not to worry about the
affidavit because he had seen 15 others
did the president turn mean that he had
seen previous drafts of ms lewinsky's
affidavit or did the president mean that
he had seen drafts of other affidavits
that were in some way connected to the
paula jones matter
thank you mr chief justice
you can take that either way but i
believe in the context and i presented
this to you the other day that in which
the president uttered those words that
the most logical conclusion is that he'd
seen 15 other drafts of hers
if you remember
she was discussing with him
the issue of whether he wanted to see
this particular draft of her affidavit
and at that particular moment he said no
i don't want to i've seen 15 others well
you know technically speaking he could
have seen 15 other
affidavits in his life somewhere back in
arkansas who knows
but it strikes me that the logical
conclusion the common sense conclusion
in the context of everything else that
you see this president was intent on and
had in his mind
and the interest that he had already
shown from all the conversations that
he'd had with vernon jordan and others
to make sure that this affidavit was on
track
and knowing that he was going to testify
in a few days himself in the jones case
and rely on it and in fact did go in and
tell the same cover stories that were in
this affidavit to the court
untruthfully
that the probabilities are pretty good
that common sense says that he was
saying he'd seen 15 other drafts of this
version of this affidavit but that's for
you to decide that's a judgment call for
the triers of fact
thank you
this is a question from senator leigh to
counsel for the president could you
reply to the statement just made by
manager mccollum
mr chief justice
on thursday afternoon i went over in
perhaps tedious detail the facts
relating to the affidavits
i pointed out
that there was no way
in which there was no evidence that the
president saw any affidavit draft
mr manager mccollum uh
just now i think admitted that he has
only a speculation he doesn't have any
record evidence the president denied uh
seeing any affidavit draft uh
the i i pointed out in the managers
chart seven
that their theory about when miss
lewinsky could have gotten an affidavit
was simply wrong because their theory
was she got it on january 5th this is a
single affidavit draft the evidence
plainly shows that she could not have
gotten it until january 6.
there is simply nothing in the record
and the independent council interviewed
miss lewinsky extensively both in
interviews and before the grand jury and
there is simply no evidence whatsoever
that the president saw any drafts or
indeed that there were 15 drafts let me
say a word about whether or not we are
addressing the facts
i'm not going to frighten you i'm not
going to go back through
the obstruction of justice evidence but
i think if you'll remember the
presentation first by mr craig who
addressed in detail
the evidence with regard to perjury then
if you'll recall what ms mills said
addressing two of the seven
allegations of obstruction of justice
and with what i said to you on thursday
afternoon for almost three hours and i
thank you for your uncommon patience you
were attentive all the way through that
exercise
you know that we have addressed the
facts what we had
yesterday what mr ruff has already
addressed is
again i'll use the word remarkable
occurrence
involving the
independent
council
we've addressed the facts
and there is simply nothing to support
in all
this record this heavy
long record that the president had
any review of any affidavit or indeed
that there was more than one or two
drafts of miss lewinsky's affidavit
this question is from senators dewine
santorum and fitzgerald to the
president's council
if we are to assume that the various
allegations as to obstruction of justice
are in fact true
is it your contention that if the
president tampered with witnesses
encouraged the hiding of evidence and
corruptly influenced the filing of a
false affidavit by a witness
that these acts do not rise to the level
of an impeachable offense
mr chief justice
this is something i won't have an
opportunity to say very often but i
believe that
mr manager graham
has in fact
stated for you
the essential
of the role that this body must play
we will probably differ as to what the
right answer to the question is
but as to the process and as to the
question that must be asked
i think he stated it well
i believe that the facts do not support
the conclusions that are embodied in the
question
but
not only can
reasonable people differ on the facts
but reasonable people may differ
on the outcome
and if indeed
reasonable people can differ
doesn't that mean by the very statement
of that proposition
that this body
cannot
meet its constitutional
heavy mandate
which is to determine whether or not
whatever conduct you believe the
president committed as outlined by these
managers over the last many days
can you legitimately determine
that he ought to be removed from office
and all i can do i suppose is to remind
you as i have too frequently i'm sure
that if you try to put yourself in the
minds and the hearts
of the men who
created our system of government
they wanted to know only really one
answer to one question
as framed in many different ways but the
essence remains the same
is there a sufficient danger to the
state
danger to the state
to warrant
what
my colleagues across the aisle here have
called
the political death penalty and i think
the answer to that
is no
this is a question from senator
wellstone to counsel for the president
to what extent should the views of the
american people be taken into account in
considering whether a president should
be removed from office
mr chief justice i think that
the answer to that question is not
the polls that you read in the
newspapers or that you see on your
evening news
whatever those numbers may be that's
only one clue as to what the american
people are thinking
and each of you knows the people in your
jurisdiction far better
than any poll taker does
and that certainly i do
but surely one way to test the ultimate
question that i just described in
response to the last
inquiry from
the republican side of the house
is to ask yourself
on the basis of experience over the last
year on the basis of your experience
in the political and by that i mean
political in the very
best constitutional sense of the term is
used by alexander hamilton
ask your sense of the political
structure of this country
and what the people are saying to you
and what your sense of their needs are
do they need
the kind of cleansing that manager boyer
spoke about
and i think the answer to that if you
look within the body of
our people who you are most familiar
with
must be no this isn't to say that it's a
popularity contest that we ought to go
out
and have a referendum or
another poll
before you all decide on this but surely
the sense of the people the will of the
people
the belief of the people
in this president's ability to govern
must educate each of you
not mandate a result but surely guide
the result that you reach
in this proceeding
this is a question from senator collins
to the house managers
the president's council has made much of
ms lewinsky's statement that no one
promised her a job for her silence
she did not testify however that no one
promised her a job in return for a false
affidavit
or for that matter that no one implied
that she would get a job for her
cooperation
can you think of any reason why we
should not call ms lewinsky to help
clarify such ambiguous testimony
thank you mr chief justice that is an
excellent question and really goes to
the heart of some of the disputes
and i think that
as you read the testimony of miss
lewinsky as you read some of the other
areas of testimony questions come to
your mind you'd like to follow up you'd
like to ask a question and that one
comes out and flags you that that's a
question that would like to be asked no
one promised her a job for her silence
and that is the testimony that she gave
in response to a question uh in the
grand jury
but i believe this is a case in which
actions
speak louder than words
i think that actions and what took place
and the common sense understanding of
what is happening here uh demonstrates
uh the case
that there was a false affidavit that
was obtained
and that was in conjunction with the
obtaining of a job for monica lewinsky
so i think that that is a natural
question and i think that also if you
read the if you look at the testimony
monica lewinsky i think it's clear that
the case is made that
she was encouraged to lie
and she
was also encouraged to sign a false
affidavit and she was also
provided a job coincidentally at the
same time
i would like to take the opportunity if
i might
mr chief justice in
in further answering a question that was
raised earlier
was on the
false affidavit and that's related i
think to the question as well during mr
kendall's presentation a few days ago he
made this statement the idea that the
telephone call
between lewinsky and clinton on january
5th about the affidavit is about the
affidavit is sheer unsupported
speculation and even worse it is
speculation demolished by fact end quote
this is the statement that mr kendall
gave the other day on this floor as site
in the congressional record summarizing
his presentation that the idea that
clinton lewinsky talked about the
affidavit is sheer unsupported
speculation and demolished by fact
well
the record demonstrates that monica
lewinsky's testimony is
that
she had a conversation with the
president on the telephone
in which she asked questions about the
affidavit she was concerned about
signing that affidavit and according to
ms lewinsky the president said quote
well you could always say that the
people in legislative affairs got it for
you or helped you get it and end quote
and that is reference to a paragraph in
the particular affidavit
now
my question to
mr kendall is would you agree mr kendall
that your assertion
that
there is no support for it in the record
is that you are totally rejecting the
testimony of monica lewinsky as totally
unbelievable and once again you have a
conflict that is presented in the
testimony and that is only one way to
resolve it and it is to hear from the
key witnesses
this is a question from senator
lautenberg to counsel for the president
could you reply to the question put by
the manager
mr chief justice
let me address the first part of
mr manager hutchinson's
response
and that is whether the
statement by miss lewinsky that nobody
ever promised me a job
for my silence
covered other possible
uh promises to her
and it's quite clear when you read all
the interviews that were done of her by
the independent counsel all the grand
jury testimony that she unequivocally
testified there were no promises made to
her there were no assistances given to
her that were in any way
conditioned upon her testifying a
certain way or giving a certain kind of
affidavit she is unequivocal about that
now in the statement that she made that
i quoted
she does not say
nobody ever did these other things but
she said that in her previous testimony
she uses the offer of a job as simply a
proxy for anything that would connect
the assistants she would receive
uh with
testifying in a certain way there's
simply no evidence anywhere in the
record and the independent council
covered that with her in detail she felt
compelled to volunteer uh her statement
at the end of the process because they
had left some innuendo in the record
that she had been provided assistance
but her testimony is unequivocal i've
quoted it now the only testimony
in the record
about
the
linking the job to
some
assistance in the jones case comes from
the linda tripp audio tapes
and that again
ms lewinsky could not be clearer in her
grand jury testimony what she told linda
tripp was false there was no connection
there whatsoever
uh her proffer which i put up on the
board was quite unconditional
not and this this you have in your
materials this is in her own handwriting
neither the president nor mr jordan
or anyone on
their behalf
ask or encouraged her to lie
so with regard to the first part of mr
manager hutchinson's question uh there
is simply no evidence again that any
kind of assistance to ms lewinsky was
conditioned on her performance in any
way in the jones case now
with regard to the affidavit
mr i i i stand on what i said uh before
you on thursday
and
i want to be very clear about what mr
hutchinson's presentation was in chart
number seven that i was responding to
and i think
that
i think it's quite important
uh to recall
yesterday that
a question was addressed
to the house managers
whether
there were any statements consent
contained in their exhibits
which contained
misrepresentations or omissions
that in the interest of fairness or
justice they would like to correct
and
mr manager hutchinson said we are not
aware of any corrections that need to be
made on any of our exhibits offered to
the senate
i would simply rest on the presentation
i'm not going to take you through again
the many errors in the charts those were
not refuted in any way they've rested on
their charts i leave that to your
judgment but with regard to chart seven
what mr manager hutchinson told you
almost a week ago
was that
chart seven was a summary of what
happened on january five
ms lewinsky meets with her attorney mr
carter for an hour carter drafts the
affidavit for ms lewinsky
she calls the president the president
returns ms lewinsky's call and then they
had a discussion about this draft
affidavit
the point of my demonstration
through mr carter's testimony and
through his billing records was in fact
that the affidavit had been drafted the
next day they could not have had a
discussion about the affidavit on that
date and i think the record is quite
clear on that
this is a question from senator lot to
the house managers do you have any
comment on the answer given by the
president's council with regard to the
views of the american people
mr chief justice
distinguished senators
this a fascinating question
edmund burke
was asked that that once
and he said that a member of parliament
owes the highest degree of fidelity to
his constituents
but he doesn't owe his conscience to
anybody
we have or we have not a representative
democracy
we're not delegates who are sent here to
weigh our mail every day and then to
vote accordingly
our work here is not an ongoing
plebiscite
we are elected to bring our judgment our
experience
and our consciences with us here
i have always believed and i believe
more firmly than ever and this
experience confirms me in that belief
there are issues of transcendent
importance that you have to be willing
to lose your office over
i can think of several that i'm willing
to lose my office over abortion is one
national defense is another
strengthening
not emasculating
the concept of equal justice under law
my life is devoted as a lawyer i've been
in the judiciary committee this is my
25th year
and equal justice under the law
is what moves me and animates me and
consumes me and i'm willing to lose my
seat any day in the week rather than
sell out on those issues
despite all the polls and all the
hostile
editorials
america is hungry for people who believe
in something
you may disagree with us
but we believe in something
this chief justice i ask unanimous
consent that we recess the proceedings
for 15 minutes in the absence of
objection it's so ordered
the majority leader is recognized
thank you mr chief justice uh
we will go approximately another hour if
uh
questions uh are still available and i
assume they will be and we would take a
break for about an hour for lunch
this is a question from senator biden to
the house managers
if a senator believes that the president
may have lied to the american people his
family and his aides and that some of
his answers before the grand jury were
misleading or half truths
but that he could not be convicted in a
court of law for either perjury or
obstruction of justice is it the opinion
of the house managers that his actions
still justify removing the president
from office
mr chief justice
i've taken two public oaths
in my career of service to the people of
this great land
one was as a member of congress
the other is as a united states attorney
as a united states attorney
it was my job on behalf of the people of
the united states
to prosecute
cases against individuals
and other entities
that violated
the criminal code of the united states
of america
that criminal code as you are well aware
includes the offenses of perjury
and obstruction of justice
that criminal code
does not include the offenses of lying
to one's family
that is not what brings us here today
what brings us here today
is the belief
by the house of representatives
in lawful public vote
that this president
violated in numerous respects his oath
of office
and
the criminal code of the united states
of america
in particular
that he committed perjury and
obstruction of justice
i can tell you
as a united states attorney serving
under two presidents
that i would prosecute these cases
because i did prosecute such cases
i prosecuted cases against people
including
members of the body from which we as
managers come
who appeared before grand juries
and lied
who appeared before grand juries and
misled grand juries
people
who obstructed justice
people who tampered with witnesses in
precisely the same way that this
president has committed perjury
tampered with witnesses and obstructed
justice
we would respectfully submit to the
senators of the united states of america
assembled here today
that these are prosecutable cases
they have been cases that have been
prosecuted
and that the question is not before this
body we would respectfully submit from
the house of representatives
into articles of impeachment
that the president lied to his family
what is before this body we respectfully
submit as contained in
two articles of impeachment passed by
the house of representatives
is that this president
violated his oath of office
and committed the offenses of perjury
and obstruction of justice which we
firmly believe on behalf of the people
of the united states of america
provide a sufficient basis
on which this body exercising its
deliberative power and its legitimate
jurisdiction
may find
that this president
as people in courts of law similarly but
not identically situated
are indeed found guilty
and removed from positions of trust as
this president ought to be
for committing perjury and obstruction
of justice
not lying to his family thank you
this is a question from senators snow
mac chafee burns and craig to the house
managers
before ms lewinsky was subpoenaed in the
jones case
the president refused on five separate
occasions november third november 10th
november 12th november 17th and december
6th
to produce information about and gifts
from lewinsky the president's council
argued the president was unconcerned
about these gifts if that is the case
why didn't he produce his gifts in
november and december
uh mr chief justice
i thank the senators for the question
this case needs to be looked at for the
mosaic that it is there is a reason why
the president
never produced gifts
there is a reason why the president
continued to give ms lewinsky gifts
it's because he believed
that she would never produce them
we know that from her testimony
in my presentation to the senate a week
ago i quoted from the transcripts
where she said nobody ever asked me to
lie
but then she also said
there was never any doubt
but that we would deny the relationship
if asked
we see that
throughout the entire proceedings we see
that before monica lewinsky's name
appeared on the list on december 5th on
the witness list
and we especially see it after
in fact monica lewinsky went to the
president
and said
i've been subpoenaed
they're asking for gifts
what should i do
maybe i should give them to betty
and the president said let me think
about that
and we all know by now that within a few
hours
betty curry called monica lewinsky and
came and retrieved the gifts
not to give them to the jones lawyers
pursuant to the subpoena
not to cooperate with the sexual
harassment lawsuit
she took the gifts
and she hid them under her bed
now members of this body
it begs
common sense
for any interpretation
of that conduct to be somehow
cooperative
with the legal proceedings in the sexual
harassment case
every piece of this puzzle when put
together demonstrates a very clear
pattern of obstructing justice not to
cover up a personal embarrassment
not to cover up
an indiscretion
but to destroy paula jones's right under
the sexual harassment laws of this
country to have her day in court and
that is the ultimate question that this
body is going to have to address
yes reasonable minds can differ
on this case as to whether the president
is should be removed from office
but reasonable minds can only differ
if those reasonable minds come to the
conclusion that enforcement of the
sexual harassment laws in this country
are less important than the preservation
of this man
in the office of the presidency and that
is the ultimate question that this body
is going to have to answer what is more
important
the survival of bill clinton's
presidency in the face of perjury and
obstruction of justice
or the protection of the sexual
harassment laws in this country
and i imagine every victim in the
workplace
will be waiting for your answer
this is from senator daschle to the
house manager
will you agree to arrange to have
prepared a verbatim unedited transcript
of any debriefing which may occur with
ms lewinsky for immediate distribution
to the senate and will you agree also to
provide for the inclusion in any such
debriefing of representatives of the
senate
one selected by the majority and one by
the minority
mr chief justice and members of the
senate
it is not our intent to be doing a
deposition a formal presentation a
preparation for the senate if we talk to
mr lewinsky it is our intent to do what
any good attorney would do in preparing
to go to trial or to presuming we don't
know that you're going to allow us to
have witnesses but presuming we're going
to be able to depose and have witnesses
and that is to meet with the witness
talk with the witness and prepare the
witness and any good attorney does that
if it's going to be his or her witness
in their own confidences in their own
quiet respite we discover things that
way we're not prepared no the answer to
your question is no we're not prepared
to say we're going to give you our work
product which is what that would be
work products the technical term of law
but for anybody who's out in the public
is what lawyers do all the time and they
work on their case and they prepare what
they're going to do and then they
present it and that's the system we have
is somebody said i think mr hutchinson
earlier this is an adversarial position
the white house council have their
chance to talk to witnesses that they're
going to present we have our chance to
talk to ours then there's the
opportunity for the depositions which is
what comes next which is the formal
proceeding when we both have a chance to
talk with them and then of course if
you've let us call them as witnesses
here they'll be here and they'll get
cross-examined and examined and all the
questions you can imagine to be asked
that is the traditional american system
of justice so no we wouldn't want to
give you our work product notes we have
no idea what would be in them and we
don't think that that's appropriate and
we think that a lot is being made out of
this we attempted to do this a couple of
weeks ago we would like to have talked
to her earlier it is not work that we've
been permitted to for reasons that we're
not sure but the reality is this is a
normal process we would talk to any
other witness despite however the white
house counsel want to argue about it
they do the same thing i yield what time
i have left to mr graham
i like to echo the work product
analogy but let me just say this as
directly as i know how to say it
that if this body as a whole believes
that we're going to do anything improper
then whatever
rule you need to fashion to make sure we
don't you do it
because nobody
should ever doubt
whether a witness comes into this body
in this case gave anything other than
testimony that was truthful and if you
want to go down the road of the
atmosphere that people were approached
and how they were treated about being
witnesses let's go down that road
together
let's bring in people in this body
and let's see how they were approached
when they were asked
to participate in this trial what the
atmosphere in the mood was
when it come their time to be identified
as witnesses so i would just say as
strongly as i know how that if you've
got any doubt about us
and what we're up to you fashion rules
so we do not create an unfairness in
this body but please when we ask for
witnesses
and we raise doubts about how people may
have been treated
that you give us the same opportunity to
explore the mood and atmosphere of those
witnesses
this question is to the house managers
from senators murkowski greg grahams
thomas crapo thompson and hatch
the president's council rely upon the
president's statements in many instances
therefore the president's credibility is
an issue
is the president's credibility affected
by the fact that until the dna evidence
surfaced the president denied any
improper relationship with ms lewinsky
chief justice
i thank the senators
first i don't think it was a compliment
to me from my colleagues that as soon as
the issue of dna came up they all
pointed to me and told me to come answer
the question
i will do my best obviously as the
triers of fact
members of this body individually will
have to make determinations
respecting the credibility of the
president as well as the other witnesses
it is indisputable however
that from
january 1998 when he spoke at the
deposition
until august 17th
when he made a quasi admission before
the grand jury
that there were intervening factors
that required him to change his position
we saw from the moment the story first
broken the press about monica lewinsky
the president making denials in the most
emphatic of ways
and not only doing it repeatedly himself
but sending out his cabinet and his
aides and his friends
to do it on his behalf that continued
up until the eve of the deposition
was it because the president suddenly
had a change of heart was it because his
conscience was suddenly
bearing down upon him or were there
other reasons
well
let's see
just before his deposition testimony
monica lewinsky
decided to cooperate
with the office of independent counsel
monica lewinsky suddenly turned over
a blue dress and that's fascinating
because as you know from the record and
you've heard from the presentations
the president was prepared
to take monica lewinsky
and trash her in a very public way
until the dress was turned over to the
fbi remember what he said to sydney
blumenthal he called her a stalker he
said that she was threatening him but he
no longer could make these
representations publicly or privately
once he knew that there was potential
physical evidence so i think that there
are a number of factors members of this
body can look at with respect to
credibility just from the cold record
but if that is not enough if members of
this body are not satisfied
that they are able to resolve these
issues of credibility then the way to
handle that
is to follow the dictates of the
constitution and our framers who
understood the value of a trial in
bringing witnesses forward placing them
under oath and giving the triers of fact
the opportunity to see the witnesses to
hear their testimony to gauge their
credibility that's what the purpose of a
trial is for
and the house managers entrust this body
to make sure that at the end of the day
this is more than a proceeding
this is an arena where the truth will be
determined not just for our time but for
history
this question is from senator murray to
counsel for the president could you
reply to the comments of manager rogan
the existence
of dna or any other
evidence or any other events
before the president's grand jury
testimony
had no bearing whatsoever
on his determination which he carried
out on that day
in the middle of august
to answer the grand jury's questions
truthfully
he did so
it may be that the managers can
speculate about well
there must have been some reason why
in the middle of august
after some months of denying to the
nation and his family
any misconduct
he changed his mind and told the truth
but there is one reason
why he did that
because he went before
a grand jury for the
united states district court of the
district of columbia
and told the truth
now it's been suggested by many of the
managers over the last
day
that
the president was somehow
anxious to or contemplated the prospect
of as they put it trashing
ms lewinsky
this was issue was raised yesterday and
it was been raised again by mr manager
rogan and i think it is time to set that
record straight
mr manager bryant
yesterday
as he was discussing
the dick morris issue
purported to recite from
the independent council's referral
and purported to describe a conversation
between the president and mr morris in
which
the quote to quote from mr manager
bryant
according to morris the president
warned him that is mr morris
he warned the president
excuse me let me start before that and
later the next day the president has a
follow-up conversation with mr morris in
the evening and says that he
that is the president is considering
holding a press conference to quote
blast monica lewinsky out of the water
but mr morris urges
caution he says be careful
and that he warned the president not to
be too hard on her
well
180 degrees
off from that
description
let me read you
what
in fact the independent counsel's office
referral says
and i'm sure it was just
a slip
of the read
that you heard yesterday
the president had a follow-up
conversation with mr morris during the
evening of january 22 1998 is page 127
of the independent council's referral
when mr morris was considering holding a
press conference to blast monica
lewinsky out of the water
the president told mr morris to be
careful
according to mr morris the president
warned him
not to be too hard on ms lewinsky
close
close
180
beyond that
let me be very clear about one
proposition which has been a sub theme
running through some of the comments of
the managers over the last many days
the white house the president the
president's agents the president's
spokespersons no one
has ever
trashed threatened
maligned or done anything else
to monica lewinsky
no one
this is a question from senators
hutchinson of texas snow allard collins
and hatch to the house managers
the council for the president have said
that the heart of this case is private
consensual sex
a tenet of sexual harassment law however
is that the implied power relationship
between a supervisor
in this case the president and a
subordinate in this case an intern is
enough to constitute sexual harassment
this is well settled in military law and
is developing along this line in the
civilian sector
in your view
how many how might acquittal in this
case affect laws regarding sexual
harassment
mr chief justice
the law of sexual harassment is a
relatively
new genre
if somebody wanted to make a case before
the congress had stepped in and improved
upon the law it essentially reduced a
woman in the workplace for instance who
had been harassed into what has been
referred to as a he said she said type
of argument
and so the law has improved upon that
because the law recognizes today
that sometimes there can be evidence of
a pattern of conduct
and that conduct is relevant to prove
how somebody may have behaved
consider what would happen
if
victims of the workplace get a message
from the congress of the united states
that what the president did with paula
jones or allegedly did with paula jones
is of no constitutional significance
here it would send a message to every
woman in the workplace
that if they have a complaint
against an employer who is attempting to
use a position of power and authority
to pursue improper advancements
the message would be that you might as
well just keep quiet about it
because the person
can lie in court
and suffer no recrimination first
they'll probably never be discovered
because most of the time dna evidence
doesn't suddenly appear
but even if dna evidence does appear to
corroborate the victim
the message is
that as long as he is appropriately
apologetic and the lie was after all
only about sex
it's of no import
with respect to removing them from their
job or having them suffer any legal
consequences i think that would be a
horrible message
the reason the law allows
this pattern of conduct evidence
is because sexual harassers operate
in a unique way
they get their victims alone they
typically don't commit these crimes
under the glare of league lights or in
front of television cameras or where
witnesses can testify they get their
witnesses they get their victims alone
for one reason
because they know
through intimidation and fear one of two
things will happen
through intimidation or fear
the victim will submit
or through intimidation or fear
the victim will not submit
but will keep their mouth shut about it
what is the message
to these victims who do brave losing
their job
being destroyed publicly having their
reputations
destroyed
what is the message to them if when they
come forward
and they want to pursue their case
we take the legal view that somebody can
perjure themselves somebody can lie
somebody can obstruct justice somebody
in the greatest position of power in our
country can take whatever steps are
necessary to destroy that woman's claim
in a court of law where she is entitled
to pursue it
if at the end of all of this we say well
you know
he was embarrassed
he did lie but it was only about sex
lies and sexual harassment cases members
of the senate are always only about sex
the question before this body is
what type of validity are we going to
give these laws and what sort of message
are we going to send to victims in the
workplace i pray
that we can put personal relationships
aside
with respect to how people individually
feel about this president personally and
how they feel about his administration
and focus on what is the ultimate
conclusion legally and what is the
precedent that will be set if we turn a
blind eye to this sort of conduct
this is a question from senators boxer
feinstein landrieu mikulski and murray
to counsel for the president
has ms lewinsky ever claimed the
relationship was other than consensual
and was not ms jones case dismissed as
having no claim recognized by law
no
and yes
indeed
as
mr manager rogan
has told you
and others before him on the manager's
side
our sexual harassment laws
and our civil rights laws
of critical importance to all of us
my colleague ms mills i think spoke
eloquently on that subject
a couple of days ago
but it's important to understand i
believe
with no sense at all that we are in any
way diminishing the importance of those
laws and of the rights of every
american citizen to seek justice under
those laws
that we are talking about a case
in which the trial judge determined
that on all the evidence that had been
gathered
and all the claims that the plaintiff
had made
and all the discovery that had been
taken
there was
no case
that's justice that's the way the system
works
a plaintiff
brings the claim
the process moves ahead and a judge
ultimately makes a decision
and this didn't have anything to do
with what president clinton said in his
deposition
in on january 17th
what the judge ruled was
first
that that evidence was irrelevant to her
consideration
and then ultimately in april of last
year
that there simply was no case
we accept the results of the justice
system whether they go against us or
whether they go for us
in either event it's justice
this is a question from senator thompson
to the house managers
is there any reason to believe that
there is any relationship between the
president telling mr blumenthal that ms
lewinsky was a stalker
and expressing his frustration about not
being able to get his story out with the
fact that shortly thereafter negative
stories about ms lewinsky including the
allegation that she was a stalker began
to appear in news articles quoting
sources at the white house
i appreciate that question and thank you
mr chief justice
because i made a note of mr
ruff's statement
that no one and i believe he specified
the president his aides or no one has
ever trashed or
spoken ill he used some other words of
monica lewinsky and i've really
caught me as striking
in light of the sworn grand jury
testimony of sydney blumenthal and of
course he is testifying as to what the
president told him
and of course
in that conversation
the president told sydney blumenthal as
described in mr blumenthal that
i've gone
monica lewinsky came at me and made a
sexual demand on me
i rebuffed her the president said i've
gone down that road before i've caused
pain for a lot of people i'm not going
to do that again she referring to monica
lewinsky threatened the president this
is the president's statement now and it
goes on and describes it she was known
as the stalker
now in my
understanding that's a
trashing that's speaking ill that's
being very critical and and uh doing
everything can to basically destroy her
reputation now why was he telling sydney
blumenth all that was he trying to
use sydney blumenthal to get the message
out to the public
and to the grand jury who might hear
this that she is not a believable person
that the whole idea is that she came
on to him that threatened the president
of the united states
i think i don't understand mr ruff's uh
representation to the senators that no
one including the president or aids has
ever trashed monica lewinsky
now
i think it's important also at that
particular point in time the president
knew that sidney blumenthal and john
podesta would be a witness before the
grand jury that was his testimony that's
what the president united states
admitted to he says he knew that they
were going to be witnesses and clearly
that constitutes obstruction of justice
when he knows that they're going to be a
witness
he gives them false information knowing
that they're going to repeat it to the
grand jury and that is an element of one
of the pillars of obstruction
now i want to come back
to uh
some things that have been said about
the jones case
first of all has been characterized as
no win case the judge
susan weber wright issued that order
well if the truth had been known
what we know now about the relationship
about the pattern of conduct would that
have made a difference
and of course when that those facts came
out it was right before a decision by
the eighth circuit court of appeals that
might have reversed judge rights order
that the president united states made a
decision you need to settle this case
for 800 some thousand dollars
now
what would have happened maybe maybe
paula jones would not have had to gone
through
that many years of litigation if the
truth had just come out but there was a
pattern of obstruction of justice of
line of threat
of
coaching witnesses of tampering with
witnesses
which ultimately led to a defeat of that
case and the truth not coming out but
when it came out it made a difference it
made a difference for that plaintiff in
that civil rights case senator
hutchinson asked a question
about whether the power of the position
makes a difference
in
sexual harassment cases
and let me assure you that there was any
chief executive officer of any company
whether it was consensual or not
with a intern or a young person half of
the
of the officer's age
and whether it was whatever they term it
at that point whenever it was a
subordinate employee and that's the key
language a subordinate employee then yes
senator it does make a difference and
that is the crux of many cases that are
brought in to court to protect uh
women against sexual harassment in the
workplace i think it's a linchpin
of this act that this congress passed
and so i think that when you look at the
overall picture
that there is that pattern of
obstruction of justice
senator biden asked a question would any
prosecutor
bring this case forward
and let me tell you it would be easier
i say this with great deference to the
senate
but it would be easier to win a
conviction beyond any reasonable doubt
and i could win a conviction beyond a
reasonable doubt in a court in this
country on obstruction of justice
because i know that common sense
permeates
a jury panel whenever they hear this
case and the perjury
they're not going to buy
they're not going to accept those what
is is
they understand what these words mean
and common sense will apply and i know
that common sense
exists in the senate of the united
states but let me assure you that this
is a case that i would bring forward
without any hesitation and i believe the
proof would demonstrate a conviction
beyond a reasonable doubt
huh
this question is from senator kennedy to
the council for the president could you
reply to mr hutchison's allegations
i think it's important because the
question put to the
house managers chief justice was
whether there was some
uh effort or
some relationship between
the
ms lewinsky and a series of articles or
stories that supposedly appeared
in the early days
following the revelation of this
investigation and i think it's important
to
recognize what the real facts are here
this was the point made at the very end
of my testimony before the house
judiciary committee on december 9th
one of the members of that committee
spoke at great length and quite heatedly
about what he believed to have been
a plan to disseminate unfavorable
information in the press
and he submitted for the record a number
of newspaper articles
well
the articles that he submitted which
were
largely spun off for one
associated press story did not contain
two
at least two
statements
that made it very clear that the
accusation that there was some
effort
on the part of the white house to
disseminate disparaging information were
simply false
in an associated press story of january
31st which was used by
the member of the house judiciary
committee as one
of his examples
of how the white house was supposedly
coordinating
such an attack
there was omitted the following
portion
this is a statement by anne lewis who is
the white house communications director
to anyone who was saying such things
about ms lewinsky either reflected a
lack of coordination or thought or adult
judgment we are not going down that road
it is not the issue a discussion of
other people is not appropriate that's
on january 31st
and retrospectively when miss lewinsky
had already begun to cooperate with the
independent council the los angeles
times wrote the following
from the beginning the white house has
been careful about what it is said of ms
lewinsky the week that the lewinsky
story broke in january clinton's press
secretary mike mccurry signaled the tone
the white house would take by deflecting
questions about whether the 24 year old
intern was less than stable quote mr
mccurry i can't imagine anyone in a
responsible position at the white house
would be making such an assertion i've
heard some expressions of sympathy for
what clearly someone who's a young
person would be going through at a
moment like this and mccurry quickly
signaled that the marching orders had
not changed once lewinsky made a deal
with the independent council can it star
for immunity from prosecution i think
it's important that the record
be clear
that the stories about which the
managers were asked in their last
question
simply
never reflected
any plan coordinated uncoordinated
to do anything other than
treat ms lewinsky with respect
uh this question doesn't show uh which
senators are submitting it
this is a question from senator hatch
uh isn't it true that chief federal
district judge johnson ruled today in an
order that she authorized to be released
to the public
that ms lewinsky's immunity agreement
which requires her to make herself
available for any interviews upon
reasonable requests
compels her to submit to an interview
with the house
what light does this shed on the earlier
debate on this matter
oh i'm sorry
it's addressed to the house managers
mr chief justice uh
i think uh certainly having come from
experience of practicing law and learned
so much over the years in trying cases
and putting together cases in a
ethical in an ethical and appropriate
fashion
to come into a a political proceeding
and as we have
dealt with this
and i think that the
lawyers to my left have have had to deal
with the same type of situation in a
political realm
not just in the senate but but months
and weeks before we came into here
is very difficult and what we've seen
this morning is
a completely innocent
standard practice of of sitting down
with a potential witness before you have
to list your witnesses monday and
deciding
whether or not you want to use her
and they've talked about lawyers
committing malpractice by not taking
depositions i submit it would be
close to that if you don't talk to a
witness
before you call that witness and and
certainly
while the oic has had
communication with her over some time we
have not we have not had contact with
any of these witnesses and
and
i alluded earlier to the white house and
the other witnesses that work for the
white house that we might be looking at
calling
we i must presume by this conversation
in this area of questioning that they
have not had any contact about this case
with miss curry and mr podesta and mr
blumenthal
and even a friend of the white house mr
vernon jordan
we're not asking that we be privy to
every time they say hello in the hallway
to these people or may sit down and talk
with them we understand the realities of
life we simply wanted that
crazy idea maybe we ought to talk to a
witness and and
before we decide whether or not we want
to list that witness and i think today
to answer the question and i'll sit down
is that judge johnson clearly vindicated
this right to do that to accomplish that
through the immunity agreement
and
i i apologize if we've offended the
senators we certainly didn't intend to
do that we certainly didn't intend to
break any rules about this and we don't
think we did
and certainly if we're going to go down
that road and and if you see it's
appropriate that we have a rule that you
can agree on we would be happy to abide
by that but we would simply like like
equal treatment with the other witnesses
also with the white house and and their
attorneys thank you
uh
this question is to the house managers
from senators collins and feingold
on the basis of the presidents and betty
curry's testimony concerning their
conversation on sunday january 18 1998
have each of the elements of obstruction
of justice under 18 usc section 1503 or
witness tampering under 18 usc section
1512 been met
we are particularly interested in your
analysis of whether the senate can infer
that president clinton intended to
corruptly influence or persuade ms curry
to testify falsely and the wait to be
given ms curry's testimony in that
regard
the answer is that under 18 usc section
1503
there is a case for witness tampering in
the conversation between president
clinton and betty curry and i want to
cite you uh refer you to a case united
states versus shannon which is an eighth
circuit court of appeals case decided
october 12 1987 and for your lawyers
here it has been shepardized it is good
law and it really puts this in
perspective in this case the defendant
contended that the evidence did not
support a conviction under 18 usc
section 1503
because the government did not prove
that the witness in this case gray
was ever a witness before the grand jury
or that the defendant knew that that
person was going to be a witness before
the grand jury and this is what the
court said
this argument is without merit a
conviction under section 1503 for
attempting to influence a witness is
appropriate so long as there is a
possibility
that the target of the defendant's
activities will be called upon to
testify in an official proceeding
now
this gentleman
this defendant mr shannon
went to jail
he made the defense that well i didn't
you know she would never that person was
never called as a witness
it was never an official proceeding
and it didn't fly
he was convicted it was affirmed by the
core of the land and presumably he went
to jail
now that's the law of the land in the
criminal courts of our country and so
there would be a conviction under 18 usc
section 1503
in this case you have lot much more
because as i pointed out yesterday in
reference to betty curry
uh betty curry was clearly a witness
they left that deposition knowing she
would be a witness the jones attorney
went back and immediately worked on
issuing a subpoena for her because they
had to have her because the president
asserted her name continually through
that the president knew she was going to
be a witness he came back and engaged in
one conversation where he coached her
testimony he tampered with her testimony
it wasn't enough so two days later he
brought her back in again and did the
exact same thing the legal question is
as a prospective witness is she covered
in the obstruction of justice statutes
the answer is yes because other people
go to jail for exactly the same thing
but i think we need to take a breath
back for a moment
this united states senate is not bound
by
the strictures of the united states
criminal code
if i came in here today and said well
under the criminal procedures of the
land
i'm entitled to bring witnesses and i'm
entitled to cross-examine and i'm
entitled to do this and we need to
follow the criminal procedure code you'd
say no this is the senate united states
and you would rightfully say that you
set your own rules in this
and the same thing is true with the
criminal law of the land i think that we
make a criminal case for obstruction of
justice it could be prosecuted as other
people in the in the every courtroom in
this land
but that's not the burden here the issue
is this an impeachable offense and
something that is much higher is at
stake and that is the public trust the
integrity of our government much more
than in united states versus shannon and
that's what you're dealing with so we
can debate the criminal code all day and
we win on that but we have to talk about
the public trust the integrity of our
system
and that's what our country needs you to
win for them
this question is from senators thurman
and bunning to the council for the
president
if there was no case and the white house
accepted the results of the justice
system
why then did the president pay nearly
one million dollars to paula jones
i say this with all due respect
truly
as i think everyone knows
in this chamber and outside this chamber
who has practiced law
litigated
difficult cases
the judgment of a defendant
to settle a case
to pay whatever some
may be required to settle it
is in all candor
i think for all of us not
reflective
of any belief
that he was wrong
that the other side was right
it reflects in this case very candidly a
judgment by the president which he has
stated publicly
that in the midst of
the many matters that he is responsible
for
including i must say this matter as well
as all those matters of state for which
on which he
spends his time and to which he devotes
his energies
he could no longer
spend any of that time and any of that
energy
on the jones case
i i am so hesitant to say this but i
really believe
and please take it in the spirit that
it's meant
that to ask whether
the settlement of this case
reflects substantively
on the merits of ms jones's claim
is not fair
the merits of ms jones's claim
were decided by judge wright
she concluded that there were none
and i really do believe
that to ask
whether
the president's decision to settle
is somehow a reflection
on the merits contrary to those reached
by judge wright
is simply not the case
this is a question to the white house
counsel from senator johnson
a few minutes ago manager hutchinson
stated that he would be more confident
of obtaining a conviction for
obstruction of justice
in a court than he is in the senate
can that statement be reconciled with
the following exchange which occurred on
the sunday program this week on january
17 1999
in which manager hutchinson was asked on
the case that you have against the
president on of of obstruction of
justice not the perjury would you be
confident of a conviction in a criminal
court and manager hutchinson said no i
would not
it's addressed to the pres is it the
president's council
it's addressed to the president's
council i believe under your ruling
yesterday i can't object to questions
that is correct i would have the the the
go ahead
the manager the parliamentarian advises
me that the manager may make an
objection to the question being answered
uh
i i i i have second thoughts frankly
either that
that ruling is based on
uh
some a very
deltic almost incomprehensible and
incomprehensible statement that sam and
chase made
during the trial of andrew johnson and i
think the correct response is that the
managers do not have a right to object
to a question by the senator so i rule
the objection out of order
i'll tell you if you'd healed me for a
minute when you clear that up
i i just wanted to address for a second
um
manager hutchinson's comments with
regard to 1503 and he cited a 1987 uh
case and in 1995 i think as we talked a
little bit about in the house managers
had discussed ag wheeler came down and
in that case the issue was was there
sufficient nexus between the actual
conduct of the person involved and the
proceeding
and in particular i'm just going to read
you for one minute from the from the
case law the government asked the
response that the government argues that
the respondent understood that his false
statements would be provided to a grand
jury and that he made these statements
to thwart the gan jury
enthalpy a grand jury investigation and
not just the fbi investigation the
government supports its argument with
the transcript and they go through the
discussion that was between the judge
and the agent in which the agent the
judge specifically asked
whether or not he was a target from for
the grand jury investigation and the
agent responded there is a grand jury
meeting convening i guess is the right
word evidence will be heard
i'm sure on this issue so in other words
the person making the statement knew at
that point
that there was potentially the
possibility that his testimony would be
presented to the grand jury and the
court ruled as i talked to you a little
bit about during my presentation before
that that was insufficient nexus who are
there to prove a violation of 1503
this question is from senators helms and
stevens to the house managers
do you have any comment upon the answer
just given by the president's council
thank you mr chief justice and first i
want to thank miss mills for the
courtesy she extended to me just a
moment ago and our exchange was and mr
chief justice my uh what i started to
state my objection was was really not to
the question at that point but i was
just going to make the reference and to
the anticipated answer that the the
statement on
this week was sam and koki was not
exactly a part of this record we're to
be debating the facts of this case and
miss mills was kind enough not to go
into that and she i think was going to
make the point that the answer that i
gave was in reference to the need to
call witnesses
that
how confident can you be in any case
without calling a witness so the jury
can hear it now let me go back to what
miss mills said she did
cite united states versus aguilar and i
wish the chief justice since he wrote
the opinion could give us a lecture on
that particular
decision and i i feel like maybe we
should not be talking about this
but i read that opinion it's totally
consistent with united states versus
shannon and that the law is clear that
if this
body were to apply 18 usc section 1503
that a conviction would obtain but again
this is a body of uh gathered for the
purpose of considering impeachable
offense and i'd also like to yield to mr
graham on that point
thank you this is uh saturday morning at
12 30 and a lot of people are
probably watching with interest what's
going on and let's talk about the law
just for a moment uh
in a way that we all can understand when
this thing's over with
it's a long time since i've been in law
school but i like the exchange between
the professor and the students because
she kind of understood what the law was
about at the end of the day
witness tampering is designed
the statutes designed to do what
as senator bumpers and i would say in
arkansas and south carolina messing with
people
well we can elevate that a little bit
and say that the witness tampering
statutes that we're talking about here
are designed to make sure we get to the
truth
1512
is in the conjunctive part b whoever
knowingly uses intimidation or physical
force
that's one thing you don't want to
happen here you never want
anybody to go up to a potential witness
and threaten them through force or
intimidation to tell something that's
not true so that's out of bounds that's
illegal
or corruptly persuades
now what does that mean
there are some cases that talk about
what that means
that means if the person has an intent
an evil intent or an improper purpose to
persuade somebody without force of
intimidation
that that's a crime
or listen to this
engages in misleading conduct toward
another person with the intent to
influence or prevent the testimony of
any person in official proceeding what
are we getting to there ladies and
gentlemen
what the law says that if you go to a
person who likes you
who's your friend
who trusts you
and you try to get them to tell a story
through misleading them that's not true
that's a crime
the marvelous thing about the law
is it is based in common sense
it's very
obvious to us we don't want somebody to
be threatened to tell a story that's not
true
it's also obvious to us that we don't
want to take personal relationships
and misuse them
to get false testimony
out into a courtroom so if you go back
to your secretary who trusts you
who likes you
who admires you
and you try to mislead them
by telling a scenario
that's not true
and you believe that they may appear in
court one day
what you have done
is very
wrong because what you have done
is you have planted the seed
of a lie
in a way that we say is illegal
so if you believe the president of the
united states
was not refreshing his memory when he
told betty curry she wanted to have sex
with me and i couldn't do that
i never touched her did i bet he
if you believe that's not to refresh his
memory
if you believe that was misleading
and you believed that he had reason to
believe she was going to be a witness
because of his own conduct
then he is guilty
this question is from senator kerry of
nebraska
to the council for the president could
you elaborate on your comments about the
settlement of the jones case focusing on
the reality for example that
corporations in this country
routinely settle cases they regard as
utterly without merit simply to spare
the costs of defense public
embarrassment and for other reasons
the chief justice i think
far better than i did the senator from
nebraska has already
elaborated on my answer i think
all of us
who have been involved either as lawyers
or as parties unhappily in litigation
know the burden that it imposes and one
can only imagine
and i am barely able to the special
burden that it places on
a president to be immersed in
this kind of litigation
we take i think as a basic understanding
and our jurisprudence
that as a matter of law
the settlement of a case
is not probative of any belief on either
side about the strengths or weaknesses
but
what it is as a matter of law is
probably less relevant
than what it is to this body or to the
public perception
but underlying the law about what one
can do in litigation
in using a decision to settle is i think
a common sense judgment
that everybody whether it be a large
corporation or an individual or the
president of the united states
makes a judgment
about where
his or her resources should be expended
and i don't mean simply resources in
terms of dollars
although they're certainly important but
resources in terms of energy
time
worry
interference with the day-to-day
business that all of us have to conduct
and i think it's fair to say
it's those factors those very common
sense factors the ones we would all
weigh in different circumstances in
different settings if we were caught up
in litigation
that inform your judgment
about what you should or in my judgment
should not
take
from the fact that the president settled
this case
this question is from senators uh
nichols warner helms imhof and thurman
to counsel for the president
members of the armed services are
presently removed from service for
improper sexual conduct
and or for perjury
if the president is acquitted by the
senate would not result in a lower
standard of conduct
for the commander-in-chief than the
other 1.3 million members of the armed
services
mr chief justice this of course
is a question legitimately asked but i
also think legitimately answered
no
we all understand entirely what rules
are imposed on members of the armed
services indeed every member
of the federal civil service
every member of
a private company
when they engage in certain conduct
they may be sanctioned for it and in the
military i understand
as do the
senators who have much greater personal
and institutional experience with our
armed forces than
i the importance
of maintaining
do order and discipline in the armed
services and also the importance
of believing that nothing that the
commander-in-chief does or says
could should ever
undermine
the strength of our armed forces their
cohesiveness or their belief
in the rules and the and the integrity
of the rules that govern them
but that said
a i do not believe
as a matter of
what will flow from an acquittal of the
president who is indeed the
commander-in-chief
that that will in fact
undermine
the good order and discipline of the
army but
if i am wrong in some fashion about that
if my understanding of the process is
flawed and it may well be
we nonetheless have to ask the question
which i think is implicit
in the question that was put to me
does it because of the rules that apply
to members of the armed forces
does it follow
that because a sergeant or a lieutenant
or a general or an admiral
will suffer in his career
that we must go back to
the framers
who wrote the impeachment clause and say
they must have expected
that the commander-in-chief the
president
would be removed for the same conduct
they had an armed forces then
indeed they were probably more
intimately involved with that having
just come through the revolution
than
presidents
and leaders of the country have been in
the following 210 years
they surely
understood that there was
a constitutional and societal difference
between the president and his role as
commander-in-chief
and the president is his role in his
role as the leader of the country on the
one hand
and those
to whom rules of discipline had to apply
in order to
secure the strongest and best armed
forces that we could secure
it is in a sense i suppose
not an easy answer to give because
members of the armed forces put their
lives on the line
and we want them to feel
that they're being treated fairly
but at the end of the day
it cannot be
that the president of the united states
is removable
for conduct
that would adversely affect the career
of a member of the military
there may be occasions on which
the president engages in such
horrific conduct
that he ought to be removed and the same
would happen to an admiral or a general
or the chief of the head of the chief of
staff
joint chiefs
or the highest military
member that you can contemplate
but that doesn't mean that this conduct
is transposed from
the world of the military into the world
of the constitution in such a way
that the president even if he is our
commander-in-chief
should be removed from office because i
think that judgment would be
inconsistent with the judgment made by
the framers
mr chief justice i suggest this would be
an excellent time to take a one-hour
break for lunch
in the absence of objection it's so
ordered okay
so
while the senate takes this lunch break
in the eighth day of the impeachment
trial of the president we again invite
you to call us with your thoughts on
what you've seen over these eight days
this the second day of the senator's
questions if the senate comprises
god-fearing honorable statesman
courageous enough to deal with this
issue
or politicians like clinton with no fear
of god his arrogance is unbelievable i
think he should be
removed the chief justice who is
moderating the session as soon as he
returns the senate will be reconvening
that momentarily until then el cajon
california
the senate will be in order the chair
recognizes the majority leader thank you
mr chief justice uh mr chief justice we
are ready momentarily to begin with the
questioning period again i believe the
first question would come uh through
senator daschle um i did want to say to
our colleagues that
um
any senator is entitled to profound
question on both sides uh and uh so we
will give you every opportunity to do
that
again it is our intent to go uh today
not later than four o'clock
and if additional time is needed for
questions it would have to go over
until monday
we have some questions that have already
been propounded that we would like to
put to one side or the other
but at some point i think we would have
a sense that maybe
the basic questions have been asked so
if any senator on either side feels
strongly about a particular question
he or she may want to be thinking about
you know how and when they would insist
that that be offered but i i think that
a lot of ground has been covered i hope
that within a reasonable period of time
the questions that senators had
or have will be given and we'll have a
response and then we'll make a decision
on how to proceed from there
i yield mr chief justice
this is a question from senator bingaman
to counsel for the president
uh when samuel dash resigned as advisor
to the independent council he wrote in
the letter of resignation
that he was doing so because the
independent counsel had become an
advocate and it unlawfully intruded on
the power of impeachment which the
constitution gives solely to the house
in
in using his power to assist one party
to the pending impeachment child before
the senate do you believe he is
unlawfully intruded on the power of the
senate to try impeachments
mr chief justice senators
the independent council statute
gives the independent council in some
sense
almost unbounded power
to investigate the president and other
high officials of government
it does not give him and has never given
him under unbounded power
even to the extent that he has become
immersed in
the impeachment proceedings in the house
for the statute itself says
not
you shall become the 436th member of the
house
not that impeachment is vested
in the independent council but that
impeachment is vested in the house and
trial in the senate
we were obviously dismayed at the role
that
the independent council chose to follow
rather than simply sending
information
to the house
that might bear on possible impeachable
offenses
but rather to
drive his van
up to the building and unload
unscreened undiluted
boxes of information which thereafter
made their way at least in part
into the public domain
but surely it was a shock to all of us
at least on this side
to learn yesterday evening
that playing a role in the house
proceeding
had now
become a role in this chamber
that the independent council was using
not only his powers of coercion
but calling on the united states
district court to assist him
in in turn enabling the managers
not simply as they would have it to do a
little work product
to do a little meeting and greeting to
do a little saying hello and little
chatting
with who's someone who may be
a witness
before this body
but rather saying to this witness
i hold your life in my hands
and i'm going to transfer that power
to the managers for the house of
representatives
managers have said we're engaged in an
adversary process here
and they themselves have talked
long and
loud today about letting them play out
the process that any lawyer would play
out in preparing for trial well no other
lawyer that i know of
gets to have a prosecutor sitting in the
room with him
and saying to the witness
talk to these people
or your immunity deal is gone and you
may go to jail
now we've been accused by manager
hutchinson and others
i'm always talking about process
of always falling back on process well i
suggest senators that process is what
our just justice system is all about
process is what we've always relied on
to protect everyone
against
the vaunted power of the state in this
case not just the managers
but the state embodied
in the independent council
but in this case it's more than just a
call for due process for fairness
because it's going to have a direct and
immediate impact on the facts as we
learn them as they learn them and most
importantly as you learn them
can you imagine can you imagine what
it's going to be like for monica
lewinsky to be sitting in a room
with the 13 managers or however many
there are
and the independent council and his
lawyers
knowing
the threat that she's under
knowing how she got into that room
can we have any reason to believe that
what comes out of that process
will be the fair unvarnished
truth
or will she of necessity be looking over
her shoulder and saying
i better not put one foot wrong
because the independent counsel is
sitting there watching
and he's already told me
that this deal is gone
if i don't cooperate with the house
managers
process and truth
they're inextricably linked
but not
not
if the independent council
moves to that side of the room
and becomes the moving force
in the development of the truth and the
facts as this body is entitled to know
accuse us of
talking about process if you will accuse
us
if you will about falling back on
process
we do it
proudly because process is what this is
all about
because process leads to truth but not
that way
this is a question from senator spector
frist smith of new hampshire inhofe
lugar brownback
roth and crapo
to counsel for the president
in arguing that an impeachable offense
involves only a public duty what is your
best argument that a public duty is not
involved in the president's
constitutional duty to execute the laws
at a minimum doesn't the president have
a duty not to violate the laws under the
constitutional responsibility to execute
the laws
it can't be
it can't be
that if the president violates the law
and thus violates his duty faithfully to
carry out the laws
he's removed from office
because that would literally encompass
virtually every
law
every regulation every policy every
guideline that you could imagine that
he's responsible for carrying out in the
executive branch
if that were so
it would have been very simple for the
framers to say
president shall be impeached for treason
bribery and failure to carry out his
oath faithfully to execute the laws
they wrote that
they could have incorporated it into the
impeachment clause if they'd wish and
they chose not to
so that if in fact you suggest that
a failure to faithfully execute the laws
inevitably leads to a decision that an
impeachable and removable offense has
been committed
i suggest
with all respect that you have simply
eliminated
the impact of
the words treason bribery and other high
crimes and misdemeanors
now you may well judge
within that setting that is within that
constitutional standard other high
crimes and misdemeanors
that some particular violation of law
warrants removal
but it surely can't be
just looking back at what the framers
did and what the words themselves mean
that any violation even if you were to
find one
must lead you to conclude that having
therefore violated his responsibility to
faithfully execute the laws
removal must follow
framers knew what the other parts of the
constitution said and they specifically
chose the words they chose intending
that they cover only the most egregious
violations of the public law and public
trust that they could conceive of
this is from question
from senator graham to counsel for
president clinton
in the event that the senate determines
the removal of the president is not
warranted
are there any constitutional impediments
to the following actions
one a formal motion of censure
two a motion other than censure
incorporating the senate's
acknowledgement
and disapproval of the president's
conduct
three a motion requiring a formal
presidential apology or any other
statement accepting the judgment of the
senate or four a motion requiring the
president to state that he will not
accept a pardon for any previous
criminal activities
assuming that one or more of the above
actions are constitutional are there any
other serious policy concerns about the
advisability of the senate formally
adopting a legislative sanction of the
president that falls outside the scope
of the constitutional sanction of
removal from office
the senator from texas
the record may so show
all right
uh senator graham i apologize i had
assumed that since senator daschle sent
it up that it was probably from this
side but i'm glad you clarified the
record for him
uh that question uh probably requires
much more constitutional learning to
answer in great detail than i possess
but
let me give it a try
and the easiest one for me to answer is
the fourth part
would it be appropriate for
in some fashion for the president
formally to
state that he would not accept a pardon
i have stated
formally on behalf of the president in
response to a very specific question by
the house judiciary committee that he
would not
and indeed we have said in this chamber
and
and we have said in other places that
the president is subject to the rule of
law like any other citizen and would
continue to be
on january 21st 2001
and that he would submit himself
to whatever law and whatever sanction or
whatever prosecution
the law would impose on him he's
prepared to defend himself in
that forum
at any time
following his
the end of his tenure and i committed on
his behalf and i have no doubt that he
would so state himself that he would not
seek or accept a pardon
i i will not even begin to tread on
uh the territory that is uh
that is the senate's jurisdiction and
the issues that uh it takes unto itself
much less give it advice about what it
is possible or not possible to do
except to venture this
i see no constitutional barrier
certainly to the senate's
passing a
censure motion
uh in whatever form
uh it chooses
whether adopting uh language from the
articles or
or uh creating language of its own
we might at the end of the day disagree
with you about whether
the language is justified or whether it
accurately reflects the facts but there
is nothing in the in the constitution i
believe that prevents this body
from
undertaking that task
now with respect to
a formal acknowledgement
there i suppose the interplay between
the legislative and the executive branch
becomes more tenuous
but to the extent that
whatever the senate chooses to say
in such a document
needs to be acknowledged
or recognized by the president
and that can be done without
trenching on
the separation of powers
and
uh
in that special uncertain area between
the legislative and executive branches i
have no doubt that some process can be
worked out that meets the senate's needs
i say this all in the sort of vast limbo
of hypothesis because obviously
i'm answering both somewhat off the cuff
and without knowing what language we're
talking about but the core position as
we see it is
that nothing stands in the way of this
body from voicing its sentiments and
indeed i have said in the house of
representatives
that i thought accenture was an
appropriate response
and the president has said he's prepared
to accept the century and i have no
doubt that although that was said in the
context of the proceedings in the house
it surely
is applicable as well to anything that
this body chooses to do
this is a question from senator thompson
to the house managers do you have any
comment on the answer given by the
president's council with regard to the
office of independent counsel
mr chief justice senators thank you for
that question
it is our judgment and i think a fair
judgment that we should be allowed and
are permitted under any of the rules
normal to all of this to request
of the office of independent counsel the
opportunity to talk to monica lewinsky
which we otherwise apparently were not
going to be had able to have as a normal
course of preparation it makes me wonder
with all of the complaints that are
going on here from the white house
attorneys
about this and
their desire not to have witnesses what
they're afraid of are they afraid of our
talking to monica lewinsky are they
afraid of the deposition of monica
lewinsky are they afraid of what she
might say out here
i don't think they should be but they
appear to be
we're not doing anything abnormal we're
exercising our privileges our rights uh
if we're a prosecutor
and you had a prosecutorial arm which
you do in the case of the independent
council office that had an immunity
agreement as there is in this case
you certainly would not hesitate if you
had a recalcitrant witness who you
needed to call
to utilize that immunity agreement and
have the opportunity to discuss the
matter with that witness and you
certainly wouldn't hesitate if you
needed to to use that immunity agreement
to assure truthful testimony in any
proceeding that was going on after all
that's the purpose of the immunity
agreement it means that the witness is
probably much more likely to be telling
the truth than under any other
circumstances which is why councils
frequently argue immunity agreements as
a reason why a particular witness is
more credible than they might otherwise
be if they were not for that agreement
so i think that there's an awful lot
being said today about our meeting that
we want to have with ms lewinsky to
prepare her as a witness and i want to
tell you all it is
being done in my judgment with all due
respect to those who are doing it uh
principally because of concerns that
they don't want us to have that
opportunity or they want to cast some
aspersion or doubt or whatever we aren't
about to do anything improper we can
assure you of that we would never do
that we're going to follow regular order
and do this as good councils would do in
good faith and in no way will wish to do
anything otherwise nor have we thank you
there's a question from senator baucus
to the house managers in view of the
direct election of the president his
popularity in short duration of his term
and in view of the fact that as house
manager graham stated reasonable people
can differ in this case please explain
precisely how acquitting the president
will result in an immediate threat to
the stability of our government
mr chief
justice ladies and gentlemen of the
senate
i don't think anyone contends that
if the president is acquitted that
suddenly it's apocalypse now
or the
republic will be threatened from
without or from within
i think
erosion can happen very slowly but very
deliberately
the problem that i have
is with this office being
fulfilled by someone who has a double
responsibility the first responsibility
is to take care
that the laws be faithfully executed
he's the only person in the country in
the world
that has that
compact with the american people
the other of course is his oath
to preserve protect and defend the
constitution
he is the national role model
he is the man
he is the flag bearer in front of our
country he is the person his office is
the person every parent
says to their little child i hope you
grow up and be president of the united
states someday
we do nothing as important as raising
our kids
and the president is the role model for
every kid in the country
and when you have a president who lies
and lies and lies
under oath and that's the key phrase
under oath i don't care about his
private life or his
matters that are not public
but when he
takes an oath
to tell the truth the whole truth
nothing but the truth and then lies and
lies and lies what kind of a lesson is
that for our kids and our grandkids
what does it do to the rule of law
injustice is a terrible thing the longer
you live the more you can encounter it
injustice abuse oppression
and the law is what protects you the law
having resort to an objective standard
of
morality in action
and
when you are sworn to take care that the
laws are faithfully executed how do you
reconcile the conduct of
perjury
obstruction of justice
with that obligation
i have a
a suggestion let's just tear it out of
the constitution tear out that
take care to see that the laws are
faithfully executed
it's wrong it's an example we're setting
for
millions of kids
that if the president can do it you can
do it
what do you say to master sergeants that
have their careers
destroyed because they hit on a
inferior
member of the military
no if we are setting the parameters of
permissible presidential conduct
for the one office that ought to gleam
in the sunlight
and
the kids
that's what moves me the kids
this question is from senators nichols
warner crapo helms inhofe and thurman to
the house managers
would you like to comment on the remarks
of council ruff concerning the impact of
an acquittal of the president accused of
improper sexual conduct and or perjury
and obstruction on the armed forces
mr chief justice
i'd like the to thank the senators for
the question because i believe it's also
insightful
need a page
the question
of double standards or establishing
lower standards i believe is
extraordinarily important
the defense
asserted and it's hard for me to believe
but they're asking you to set higher
standards for judges
at a lower standard for a president who
nominates them to you
asking you then then they think that
we can set a higher standard for law
enforcement
yet establish a lower standard for the
chief executive or the chief law
enforcement
officer that has the duty
to faithfully see that the laws are
executed
set a higher standard for military
personnel
and then a lower standard for the
commander-in-chief
who must make the painful decisions
to send them into battle
now the precedence
in impeachment trials here in the senate
the judgment of the armed services
committee and the senate regarding the
standards for promotion have been
otherwise than that which mr ruff has
asserted
we must confront the fact that the
president is the commander-in-chief
and i believe that it is perfectly
acceptable
of the american people to demand of the
military the highest standard
which also means that those of whom find
themselves in positions of
responsibility in the pentagon of whom
are in civilian leadership but also must
also live by such exemplary conduct and
standards
the high character of military officers
is a safeguard
of the character of a nation
the senate who must ratify the officer's
promotion list has repeatedly found that
anything less than exemplary conduct is
uh is therefore unworthy of a commission
or further promotion
i recall when i first came to congress
in 1992 there were many making a big
to-do over tail hook
remember
and it was serious
there are still remnants around of tail
hook because there are still those who
are screening the officer's promotion if
you are within 100 miles of tail hook
look out for your career
that needs to be put to bed
then i was given a duty to ensure that
after aberdeen broke and the sexual
misconduct in the military whether it
was at fort jackson aberdeen or at other
places i spent 18 months out on the road
to ensure that the policies of the
military were fair in the treatment of
equal dignity in the workplace among men
and women
we can't forget that
you see we also must recognize and must
be candid with the harsh reality that
the officers and ncos are human and not
without fault folly and failings
i believe though it's the aspirations of
high ideals that is important
for each of us
but more so to the military in order to
keep the trust and the public faith of
the military
you see it's a soldier a sailor an
airman or marine is prepared to lay down
his or her life to defend the
constitution
and it is the devotion and the fidelity
to the oath without mental reservation
that is the epitome
of character
now the president is not and should not
be subject to the uniform code of
military justice and i concur with mr
ruff when he made that point
and the president is not an actual
member of the military
but we have a unique system in the world
we have that civilian control of the
military and it works
but we also must be recognized and be
cognizant
that the president however is at the
pinnacle he is at the top of the chain
of command
and that is what i learned about being
on the road for 18 months and how do we
make corrections of how do you set the
proper dignity in the workplace
it doesn't matter if it's your own
office or in fact if you're the
president is commander-in-chief whoever
who leads you set the tone and tenor of
those of whom must follow
you see the message is that the military
personnel do look to the
commander-in-chief to set the high
standard of moral and ethical behavior
the military personnel are required to
set a high standard of conduct in order
to set the example to those they lead
adherence to high standards is the
fabric of good order and discipline when
military leaders fall short of this
ideal then there is confusion and
disruption in the ranks
and today many do see a double standard
there is a double standard because the
commander-in-chief has allegedly
conducted himself
in a manner that would be a court
martial offense for military personnel
having been alleged of the very same
thing
the president's actions have had an
intangible and coercive impact upon
military personnel to turn a blind eye
and a deaf ear to it would be shame on
us
the questions soldiers and sailors ask
are i took an oath to swear to tell and
tell the truth and i also uh took an
oath to uphold the constitution
how can this president take the same
oath and not be truthful and remain in
office
if i were to have done what the
president did i'd be court-martialed
you see we also have to recognize that
each of the services are recruiting
young people all across the nation
at boot camp they infuse these young
people with moral values of honor
courage and commitment and their
teaching self-restraint discipline and
self-sacrifice
military leaders are required to provide
a good example to those young recruits
yet when they look up the chain of
command all the way to the commander in
chief
they see a double standard at the top
again it's the president that sets the
tone and tenor for the military just as
he does for law enforcement
i believe the president has violated a
sacred trust between the leaders and
those of whom he was entrusted to lead
i also spoke in my presentation that it
was the president's self-inflicted
wounds have called his own credibility
into question not only in his
decision-making process
but with regard to mr
the chairs of the view that you have
answered the question
thank you mr chief justice
this is a question from senator
torricelli to the president's council
at the outset of the house proceedings a
member of the majority
now a manager stated
the solemn duty that confronts us
requires that we attain a heroic level
of bipartisanship
and that we conduct our deliberations in
a fair full and independent manner
the american people deserve a competent
independent and bipartisan review of the
independent council's report
they must have confidence in the process
politics must be checked at the door
in evaluating the case against the
president should the senate take into
account a the partisan nature of the
proceedings in the house or be
the public's lack of confidence in the
proceedings thus far
chief justice
i think that this body has got to take
into consideration what brought these
articles here
and that's the action both of the
independent council
and the house of representatives
and i think when fairly considered
when you look at the actions of both
you find an absence of fairness and
bipartisanship
the independent council investigated
this case for eight months
it developed
every bit of evidence it could
that was negative
derogatory
or prejudicial and it put him into those
five volumes
it did not pursue exculpatory leads
it did not follow up
evidence that might lead to evidence of
innocence
and it downplayed when it came to write
the referral
significant
testimony
which was exculpatory or helpful
i think the independent council's
process
was really epitomized by ms lewinsky's
statement that nobody
asked her to lie
or had promised her a job for silence
you see the independent counsel didn't
bring out that testimony in fact
it came out when the independent council
was through examining ms lewinsky in the
grand jury and i just want to read you a
very short part of that
it's a page 1161 of the appendix
the independent council's prosecutor
says
we don't have any further questions
and a grand juror pipes up
could i ask one
monica is there anything that you would
like to add
to your prior testimony either today or
the last time you were here
or anything that you think needs to be
amplified on or clarified
i just want to give you the fullest
opportunity and here's what ms lewinsky
says
i would
i think because of the public nature of
how this investigation has been and what
the charges aired that i would just like
to say that no one ever asked me to lie
and i was never promised a job for my
silence
and that i'm sorry
i'm really sorry for everything that
happened now
we requested the independent counsel
before he sent the referral to the house
of representatives for an opportunity to
review that
we were denied this
i think if you compare what happened
here with what happened in 1974
when special prosecutor jaworski
sent a transmission of evidence to the
house judiciary committee the comparison
is very revealing then
special prosecutor jaworski sent only a
roadmap of the evidence a description of
what was in the record
judge
sarika reviewed that at a hearing where
white house counsel were president judge
sarika then
said it was a fair impartial summary and
transmitted it on to the house judiciary
committee
here
without review either by the presiding
judge or the grand jury
a referral was sent to the house that
was a one-sided
unfair prosecutorial summary
when the house managers speak of the
need for discovery they have no such
need everything prejudicial that could
be found through an unlimited budget and
a seemingly endless investigation has
been found and put there
tied up with a red ribbon for them
in terms of bipartisanship in the house
i think that speaks for itself i don't
think this was a bipartisan process i
don't think it was a bipartisan result i
think though it rests with this body
to try
the case it's clear under the
constitution
that this body has the power the sole
power to try impeachments the chief
justice in the nixon case made that very
clear i'm not going to comment on the
independent council's assistance to the
house manager with the with ms lewinsky
i think that's for you to decide whether
that is consonant with how you decide
the case ought to be tried but i think
that the presentation of the articles to
this body has been neither fair nor
bipartisan
this is a question from senator lot to
the house managers do you have any
comment on the answer just given by the
president's council
mr chief justice members of the senate
i welcome this opportunity to
fill in a
considerable gap in the record
mr kendall said earlier
today or perhaps yesterday we it was
yesterday we never had a chance to call
witnesses ourselves to examine them to
cross-examine them to subpoena
documentary evidence at no point in this
process
on october 5th 1998 the house judiciary
committee passed house res 581 by voice
vote the impeachment inquiry procedure
which included the right to call
witnesses for
the president on october 21st the house
judiciary committee staff met with mr mr
ruff mr kendall and mr craig
at that time the judiciary committee
staff
asked the white house to provide any
exculpatory information provide a list
of any witnesses they wanted to call
without result on november 9 the house
judiciary committee wrote to messers
rough kendall and craig and again
informed them of the president's right
to call witnesses
on november 19th
independent council star testified 12
hours before the house committee on the
judiciary president's council was given
the opportunity to question the
independent council he did not ask a
single question relating to the facts of
the independent council's allegations
against the president now the democrats
had mr kendall
they had abby lowell
we had dave shippers
that's not an invidious comparison
on november 25th
i wrote a letter to the president asking
the president among other things to
provide any exculpatory information and
inform the committee of any witnesses it
wanted to call
without success
on december 4th
two working days before the presentation
of the president to the judiciary
committee counsel for the president
requested to put on 15 witnesses
the white house was allowed to present
all 15 witnesses not a single one of
those was a fact witness
and lastly i quote from a letter from mr
kendall
to mr bittman it's in
volume three part two of two
page two three two six
that you now request we submit
exculpatory evidence is perfectly
consonant with the occasionally alice in
wonderland nature of this whole
enterprise i'm not aware of anything the
president needs to exculpate
this question is from senator lay to the
white house counsel
the managers argued in response to a
previous question that would set a bad
example for the military to acquit the
president
given that argument how can you
reconcile the statement by manager hyde
after casper weinberger was pardoned by
president bush of multiple criminal
violations including perjury
that i'm glad the president had the hood
spa to do it the prosecution of
weinberger was a was political in nature
an effort to get at ronald reagan i just
wish us out of this mess the six years
and this 30 or 40 million dollars that
has been spent by independent council
lawrence e walsh
the question in
virtually every respect speaks for
itself
but i would make this point because i
think it fleshes out a bit
my earlier answer and responds
in some fashion to the argument made by
the managers on this very issue
i was probably too
lawyerly
this is my want
in responding to the earlier question on
this issue by senators warner and
thurman and others
because i think the one point that needs
to be made in the context of senator
leahy's question
which goes to
the leadership of the secretary of
defense
and the issue of what it means to
undertake the removal of the president
the distinction
that i think we all need to hold on to
here
that i probably glided over too rapidly
in my earlier answer is that the
president of the united states
is elected by the people of the united
states
he appoints the secretary of defense
he appoints the officers in the military
he appoints the judges
and the senate plays a role in that
process
by approving his choices or occasionally
not approving his choices
but there's only one person
who's put in his job with the voice of
the people
and however we may
be concerned as rightly we should
if that person oversteps the bounds
either of his office or his personal
conduct
to say that there is some
one-to-one
or any other number you can think of
comparison
between the impact of enforcing the law
on those
civilian and military personnel who
serve their country
and the very different question
of whether the voice of the people will
be stilled by removing the president
is the point on which i think this body
needs to focus
this question is from senators kyle and
mack to counsel for the president
mr ruff said president clinton was never
asked in the grand jury whether
everything he testified to and the jones
deposition was true
if he were asked would he say it was all
true
would the president be willing to answer
on interrogatory from the senate
answering that question
senator
it is true that he
testified
that he tried to be truthful in the
jones deposition
that it was his purpose to be accurate
in the jones deposition
he tried to navigate his way through a
minefield without violating the law and
he believes that he did
there is no statement
in that testimony the grand jury
that reaffirms ratifies and confirms
all of his testimony
in the jones deposition
now we would
be happy to take questions in response
and and get responses to you
consult uh with president mr rough if
you'd like to submit them
this is a question from senator murray
to the white house counsel
has ms lewinsky ever claimed that she
was sexually harassed by the president
justice
ms lewinsky has made no such claim
what happened between the president and
her
was improper but it was consensual
to say that does not
excuse it or sugarcoat it or justify it
but it does i think put it in the proper
context
she has never claimed that she has any
evidence at all
relevant to sexual harassment by the
president
when
the president
and i i i went through this on
thursday in in in respect to the object
obstruction of justice allegation
about the president
stating that she could file an affidavit
the president and miss lewinsky
reasonably believed that she could have
filed a limited but truthful affidavit
and i think you've got to look to the
fact that the jones case was not a class
action
it was a suit only about what ms
jones claimed happened in may 1991 in a
little rock hotel room
uh the december 11th ruling on discovery
was a ruling not on admissibility uh but
discovery
uh the president believed that an
affidavit a truthful affidavit might be
successful not that it would but that it
might be now in filing such an affidavit
in in in preparing it no particular form
was necessary there was nothing to
dictate what had to go in and what had
to go out of it
there were many witnesses on the witness
list
discovery the end of discovery was
approaching
and
there was at least some chance
they thought that a factual affidavit
which was limited might accomplish the
purpose and i think this is confirmed by
the fact that when judge wright
considered
whether to order ms lewinsky's
deposition she issued a ruling on
january the 29th
saying that
the deposition would not go forward
because evidence from ms lewinsky
would not be admissible
at the paula jones trial because it was
both irrelevant to the core allegations
and it was inadmissible as extrinsic uh
evidence of of other facts
so i think that ms lewinsky had nothing
whatsoever to offer on the critical
issue in the paula jones case which was
an issue of sexual harassment
this is a question by senator shelby to
the house managers
would a verdict of not guilty be a
stronger message of vindication for the
president than a motion to dismiss or in
the alternative a motion to adjourn what
are the constitutional implications if
any if a motion to dismiss prevailed
short of concluding the trial
mr chief justice members of the senate
there are various options it's really
a misdirected question if i may say to
ask us to suggest
consequences of solutions to this
dilemma that we're in
i think the
beauty and that's not the word i think
the advantage of proceeding
with the articles of impeachment is it's
consonant with the constitution
it's simple it's clean
either guilty or not guilty the
consequences of that verdict of course
are
up to any individual who casts a vote
now if you uh i heard the word censure
sometime before
um
you gentlemen and ladies do
anything you want to do it's your
it's your power it's your authority it's
in your
yard
but you've got to deal with the
constitution no matter what you do you
have a problem of a bill of attainder
you have a problem of the separation of
powers you have a problem of any
censure to be meaningful has to at least
damage the president's reputation
and that becomes in my judgment
a bill of attainer but that again is up
to you
the consequences
i don't think will harm us whatever you
do
we've done our best we've lived up to
our responsibility under the
constitution
and all we ask is that you live up to
your responsibilities under the
constitution and give us a trial
i'm sure you will
this is a question to the president's
council from senator levin
monica lewinsky has explicitly
explicitly said in her hand written
proffer that no one encouraged her to
lie
yet house manager aza hutchinson claimed
to the senate using inferences that ms
lewinsky was encouraged to lie
do the house managers argue that such
inferences are as credible as ms
lewinsky's direct testimony to the
contrary
council
i think senator levin's question chief
justice goes
to the heart of much of what we have
been
saying for the last
few days
if in fact you look at the five volumes
stacked up in front of my colleague mr
kendall
you will see
ms lewinsky say not just once but many
times in essence that i was never
told to never encouraged to lie
never traded an affidavit for a job
never did any of the things that lie at
the very heart of
the manager's case
and so what do we have then
we have
the managers trying to snatch
a bit of evidence here or a bit of
speculation there or a bit of
extrapolation
over there
and say well
she really didn't mean it
when she said several times quite
directly nobody ever told me or
encouraged me to lie
it is possible of course
whenever one deals with
circumstantial evidence to make
reasonable
leaps from that evidence to some viable
conclusion
but i think most courts that we are
familiar with and that those of you who
practice
law are familiar with
would have a great deal of difficulty in
concluding
that if i take
a little bit here and a little bit there
and a little bit over there and pull
them all together in some vast
speculation about what was really in
someone's mind
and on the other side i have the person
saying what's in her mind
and saying the opposite
i don't think that case
would ever get to the jury
and maybe it's one of the things that
worries me just a little bit
about the normal day
we do it all the time conference between
the managers and the independent council
and ms lewinsky
then maybe in that setting with the
independent council
gently patting ms lewinsky on the back
and telling her it's time to cooperate
maybe the message will be
come closer
to their side
and their speculation
don't stay where you were which is what
you told
the grand jury and the fbi and us under
oath and not under oath on multiple
occasions which is indeed
nobody told me to nobody encouraged me
to lie
this is a question from senator bond to
the house managers
when mrs mill ms mills described pres
the president's testimony before the
jones grand jury
she
she said the president was surprised by
questions about ms lewinsky
what evidence is there
of the president's knowledge that
lewinsky questions would be asked
is there evidence he knew in advance the
details of the lewinsky affidavit which
his council presented at the jones
deposition
thank you mr chief justice
well there's
numerous
evidences in the
record to show that the president was
not surprised about the questions
pertaining to monica lewinsky at the
january 17th deposition
first of all in regard to the affidavit
testimony of monica lewinsky is that i
believe it was january 6th it was fifth
or sixth that she discussed that with
the president the signing of the
affidavit and the contents of that
affidavit that's whenever he made his
statement uh don't worry i don't see it
i've seen 15 of them again we don't know
what he's referring to in reference to
that 15 but clearly
according to monica lewinsky's testimony
she went over the contents of that even
though she might not have had it in hand
she went over the contents of that
with the president also circumstantially
there's conversation between mr jordan
and the president during this time
but in addition let me just recall
something i made in my presentation
that a few days before
the president's
grand
deposition testimony that it was michael
issakov of a national
publication
called betty curry
and ask about
courier records on the gifts
this startled betty currier betty curry
obviously because the gifts at that
point were under her bed
and so she went
as she recalled she probably told the
president that
and then secondly she went to see vernon
jordan about that issue
all of that leads you to believe clearly
that the president fully knew that when
he went to the deposition on january
17th that he would be asked time and
time again about the specifics of his
relationship with monica lewinsky
so i think that addresses part of that
question let me remark on what mr ruff
just said i'm just constantly amazed
about
our effort to interview witnesses
because yesterday
mr ruff i believe it was and it might
have been mr candle so excuse me if i've
got the attribution wrong
but criticized us saying they want to
call witnesses but they have no clue
what these witnesses would say
you recall that that was the argument
yesterday
and so if we make an effort to determine
what these witnesses would say
they were criticized for
trying to find out what they would say
and so i think that again
it's more convenient to talk about what
the managers are doing what the process
is rather than the facts of obstruction
this is a question to the white house
counsel from senator kennedy
would you please respond to manager
hyde's suggestion that an acquittal
would send a bad message to the children
of the country and to manage your hide
statements regarding the fairness of the
process in the house of representatives
mr chief justice
thank you for that question senator
the children
what do we tell the children
well ladies and gentlemen of the senate
that's not an academic question for me
and for my wife
and i assume that's the case for many
many families all over this country
we happen to have quite a few children
and they're very young
they're under 12.
and we talk about what is going on here
and we talk about how important it is to
tell the truth
and we talk about how wrong it was for
the president of the united states not
to tell the truth
and we think
that we've learned a lot
by going through that process
we have talked about what president
clinton did and why it was
wrong and with all due respect to the
chairman of the house judiciary
committee i
and my wife and i don't think many
parents when they raise their children
rely every day on messages or
resolutions from the congress of the
united states
to tell them that it's important to
teach children
the importance of truth telling
i'm a little bit disappointed in the
inference of the argument
that those of us
who oppose impeachment
for the reasons that you understand
somehow
are sending a message that it's okay to
kids
not to tell the truth i'm a little bit
disappointed in that argument
because i don't think that's the way the
parents of this country feel that's
certainly not the way i feel
and i don't believe that impeachment
is a question of what you tell your
children about truth-telling of course
you tell your children to tell the truth
of course you tell your children the
difference between right and wrong
i'm surprised it's an issue here
now as to the second part of your
question senator
i went through that house of
representatives experience
and i must say that i was disappointed
in it
because we had been promised
bipartisanship
and when the office of independent
council
sent its referral
to the house of representatives
white house counsel did not have access
to that document before it was released
to the world
when the office of independent council
sent its 60 000 pages 19 boxes of
evidence
to the house of representatives
we were not given access the way members
of the judiciary committee were
to all that material we were given
access to a very limited amount of
material in the course of that process
in fact
much of that material we've never had
access to on behalf of the president
we were disappointed that there was no
full discussion of the constitutional
standards for impeachment before they
went forward to vote for an impeachment
inquiry we thought that was the cart
before the horse
we were disappointed and we regretted
that grand jury materials provided with
promises of confidentiality
were dumped into the public
with salacious material
unfiltered by the house of
representatives of the judiciary
committee
and we saw a party line vote after party
line vote after party line vote over and
over and over again in the judiciary
committee
we were disappointed that the
depositions went forward
without our participation
we were disappointed there was no
definition of the scope
of the inquiry
we were disappointed that there was no
term
of time
no limitation on either the scope or the
time of this inquiry
and we were disappointed that there was
no adequate notice of the charges
there were two
events that happened near the end of
this process that i think were
particularly disappointing to us
one was that while the debate was
underway on the house floor
members of the house of representatives
were taken into that evidence room
and shown evidence that was not in this
record
that had not been included
in the discussion in the house judiciary
committee that had never been shown to
the lawyers for the council
for the president
that was not in the referral
and became a factor
in the decision making at least of some
members of the house unfairly so i think
and finally we were disappointed that
the members of the house of
representatives were denied
the right and the opportunity to vote
for censure
they were promised the right to vote
their conscience they were told they
could vote their conscience and if
they'd been given that right to vote
their conscience we might may not be
here today we might have had the
resolution of censure and this thing
might have been resolved
and that was the greatest disappointment
of all
thank you
this is a question from senators bennett
brownback campbell hegel roth specter
and mcconnell
to the house managers
with each of the managers who have been
prosecutors prior to being elected to
the house of representatives please
state briefly whether he believes he
would have sought an indictment and
obtained a conviction of an individual
who had engaged in the conduct
of which the president is accused
mr chief justice i i know there are
several probably uh not only on our
table but all across
this senate who have had some experience
somewhere in prosecution of cases
i would just briefly say that
and i think it's probably been said very
well today more eloquently that i will
say it not only from some of the people
on our side but even some of the people
on the president's side have talked
about this same concept
of justice and and the rule of law
it is so important in our system of
justice that
that the american people have confidence
in that
and one of the ways that i found in my
experience that confidence sometimes
suffered
were phone calls that occasionally you
would receive where there had been an
allegation that someone in an elected
office or some public official in
particular had
allegedly again uh
committed a crime or perhaps been
charged with a crime and allegations of
cover-up because of who that person was
uh there was not equal justice out there
people were being treated differently
and especially and and that happens that
that comes with our territory we're very
visible people certainly the president
of the united states is the most visible
of us
as i said in my opening remarks he's a
role model for many people
and certainly when these kinds of
allegations come
up against the president
you people raise these kinds of thoughts
and and complaints
as a prosecutor i would find this type
of charge particularly of concern not
only because of the perjury which is so
important because as i said earlier too
truth underpins our whole system
but i find it equally compelling as a
prosecutor that a person of this
visibility of this responsibility not
only commits a crime himself
but he brings someone else into that
he ensnares
another person actually other people
into this
the cover-up the obstruction part
monica lewinsky betty curry vernon
jordan
all the white house people that we've
talked about he brings other people into
this and causes other people to commit
crimes i would view that even more
seriously because of the fact that he
and he made other people commit types of
crimes
and because of that
i think as a prosecutor for this another
person a john doe of some visibility a
local district attorney a local mayor or
something something like that there
would be no doubt that the allegations
would have to go to court and i might
add
in line with this that we've heard this
this
selecting the president out of this
process by saying well
you know we should not consider him like
we would a federal judge
or or like a general that we're talking
about maybe promoting to to head the
joint chiefs of staff or a captain for
promotion to major or any really anyone
else here
and it almost seems like
that
yes he is different
but it almost seems like we want to
treat him like a king
because he is the only person we've got
here
and and because he's the only one we we
can't look at him like we look at a
thousand judges or uh 200 generals and
and just write other public officials
and i i just i think there's that's a
fallacious argument if the facts are
there no matter if this man is the
president
to me that's what the constitution's
about i think they they they set up this
process to avoid a king and a kingdom
and i would
yield time to mr mccomb
i'll be much briefer and answering that
question mr chief justice i served as a
military judge advocate for four years
on active duty 20 more years in the
reserves i was a prosecutor defense
attorney and military judge i think this
is a very compelling case on the
evidence i would never hesitate to take
this to trial if i were prosecuting the
crimes of perjury obstruction of justice
or any of the military offenses that
might be included in here but just on
the criminal charges which are under the
ucmj i would certainly do so given the
opportunity for all the reasons and then
some that mr bryant gave
mr chief justice
uh to me this is not a hypothetical
question in any sense of the word as a
united states attorney under two
presidents
i had the opportunity not to not only to
contemplate
bringing such cases based on the
evidence of the law but actually having
the responsibility of carrying those
cases out prosecuting them including a
case that probably cost me a primary
election in the republican party for
prosecuting a member of congress for
precisely the activity which brings us
here today that is perjury misleading a
grand jury so the answer to the question
mr majority leader is not only yes
but absolutely yes
uh
mr hutchinson
well i i know we've run out of times the
answer is the facts the laws support it
and the answer is yes and may i add that
mr rogan who certainly prosecuted mr
lindsey graham and mr giekas
that all would if you would like to join
in that otherwise we all would affirm
that the answer is yes
this is a question to the president's
council from senators boxer and johnson
the managers repeatedly assert that if
the senate acquits president clinton the
senate will be making the statement that
the president of the united states
should be held above the law
if as the managers concede president
clinton may be held accountable in court
for the charges alleged in the house
articles regardless of the outcome of
his senate trial how could a senate vote
to acquit the president be fairly
characterized as a vote to place him
above the law
i suppose the one quote that has been
heard most often throughout these
proceedings in the house and in this
body is theodore roosevelt's and i won't
repeat it except
to
go to the heart of this question
the fact that we are having
this trial in this chamber the fact that
we had an impeachment proceeding in the
house is itself part of our rule of
law president is immersed in the
application of the rule of law at this
very moment
and the rule of law as i think my
colleague ms mills said
is neither
a sword nor a shield
depending on your perspective
we're all subject to it
and we live with its outcome if it is
fair
and is consistent with the system of
justice that we've developed in the last
two hundred and ten years
and so
the verdict here if it is not guilty
as i trust it will be
or if this trial is ended
appropriately through some other legal
motion or mechanism
as long as it's done within the rule of
law we'll have met
all of our obligations and most
importantly it will have ensured that
the president is treated
neither above nor below
but certainly the one issue that is
raised in this question
is important to focus on because
this is not a situation in which the
president
walks away scot-free
no matter what happens
not to mention the personal pain and the
pain that has been suffered in going
through this process
the president has said and i've said on
his behalf
that he will not
use his powers or ask anyone else to use
their powers to protect him against the
application of the rule of law
moreover
just in case
it has slipped
anyone's mind
and it's occasionally been
misstated in other forums
the statute
that has allowed the independent council
to pursue the president for the last
four plus years specifically provides
that he retains jurisdiction over the
president for a year after the president
has left office
so there can be no argument that
oh this will just fall into the cracks
or this will disappear into the ether
somewhere
the president is
will be at risk we trust that reasonable
judgments will be made and a
determination will be reached that it is
not appropriate to pursue him but that
too will be pursued under the rule of
law to which he is subject
this is a question from senators
campbell hegel and specter
to the house managers
white house counsel of several times
asserted that the grand jury perjury
charge is just a he says she says case
and that we cannot consider corrupt
corroborating witnesses you cite
what is it about the president's grand
jury testimony that convinces you he
should be removed from office
mr
chief justice
that question goes to the heart of what
we're here about today we've had a great
deal of discussion about a lot of
peripheral questions and issues but the
fact of the matter is the simplest
portion of this deals with grand jury
perjury and i assume the question
principally is directed to the first of
the four
uh
points under the grand jury perjury
article because with for example the
second point with respect to the
president having
the goal or the intent of being truthful
which he said he did in the grand jury
in the jones deposition there isn't a he
says she she says question that's just
very simple president lied multiple
times in that civil deposition
and if he said in the grand jury to the
grand jurors my goal was to be truthful
is pretty self-evident that that was a
lie and he purged himself so that's not
what he says she says but the question
that the council over here have tried to
bring up several times is saying the
part with with respect particularly uh
to monica lewinsky saying that the
president touched her in certain parts
of her body which would have been
covered by the jones definition of
sexual relations and the president who
said
explicitly in his grand jury testimony i
didn't touch those parts and yes i agree
that is would have been and is part of
the definition of sexual relations in
the jones case
that is whether you believe her or him
and they say that's what he says she
says and it's not
but even if it were you could listen to
it and accept it i think there's some
confusion about the law
the law of perjury does not require
grand jury perjury does not require two
witnesses nor does it require the
corroborating testimony of anybody else
it does not
that's why in 1970 it was changed and
most prosecutions today for perjury
including people who are in federal
prison today for grand jury for perjury
i should say in civil cases
for lying about matters related to sex
and there are several a couple of whom
testified before us in the judiciary
committee during our process and
hearings
is based are based upon that 1970 law
that does not require
any corroboration
in this case you have monica lewinsky
who is a very credible witness by other
reasons that you don't have to get to
those corroborating witnesses on these
points number one she was under immunity
under the threat of prosecution when she
testified that way number two
she has consistent statements throughout
many times over she didn't say she'd had
sexual intercourse with him she could
have made that up but she didn't
everything she says is believable about
that portion of it and third and not
last in all of this is that she did make
very contemporaneous statements to at
least six other people who were her
friends and counselors
describing in detail exactly the same
thing she testified to under oath before
the grand jury in this respect now they
say the counselors here you can't
consider that on the federal rules of
evidence because that's presumably
hearsay
well there are at least three exceptions
to that hearsay rule which could be
brought out in a courtroom
they've
gone about trying to carefully say we
never said that uh
that monica lewinsky lied i remember i
think was mr kendall maybe was mr craig
up here a little earlier saying
when asked that question did she lie
in this instance or any other and they
said well it's just a different version
of the truth well if she's saying it as
explicitly as she is about this nine
times or four times and whatever and the
president's saying i never did that
i don't see how they can fudge around
challenging her truthfulness and
credibility that's what they've been
doing and any courtroom i've ever been
in once that's occurred you could
certainly bring in her prior consistent
statements and you don't even have to go
with the rules of evidence on this
you're not bound by those rules of
evidence and common sense says that she
had no motive to be lying to her friends
in those numerous telephone
conversations or her meetings with her
counselors when she described in detail
these things the president says he
didn't do
because all of those statements occurred
all of those discussions occurred before
she ever was knowingly on a witness list
or likely to have to testify in any
other way she's very credible those
prior consistent statements are very
believable and i submit to you they
would be admissible in a court in the
kind of contest that would be involved
in a situation like this and it goes to
the very heart
of what we're here about grand jury
perjury the simplest clearest one
the president lied monica lewinsky told
the truth about it and it's profound
then it is important and it's critical
to this case and that's the principle
one of the perjuries that we've been
directing our attention to because it is
so clear thank you
this is a question from senator dorgan
to counsel for the president
how can the house claim that its
function is accusatory only
when the articles it voted for
voted call for the president's removal
this of course takes us back to the very
heart
of the argument that
raged for a small time here yesterday
and in previous days
the notion that the house of
representatives viewed itself
during the month of december
as merely
i won't even
say that it rose in their mind to the
level of accusatory body that we would
think of when we think of the grand jury
but to a body whose job it was as one of
the managers said at one point simply to
find probable cause to believe that the
president had committed these acts
perhaps there has been some
extraordinary transposition from
the mood and the tenor of the comments
made
during those days when the judiciary
committee was doing its work
to the days when these managers have
appeared in the well of the senate
something that has transformed
the mere probable cause screening
finding that they allegedly
viewed as the role of the house and of
the judiciary committee into the
certainty
that you're here today
it is a good question as to how then
given
the role they saw for themselves
they could go so far not only to seek
the removal of the president but indeed
to add
in all their prosecutorial vigor
something that has never been sought
before a bar against holding any future
office
at the level of certainty that they must
have achieved given the standard that
they held themselves to
what happened between december 19th
and today
that allows these managers
to come before you
not saying
well
we were certain then
and we're more certain now
or we only found probable cause back in
1998 but in 1999 we are sufficiently
certain that we ought to shut down
the public will as expressed in the
elections of 1996
i haven't yet found an answer to that
question
this question is from senators bond
brownback campbell hegel
luger hutchinson of texas
roth and stevens
it's directed to the house managers
after everything you've heard over the
last several weeks from the president's
council do you still believe that the
facts support the charges of obstruction
of justice alleged in the articles of
impeachment
specifically what allegations of
improper conduct has the president's
council failed to undermine
the question is also from senator
spector mcconnell
thank you mr chief justice
first of all why is obstruction of
justice important to begin with
i think back on a
opportunity i had in a hearing once to
question a member of the columbian drug
cartel and i asked him
what is the
greatest weapon that law enforcement has
that you fear
and his answer was very quickly
extradition
and i said well explain what do you mean
by why is extradition feared and he said
because in colombia you can fix the
system but in america you can't
and that's why i think the obstruction
of justice charge is so important to the
administration of justice money position
power
does not corrupt should not corrupt the
administration of justice
now the question is is
where has the president attacked the
councillors attacked credibly the
allegations of obstruction the first one
is that the president personally
encouraged a witness monica lewinsky to
lie this was on december 17th when at 2
a.m in the morning when the president
calls monica to tell her that she is
a witness
on the list 2 a.m in the morning
and at that time of course she's nervous
she's a witness
and
asked about well what am i going to say
and the president offers according to
monica lewinsky you can always say you
came to see betty or you came to deliver
papers
now the president's counselor attacked
this
by saying
well remember what monica said i was
never told to lie
well i would refer you to a 10th circuit
case
in which
united states versus tranakos
10th circuit 1990
and the law is that the cr request to
lie need not be a direct statement
as the court held quote the statute
prohibits elliptical suggestions as it
much as it does direct commands in quote
now that's common sense
that is logic that's what a jury applies
common sense
and here
of course in this case monica lewinsky
testified that she was told in essence
to lie now she was the president and say
monica i need you to go and lie for me
he told her
the cover story in a legal context that
she could use
that would cover for him that in essence
would be a lie we all know that
is what it is
and of course the president says well uh
he does not he denies that of course he
said i never told her to use the cover
stories in a legal context direct in
conflict but clearly the president's
counselors have not attacked that
obstruction of justice the second one
is the
jobs and the false affidavit and they
say there's absolutely no connection in
these twos none whatsoever
and of course
i pointed out the testimony of vernon
jordan
who testified it doesn't take an
einstein to know
that whenever he found out she was a
witness
she was under subpoena
that the subpoena changed the
circumstances
that's the testimony of vernon jordan so
they say there's no connection vernon
jordan the president's friend says the
circumstances change whenever you're
talking about getting a job
for with somebody who is also under
subpoena in a case that is very
important to the president of the united
states and of course the president
vernon jordan also indicated the
president's personal involvement when he
testified before the grand jury in june
he said he was interested in this matter
he referring to the president was the
source of it coming to my attention in
the first place
he further testified the president asked
me to get monica lewinsky a job the
president was personally involved in the
obtaining of a job
he was personally concerned about the
false affidavit and vernon jordan
acknowledges that when those are
combined the circumstances are different
the third area of obstruction
is a tampering with the witness betty
curry
on january 18th and january 20th where
the questions were posed after the
deposition the president's counselor
challenged this and says well
she wasn't a witness
we had even the jones lawyers never had
any clue that she was going to be a
witness in this case the president
couldn't know that she was going to be a
witness
well they hoped that we would never find
the subpoena
because he mr ruff made that statement
early on which he very professionally
expressed regret that he made that
misrepresentation
but we found the subpoena we found the
subpoena that was actually issued a few
days after the deposition for betty
curry she was a witness she was not just
a perspective witness she was there she
was
had to be ready to go and the president
knew this the jones lawyer knew it so
that stands the pillar of obstruction
stands
we
the false statements to the grand jury
that has been covered there's been never
any holes that have been poked into that
but it was to continue the cover-up of
the false statements that were made in
the civil rights case
another area of obstruction was the
december 28th when the gifts were
retrieved
and this has been challenged and i will
admit as i always have
that there is a dispute in the testimony
but i believe the case is made through
the circumstances the motivation the
testimony of monica lewinsky as to what
betty curry said when she called and the
corroborating evidence
i don't believe they have poked a hole
in that i believe it stands we would
like to hear the witnesses to make you
feel more comfortable in resolving that
conflict and determine the credibility
of those witnesses but the
gifts that were subpoenaed were evidence
in a trial
they were needed in the civil rights
case the president knew they were under
subpoena he had the most to gain and
they were retrieved and i believe the
testimony indicates that it was based
upon
the actions of betty curry
that would have been directed by the
president
there are other areas of obstruction
including the president
allowing his attorney robert bennett to
make false representations to the
federal district judge in the deposition
the president's defense is that there's
no proof whatsoever that he was paying
any attention and we offered the
videotape that shows that he is i
believe looking at the attorney but
we would offer a witness in that regard
to show that he was attentive
that's simply something that can be
substantiated and we believe that you
can evaluate that that he was paying
attention but that is an element of
obstruction because he was allowing his
attorney to make a false representation
representation to the court that was
totally untrue that would aid in the
cover-up and that was presented
answered the question
i thank the chief justice
this is a question from senator levin to
counsel for the white house
in their brief to the senate the house
manager said that there was quote no
urgency close quote to help ms lewinsky
until december 11 1997.
and that on that day quote sudden
interest was inspired close quote by a
court order which the house managers had
represented was issued on the morning of
december 11
before the vernon jordan monica lewinsky
meeting that afternoon
it took some doing yesterday to get the
house managers to finally acknowledge
that the court order was not issued in
the morning but in the afternoon of
december 11th
why were the house managers so reluctant
to make that acknowledgement
mr chief justice
well i think they were reluctant to make
the acknowledgment because they were
in cement
due to their trial brief uh which at
page 20 as the question indicates uh
said
as to this this particular time period
uh after the december 6th meeting there
was obviously there was obviously still
no urgency to help miss lewinsky
they thought that they had
a chronology
that was consistent with the inference
of causation
but when you look at the true time of
the events
that dissolves now mr manager hutchison
uh used a word a phrase i'd like to call
your attention to repeatedly as he was
summarizing the evidence he used the
phrase in essence
now that's another phrase that's kind of
a weasel word when you hear that it
means that the evidence isn't really
quite there but if you look at the big
picture maybe you can see what's there
in essence it doesn't work here it
doesn't work because of the evidence
just a week ago
mr manager hutchinson on this
obstruction of justice question was
asked very clearly
on the case that you have against the
president
on obstruction of justice not the
perjury
would you be confident of a conviction
in a criminal court and he said no i
would not
now he i'm not going to walk through
each and every
elements that he identified i think
we've repeatedly uh
dealt with them and i'm not going to
i'm not going to
kind of step on your patience to do that
again each time i would like to make two
points and that was
in terms of encouraging
ms lewinsky to lie
were these cover stories an attempt to
encourage her to lie
as i tried to indicate there is
testimony in the record
that at a certain time in the relation
these cover stories were discussed there
is not any evidence however for ms
lewinsky the president or anyone else
that these were discussed in connection
with the testimony in connection with
the affidavit you remember ms lewinsky
when asked if she could exclude that
possibility said i pretty much can
now the testimony that uh mr hutchinson
mentioned with mr jordan
on december 19th you remember he quoted
mr jordan he said the discovery of the
af the subpoena at that point changed
the circumstances
well it did but just in the opposite way
that mr manager hutchinson would have
you infer because when mr jordan
discovered on december the 19th that ms
lewinsky had a subpoena was going to
testify in the jones case as a witness
unless she could get it quashed he went
to her and went to the president to seek
assurance that the job assistance he was
engaging in could not at any time be
said to be improper because of the
presence of an improper relationship
both parties assured him that there was
no such relationship this observation by
mr jordan cuts just the opposite way
thank you
mr chief justice the chair recognizes
the majority leader mr chief justice i
do have uh another question i'll send to
the desk momentarily but i would like
for the senators to know that we've had
some 100 or 405 questions now that have
been asked i believe that's correct 104.
uh senator daschlein conferred we we
want to thank the senators for their
participation and and their their
questions we do want to make it clear
we're not seeking questions
[Laughter]
so don't feel like you need to help us
by sending any down but
under your rights as senators under the
senate resolution 16 and and the rules
we're proceeding under every and each
senator is entitled to submit a question
if he or she feels that it's important
but i hope it would be one that you
think really is essential that has not
been touched on uh somewhere already
and the answers to the questions and i
also
would hope and that the record may be
made clear that we in a bipartisan way
have
tried very hard
to make sure that this proceeding
here the question period and all that
we've done has been
fair
both to the president's council and the
house managers and we will continue to
work in that bank uh with that
observation and if we do need to
continue uh going forward with questions
we would have to give some consideration
to taking a break and going longer
although i'd indicated i'd hope we could
quit at four and maybe after this
question and if necessary one or two
more
we could end for the day and then uh get
together and see if we need more time on
monday for additional questions i send
the next question to the desk
this is a question from senators cochran
roth campbell and frist to the house
managers
the president's council has suggested
that the senate considered a good
behavior standard in impeachment cases
involving federal judges
the removal of judges seems to have been
based by the senate on the impeachment
power whose standard for removal is the
same for both federal judges and
executive branch officials
is the council for the president asking
us to use a different test for removal
of this president than we did in the
case of judge walter nixon please
explain
mr chief justice members of the senate i
appreciate the opportunity to ask this
question it is an important question and
it is true
that counsel for the president
are asking
that you use a different standard in
this case than the standard you have
already established not in just one case
but in fact in a series of cases
involving federal judges that were
before the senate
in the 1980s
there was a succession of three cases
in the senate all dealing with the
question of whether a federal judge
who had
lied under oath
should be removed from office because
the federal judge had lied under oath
in all three cases the senate decided
that the federal judge should be
convicted and removed
now the president's council have the
burden
of establishing that those
recent
and very clear precedents of the senate
should not apply
to this case where the president is
charged with lying under oath and they
attempt to do that
in a in a number of ways but i would
suggest as you evaluate their attempt
to distinguish away those precedents
that you look first and last to the
constitution the constitution should be
your guide
and i would suggest to you that there is
nothing
in the constitution which establishes a
different standard for the president for
any reason
there's not something in the
constitution that says he is subject to
a different standard because he is
elected that argument has been advanced
if you look in the constitution you
simply won't find that and to argue for
a different standard because the
president is elected
i would submit to you is to impose
something on the constitution that is
entirely alien to the document itself
the constitution contains a single
standard for the application of the
impeachment and removal power and i've
read it before but i will read it again
article 2 section 4 provides the
president
vice president and all civil officers of
the united states shall be removed from
office on impeachment for and conviction
of treason bribery or other high crimes
and misdemeanors now reference was made
in the question and reference has been
made by president the president's
council to the good behavior clause
that's found in article 3 section 1.
that clause does not alter the standard
i have just read to you however rather
than creating an altered standard for
removal of federal judges the good
behavior clause merely establishes that
the term of office for judicial officers
is live
now i wouldn't ask you to take my word
for this let me refer again
to the
1974 report by the staff of the nixon
impeachment inquiry there they said they
asked the question does article 3
section 1 of the constitution which
states that judges shall hold their
offices during good behavior limit the
relevance of the impeachments of judges
with respect to presidential impeachment
standards as has been argued by some
that is essentially the question before
the senate now
their answer was it does not
it does not
the only
impeachment provision they go on to say
discussed in the constitutional
convention and indeed in the
constitution
it's article 2 section 4 which by its
express terms applies to all civil
officers including judges now i would go
on to note that it's very interesting
that at the constitutional convention on
august the 27th
1787 an attempt was made
to amend the good behavior clause by
adding a provision for the removal of
judges by the executive on the
application
by the senate and house of
representatives now this proposal which
was offered by john dickinson was based
on the english parliamentary practice of
removal of judges by address a practice
also utilized among by several american
states under this process
judges could be removed for misconduct
falling short
of the level of seriousness that would
justify impeachment
now the proposal offered by dickinson
was overwhelmingly rejected it was
overwhelmingly rejected by the
convention
thus the sole provision for removal and
the sole standard for removal is that
which i have referred to in article 2
section 4. now mention has been made and
i want to respond to this because
mention has been made of efforts in
congress to establish a separate
procedure for the removal of federal
judges a procedure separate and apart
from the impeachment and removal process
a specific
mention has also been made of testimony
given in 1970 uh by the chief justice
who was then an assistant attorney
general regarding a proposal to
establish a separate removal procedure
the testimony
given by the chief justice at that time
related to the constitutionality of the
provisions of the bill relating to the
removal of judges by methods other than
methods other than impeachment now my
own view quite candidly is that such a
separate removal procedure raises
serious constitutional questions
serious questions about maintaining the
independence of the judiciary but
putting that question aside and
regardless of the standards that might
be applied in such a separate removal
procedure it is clear that the single
constitutional standard for impeachment
and removal would remain the same that
is what is in the constitution that
can't be changed by any statute or
anything that is set up apart from the
constitutional procedures
now
one one thing i want to make as i move
toward concluding my response
it should be recognized that some
specific acts
might be a breach of duty if done by a
judge but not a breach of duty if done
by the president of the united states
and that's an important distinction that
we all should bear in mind for example
it would be serious misconduct for a
judge to engage in repeated ex-parte
meetings with parties who have an
interest in a matter of pending before
that judge
but it is typical for the president to
engage in such ex-parte meetings with
persons who have an interest in matters
on which he will decide for a judge
such conduct constitutes a breach of
duty for the president it does not
constitute a breach of duty but
i think you've answered the question
thank you
this question from senator harkin is to
counsel for the president
there are three contradictions in the
record one who touched who on what parts
of the body
two when the relationship began
three who called whom to get the gifts
ms curry or mr lewinsky
how would these witnesses
clear up the contradictions
mr chief justice
senator harkin
um
it's difficult for me
to explain
how after you've gotten
19 interviews
to grand jury appearances at one
deposition
to cover
to cover
uh that that precise territory
that any further kind of inquiry along
those lines would be of any help the
house managers have argued that they
need to call witnesses for the purposes
of resolving inconsistencies conflicts
and discrepancies and testimony
and they have in fact identified monica
lewinsky
in particular as having given testimony
and conflict with the testimony of the
president
with betty curry and vernon jordan
but it would be well to remember that
the author that the lawyers for the
office of independent counsel
certainly not seeking to elicit
testimony that's favorable to the
president that those lawyers have
already done a great deal of this
precise kind of inquiry at some great
length
those lawyers no friends of the
president
have already explored inconsistencies
they've already tested memories they've
already laboriously and at great length
subjected these witnesses
to searching scrutiny
and their work is available for all to
see in the record of this case before
the
senate today let me be very specific and
very concrete
monica lewinsky
was interviewed by the lawyers for the
office of independent council or
testified before the grand jury
on 20 different occasions
after betty curry
and vernon jordan had given their their
testimony before the grand jury
and contrary to the assertions of the
house managers
monica lewinsky was interviewed
six times and testified twice one time
before the grand jury
and once in a sworn deposition
after the president
had given his testimony before the grand
jury
on august 17th
on
august 19th she was interviewed
by the fbi
and by lawyers for the special counsel
she testified before
the grand jury ms lewinsky testified
before the grand jury on august 20th
she was interviewed
by lawyers and
fbi agents for the independent council
on august 24th
she was interviewed on august 26th
she appeared for
a deposition held in the conference room
of the office of the independent council
on august 26th
she was interviewed pursuant to her
immunity agreement
with
independent counsel and fbi agents on
september 5th
she was also interviewed
um on sept excuse me that was september
3rd
she appeared and listened to tapes with
the fbi present
on many occasions during the period
september 3rd through september 6th
she appeared and was interviewed
by
special counsel independent council on
september 7th
and on september 5th and on september
6th
so it raises a question
as to whether or not the desire to
interview
monica lewinsky stems from a desire to
resolve conflicts that she has
with other people because certainly
these occasions
gave the lawyers for the independent
council an opportunity to do so
and i would simply submit
that
within the bounds of ethical behavior
i'm sure because i respect the
professionalism
of the house managers but
i would suspect that one of the reasons
they want to
inquire of ms lewinsky is not to resolve
discrepancies and disputes
it is to perhaps challenge your
testimony when it's helpful to the
president
and perhaps
bolster her testimony
when it's not helpful to the president
the count the
house managers are not neutral
investigators or neutral interrogators
and
it raises questions about what the
manager's true purpose is in calling
vernon jordan
and betty curry ford as witnesses what
they want to
inquire about if they conduct an
interview of them
and i suggest that this is also
a bit of a fishing expedition looking
for evidence
that will be damaging to the president
we're not afraid of witnesses
but we do want fairness
and we don't think it's fair
in this process
uh if you're going to have a real trial
then we want to have a real defense
and to have a real defense
requires real discovery and real
opportunity to have access to documents
and witnesses and evidence that has been
in the custody
and the control
of the house of representatives that has
not been made available to us that is in
the custody and control of the office of
independent council that has not been
made available to us
and i would suggest as we've seen from
the statements made by the managers to
this body yesterday and today about
vernon jordan suggesting
actually suggesting that he did not tell
the truth when he testified numerous
times before the grand jury which is an
outrageous suggestion
as suggesting which happened today
implying that he destroyed evidence
which not even the independent council
has suggested
they seek to do nothing more than to
attack attack attack
the best friend of the united states the
president of the united states and his
personal secretary that's the reason
they want to talk to these people
and i think it's an improper reason
it's wanting to win
too much
and i don't think the united states
senate should be part of it
[Applause]
this question is from senators hegel
abraham and hatch to the house managers
white house counsels indicated their
opposition to calling witnesses
asserting that calling witnesses would
not shed light on the facts and would
unnecessarily prolong the proceedings
but it is the responsibility of the
senate to find the truth and if any
senators reasonably believe that hearing
witnesses would assist in finding the
truth
why shouldn't they be called
mr chief justice
me thinks thou dost protest too much
and i think that's what white house
counsel's been doing i don't know why
but they frankly don't want witnesses
they don't want what you normally have
in a trial we can paint this with any
kind of colors that you want to have
but a trial without witnesses when it
involves a criminal accusation a
criminal matter
is not a true trial
it really isn't i mean it's it is not
what i think of and i guarantee it's not
what any of my friends who sit over here
who've been councils and prosecutors and
defense lawyers think of
it is remotely conceivable but certainly
not where you have had the inferences
and the conclusions that we draw
logically from the entire sequence of
events that are painted from the very
day when the president got word of
monica lewinsky being on the witness
list and all the way through his
testimony in the jones case all the way
through his grand jury testimony when
they challenge every inference that we
think you should logically draw from the
record and then suggest that oh but we
shouldn't have anybody in here so you
who are going to judge ultimately
whether our representations and persua
are persuasive or not about those
inferences whether you should be able to
judge and i think you should
what the witnesses actually
are saying are you let's give you just
one illustration and i'll yield any of
my other councils on this i don't know
how many times i think two or three
times i've put up here on a board or
i've said to you and i know a couple of
my colleagues have said to you
that during the discussion
with regard
to the affidavit that monica lewinsky
had in front of the grand jury
she explicitly said no the president
didn't tell me to lie but he didn't
discourage me either he didn't encourage
me nor discourage me
but you need to have her say that to you
i mean they've been up here whacking
away at that they've been confusing
everything they can talking about the
job search at the same time they're
talking about the affidavit what she
said here what she said there what she
said anywhere else witnesses are a
logical thing
there are a lot of conflicts that are
here we when we get to the point which
we presume we'll get that opportunity to
do to argue our case on why we should
have witnesses in a maybe monday or
perhaps tuesday i think under your rules
even though you have a motion to dismiss
we'll get that chance
we'll lay out a lot of these things
there are a lot of them out there but
the point is overall we you need to have
the witnesses
to judge what any trier of fact judges
about any one of these and i'd be happy
to yield to mr graham or mr rogan if
you'd like to come up here
neither one that's fair enough but
that's why you need witnesses
the chair recognizes the majority leader
mr chief justice uh
it now approaches the hour that we'd
indicated that we would conclude
our work on saturday
there may still be some questions that
senators would like to have offered
i've talked to senator daschle one
suggestion has been made is maybe we
would on monday ask that questions could
be submitted for the record in writing i
think that's a common practice but i
don't we don't want to cut it off and at
this point i wouldn't be prepared to do
that
but i would like to suggest that we go
ahead and conclude our business today
and if there is a need by a senator on
either side to have another question or
two or three we would certainly consult
with each other and see how we could
handle that perhaps on monday and even
to see if it would be appropriate to
prepare a motion with regard to being
able to submit questions for the record
which would be answered we wouldn't want
to abuse that and cause that to be a
protracted process
but in view of the time it's been sp
spent here in fact we've had around 106
questions and we've got about 10 hours
in this now uh i i think we should
conclude for this saturday we will
resume at 1 pm on monday and continue in
coordinates with provisions of s rest16
i will update all members as to the
specific question or schedule when it
becomes clear i now ask unanimous
consent that uh in the record following
today's proceedings there appear a
period of morning business to
accommodate bills and statements that
have been submitted during the day by
senators i i
for their intentive attentiveness during
the proceedings and asked the
senate standing in german under the
previous order i object i object
this is a motion to adjourn
uh the motion the question is on the
motion to adjourn
all in favor say aye
those opposed no
no
the eyes appear to have it
the eyes do have it
senators adjourn
[Music]
the eighth day of the impeachment trial
of the president of the united states
now concluded the second day of
questioning by senators of house
managers and white house counsel
we have several cameras around capitol
hill we're going to be showing you as we
open our phone lines showing you live
events as they happen
generally each day senators have
something to say afterwards one of the
cameras we have is just off the senate
floor this is an area referred to as the
ohio clock area of the capitol we may
see some senators coming there we have a
camera that's outside the capital if
senators are coming